This comprehensive course is for absolute
beginners, and will teach you back end web
development with Python. You will learn the
basics of Python and Django and create a few
projects along the way. Tommy has created
many popular courses, both on his own channel
and on the Free Code Camp channel. Hey guys,
welcome to this back end web development course
with Python. In this course, we're going to
be learning everything you need to know to
start your web development journey with Python.
Let's take a quick look at the agenda of this
video. First, we will start from learning
Python, which is a programming language we're
going to use in this video. In the Python
tutorial, there'll be lots of exercises in
which we're going to do together just to get
comfortable with the Python programming language.
Once we are familiar with Python, we will
move straight into Django. Now Django is a
Python framework, which is used for building
server side web applications. In the Django
tutorial, we will learn all the concepts you
need to know while getting started into January.
After that, we're gonna build three different
projects using Django. The project we're gonna
do a blog application, a weather detector
program, and a real time chat application
using Django. We're gonna build out this project
so you get familiar with building your own
project in jungle. After that, you are going
to get introduced into API's with Django,
you will learn how you can view the rest API's
in Django using the Django rest framework.
And I hope that after this video, you'll be
comfortable with building your server side
web applications using Django. Now, I have
some free resources like a Django roadmap
Python data structure cheat sheet, a Django
cheat sheets are plenty more free resources
in which are compiled into a PDF. And you
can download a PDF for free using the link
in the description below. And if you like
more tutorials like this, you can also check
out my own channel at COVID told me where
I teach more Python and web development in
general. Now have you noticed that let's dive
straight into this video. This tutorial is
a bite of food because we are going to be
learning python programming from scratch.
So this is a list of everything we're going
to be talking about in this video. So let
me give a brief introduction to Python. So
Python is one of the fastest growing programming
languages in the world. with Python, you can
go into various fields like machine learning
and AI, web development, and plenty others.
So take into lambda scores and easy to learn
Python with a very good decision for your
programming journey. So without wasting any
time, let's get straight into the tutorial.
Right here, I'm just on my browser. So we're
gonna download Python on our laptop. So to
do this, I'm just gonna search for download
Python for Windows since I'm on a Windows,
and I'm going to click on the first link.
And then right here, I see download Python
3.9 point one, which is the latest version.
So we're just going to click on it. And then
you can see that it downloaded it automatically.
So I already have Python downloaded. Now what
I just need to do is to install it, I'm just
gonna come into where I saved it. And then
I'm going to run it. So make sure that when
you're installing Python, you must stick this
out Python to path. If not, you're just going
to make it more complex. And it's supposed
to be for you. So let's click install now.
Yes. And so this is just going to install
Python on our machine. It should take a few
minutes, a couple of minutes to install. And
I'm going to be back when it's installed finish.
So right now the setup was successful. So
as you can see, the installation has been
done. So I can just click on Close. Now for
me to confirm evolve Python installed, I'm
going to open up my command prompt. So here
in my command prompt, I'm just going to type
Python. Once I type it, you should open up
this show. You might not understand what all
this is now. But this is just to verify if
Python was truly installed. So now that we
know we have Python installed, let's just
go ahead and install our code editor. So Python
is the programming language. But we are going
to code we are going to program everything
or the Python we're going to do is going to
be in a code editor. And there are various
code editors out there. We have Visual Studio
code, we have pi charm, we have Sublime Text,
we have atom. There are counselors out there,
but for this tutorial, we are going to be
using Visual Studio code. So let's go ahead
and download it. So I can close up my command
prompt right now. So let me just say if you
don't know how to get your command prompt
You can just search for it on your Windows
search bar. So right here, we can just go
back to Google. And then we can search for,
let's say download Visual Studio code. And
I'll just click on the first one. So since
I'm on a Windows, I'm going to download the
one for Windows. If you're on Ubuntu or Linux,
or Mac, download the one for your OS. So right
now you can see that it is downloading. So
I already have it downloaded on my PC, I'm
just going to cancel that since I already
have it downloaded. Let me just show you the
installation process. So right here, I have
it downloaded already, we just click on Enter
does to run it. So what it tells me here is
that setup has detected the Visual Studio
code is running. So this simply means that
I already have Visual Studio Code installed
on my computer. So I'm just going to press
Cancel. But for you, as a beginner, you want
to install this as a new software. So when
we already have this installed, by just going
to open up our Visual Studio code, and this
is what it should look like once you first
open it up. So now we have everything set
up. We downloaded Python and installed it.
And then we downloaded Visual Studio code
and installed it. Now we can go straight into
coding. So now that we have everything stored,
what we just want to do is to create a new
file in this file is where we're going to
code all our Python. So in Visual Studio,
good weather is going to come into the toolbar,
and click on new file. So once we click on
new file, you can see it automatically as
this untitled name, but I want to save it
by pressing Ctrl S. And I'm just going to
save it. First of all, let me say all files
are there now to save it as up dot p y. So
the name of the file is up. But at the bottom
of the file extension, I used dot p y. So
anytime we're working with Python, anytime
module, create a new Python file, it must
always have the extension dot p y does will
make whatever we are running on know that
we are using a Python file. So now once I
save it is updated here. And as you can see,
Visual Studio Code automatically detects the
logo of Python now does how to save grades
and save a new Python file. So this is basically
how everything looks like in Visual Studio
code. On the left hand bar, we have four bar
does we if we open in a folder, this is where
we're gonna see all the files and folders
in there. We have this search this GitHub.
We don't need to bother about that for now.
But this is our Visual Studio code looks like.
So since we have everything we know how to
create a new file, what we want to talk about
now is the print function. So in Python, we
have some built in functions, that means some
things that already done automatically, which
we don't need to write too much of code. Now
let's say we just want to print us text to
the screen. Like we just want to show a user
like a Hello World or welcome, we're gonna
use the print function, it is going to bring
some basic text to the screen. Now first,
to do this, we're going to say print, and
then we're going to open parentheses. And
then we can use single quotes. Or we can also
use double quotes. There is no problem here
in Python. But we can just go with single
quotes. So you can just pick one and go with
that. So in this codes, I'm going to write
my text like I say, Hello World. Now as you
can see, I have printed hello world. And I
must make sure I save this file. And then
for me to run this Python file for me to see
the output of my code, I'm going to have to
come to the right hand corner right here and
click on Run. Now once I click on Run, you
see that it opens a new terminal automatically.
And our code is going to be run in this terminal.
So if we just wait a second, we're going to
see the output of this good. You can see right
here that we have a little word automatically
prints hello world. If I say hello world,
welcome. And I run it you see it changes and
it says hello world welcome. So does how to
run a Python file. Now let's talk about some
more features about this print function. Now,
let's say we want to prints on a new line.
Hello world, I wanted to welcome to be on
another line, we can easily do that, we can
just remove these. And then on a new line
by just going to print welcome exactly the
same thing. Now once I run it, you can see
says a logo down yet, and it says welcome,
so does how to print on a new line, we can
also do a lot of things, let's say we want
to add another value to this hello world.
Like, let's print a sentence, let's say my
name is told me. And then I want to say my
age is then I can add a comma right here and
say 100. So this will automatically tell Python
that this is a number, and is no more a string,
just a normal kurata. So now once I run it,
you're gonna see it says My name is Tony,
my name is Andre, with no arrows. And automatically
you see the leaves a space right here, right
here, we didn't leave a space, by automatically
once we put this number year, it leaves a
space to clarify that if I put don't leave
no space, and I run it, you see that the spaces
to do. So that's just a smart feature of Python.
So I think that's gonna be all for the brains
function. Now let's talk about variables in
Python. As you can see, I have three prints
function. The first one says Tim is a boy.
The second one says team is 18. And the third
one says team is from Turkey. So as you can
see, in the three print functions, I'm repeating
team three times. Now we can use variables
instead of repeating a particular text. Now
variables are just basically saving a data
in the memory of Python. And then we can get
that data back by referencing its name. So
let's see this in action. Let's say above
the code, I have a variable named name. So
this name is the name of the variable. And
I'm seeing equals two, I put single quotes,
and the name is theme. So name is the name
of the variable. And theme is the value assigned
to this name. So like these, we've saved this
variable up here. So we can print that we
also say print. Whenever we are printing a
variable, we don't put quotes like we do when
we are printing a normal string. So we can
remove the quotes and just type the name of
the variable which is name. So now when I
run these, you are going to see it prints
all these. And on the fourth line, a print
team. It didn't print name. Now this is what
variable is impulse is just basically saving
a particular data and then referencing it
drew the variable name. So now instead of
saying the same three times, we can just replace
this team with name. And for us to do this
right here you see we printed only the variable.
And we didn't have quotes. We're right here,
we're printing a string with quotes. And we
also want to print the variable with it. So
this is called concatenation. We're gonna
join the variable and the normal string together.
To do these. Let's remove theme. And we're
going to say name, which is the name of the
variable plus the remaining text. Now what
is the name plus is a boy is going to print
us theme is a boy. So we can also do the same
right here. We just simply remove theme, I
would say name plus is 18. We do the same
for the third line, we'll say name. Plus is
from Turkey. Now once we print this, you can
see it says theme is a boy Tim is 18. Tim
is from Turkey. Well rightio said name. So
that's what variable is about. So let's just
type CLS closes up. But variable is more broad
than just this. So there's something we call
data types. Now as you can see, this is just
sim sim is letter is a corrector. And that
is a string. So strings are basically just
characters. Now, string is a data type. We
have if this is a number like 23 is no more
a string is now an integer. We have Boolean
which is for true or false values and oh This
before this tutorial was going to be particular
about maybe two or three. So now, let me just
undo that. Let me specify a new variable and
name it age. Now this variable, I want it
to be the age. Let's give it a team. So whenever
we are using an integer or number, we don't
add code when we are assigning the variable.
You see right here, we added codes, and inside
our code we put team, but for it to be an
integer, you will see that we do not add codes.
If I over on these, you see dices 18 is i
n t, which stands for integer and then seem
right here is a string. So now we can just
join these by saying plus H. Now once we print
that is still gonna give us Okay, so you can
see now that this is can only concatenate
string, not integer. So now there is a problem
with Python. Anytime I want to concatenate
a string with a variable, it doesn't, I mean,
an integer with a string, it doesn't work.
So we can just solve this instead of using
this, we can say comma H. Once we press this,
you can see it says theme is from Turkey.
So let me close this up. Right here, we can
see anytime we're concatenating we just drink
it's possible. But when we are dealing with
an integer, we can't use this plus, we have
to use comma. And we can also use comma, we're
concatenating with a string also. So this
is the two things, we can use additional sign
with only string. And then we can use comma
with string an integer. So if I run it is
to go to work theme is a theme that does basically
out to concatenate and join strings with variables.
Now we're gonna be talking more about strings.
So strings are just plain text. So if I print
something like print, alright, this is a string,
string, or just plain text. Now we're going
to talk more about the features of strings,
different things you can do with strings.
Now let's say I say I put a full stop. Oh,
you know, once I run this, you see that it
runs it on the same line, which is I will
you wave, I want this to be on another line
without being put in another print function,
I can just simply we use a backslash n. This
is a backslash n. Now this is gonna automatically
take these to a new line, it's just like a
break, it's going to add a break in between
these and these. So now once I run it, you're
gonna see he says, I, our you will have this
piece here because of this, if I can Sadat
and I run it again, you're gonna see we have
I owe you. So with also prints drink as a
variable. So let's see we have something named
name, and the name is Tim. So this is a string
is a variable, both a string type of variable.
And then in print function, we also print
that string variable by just saying print
name, without quotes. Once you print it, you're
gonna see right here we have seen printed
visuals close this up. So if we come up here,
we can also print let's say we want to add
a double quotes or single quotes. Now you
know we can add a single quotes in between
our text does because Python is going to see
this like we want to close on this prints
text. So first we'll add the double quotes
we can just easily add the bus slash then
the quotes now once you have a blog slash,
and that's good, this court is going to print
it as I run it, you see now we have I with
this good hour you so if you want to create
special characters, we use the backslash,
or you can just bring the backslash alone
is gonna work. So you can see the backslash
is there. So we can print. Use them. Last
crash to break to make it on a new line, because
there is a backslash to add a quote. And then
we can bring the bus slash just like that.
Now let me talk to you about special functions
on strings. So functions in Python is just
a block of code, which does a particular task.
So in this string string gets a lot of function,
which does different things. Let's say we
want to convert all the characters in this
to uppercase, we can use a string function,
we want to check if it's lowercase, or once
we get on to the first letter, or the second,
those are functions in Python. So now, we
can just say want to get only the first letter.
Now once we get the first letter, we can just
easily do something like print name, square
brackets, and zero. Now zero represent the
first letter, if I say one, it represents
the second letter, if I said to represent
the third letter. So in Python, or in programming,
in general, numbers start counting from zero.
So once I put zero and then run it, down here,
you see it prints only t. Now let me run to
which is the third one, you see, it's prints
only M. And if I run what is not there, like
0122, I try to run theory is going to give
us an error, index error. So you can see string
index out of range, which means it's not present.
Now it also do multiple things. Let's say
we want to convert these all to uppercase,
we can just do name Dodd's case. Now once
we run this, it says as no attributes or by
case, so sometimes we can run into error,
we just change it. So I think is because there
is no supposed to be case. So named oppa is
the function that changes it to uppercase.
So once I run it, you see now that we have
seen in uppercase, we can also do the same
thing with lower, we just say named or lower,
and then we run it, now you can see that everything
is being changed to a lower case. Now once
we come back here, we can also check if everything
which is present here is uppercase, or if
all the characters are lowercase. So for us
to do that, we're just gonna say name.is,
lower. So as I run it, you see it says false,
so it's going to give me a true or false response.
If everything is upper case, it's going to
give me false, but it's lower is going to
give me true. So you can see, since there
is an upper case t, I asked if it's lower,
and it says false. But if I ask if it is upper,
I run it. If this is false, that's simply
because this upper case and lower case, not
everything is upper or lower. But if I change
it to a lower case, let me change everything
to upper m, and then I run it because the
nicest true, because everything is uppercase,
and they will also join different functions
together. Now you can see if I say something
like is lower, and I run it, it says false.
But I can first of all, convert it to lowercase,
then ask if it's lower, so I can do that lower.
And then run. You see now it says true. What
is upper case. So first of all, it says named
don't lower, which means converted to lowercase,
then it checks if is lowercase, which gives
us true. So that's basically how to just join
different or add different functions together.
Along with also do something else by let's
say we want to get the amount of characters
we have in this variable. To do the arts,
we can say Len, then we open a bracket and
close it. When we run these, you can see it
gives us three because we have 123 if I have
a lot, and then I run it is going to give
me a team the number which we have in the
so that's how to get the length of a string.
But let me just undo that. But let's say we
want to find where at particular text ease.
So this is i less than want to get the index
number of I, as we know this is zero, and
one. So this i is index number is one, if
we want to get it, we're just going to say,
Len by going to remove Len. So I'm gonna say
name, dot index. And then we're gonna say
I, so now he's gonna print me one, because
as the index number of I, once I run it, you
see, it's prints me one, which is the index
number. Now, let's say we want to replace
a text, let's say we have m want to replace
it with C. So we can easily do that. We're
just gonna say his name, the Replace, I'm
gonna open a bracket, Bertha parenthesis,
then the techs to replace will not replace
m are gonna put M. And then what we just want
to do is comma, and then what want to replace
it with want to replace it with C. So now,
once I run these, you can see it's printed,
see it. So that is replacing this m with T
code, that's basically how to replace. So
there are also a lot of functions, a lot of
string functions. But these are just shown,
I showed you how to use them. So that's gonna
be all for strings. In this part, we're going
to be talking about numbers in Python. So
to print a number in Python is pretty easy.
We just type print, and then we just go ahead
and type the number 78. Now once we just run
it, you'll see that it prints 78. So we don't
need to add any syntax or anything, we just
print 78. And it gives us 78. Now we also
specify a number, the variable can say, No,
the number is equal to 79. We just write the
letter, we don't need to add these. And then
we can print number. So once you run it, it
gives us 78 and 79. Now we can also add numbers.
So let me just remove this. So instead of
just printing 78, we can print 78 plus 22.
Now we got add a number, we can perform arithmetic
operations. Once I run it, you see that it
gives me 100, it automatically adds these
two numbers or integers together, and then
it runs it. I also try these with a decimal
number is 2.7 days. Then once I run it, you'll
see it gives me 100.9 34. So that is how numbers
work. And we'll also test it out with the
subtraction. Says gives us 55.066. And then
we can test it out with the division gives
us the answer. And then we can also test it
out with the multiplication. When we run it,
it gives us the answer. So that's basically
basic arithmetic operation with Python, we
can go further just what we did with strings,
we can go further and use the beauty number
functions. So let's say I want to show the
remainder of a division. So let's say something
like 20 divided by six. Now you know that
this will give us three remainder two. So
gonna give us three remainder of these. Well,
what we would just only want to get the remainder,
we don't want to get the main answer, we can
just do 20 percentage sign six, as I run it,
you see gives me two which is the remainder.
Now does how to get the remainder of a division
will also convert a number to a string. Now
let me show you. Let's say we have this variable.
We have a variable named number equals to
55. You can see that is a number an integer
right here. Then I can specify a new variable,
I can name it number two, and I want this
number to be a string. So I'm going to say
this drink of number variable. So now, if
I over on this number two, you're going to
see that as a string, when I print number
two is going to be 55. But now we just shrink
55 also boys a string. So how do we know if
it's really a string? Remember that when concatenating
yukako calcination numbers, wake up caucus
needs restring. So let's try to concatenate.
So right here, let's see. Number is, let's
try to call continue with the main number.
So let's say add number. Let's run it, you
see, it gives us an error can only call cause
in a string, not integer. So but now that
we've converted it, this try to calcagni with
non to, once we run it, you see that gives
us number is 55. So that's to show that it
has converted that integer or that number
to a string. Now Python sees that as a string,
this is also very useful in a lot of cases.
So does that. And then we can also get the
absolute value of a number. So let's say let's
just cancel this, let's print minus five.
Now, obviously, when we print, this should
give us minus five, as you can see down here,
and just closes up. What if I wanted to print
only five regardless of the sign, if it's
positive or negative, I'm going to add a b
s. Now this is a function is a number function,
as I explained earlier, function is just a
block of a block of code, which does a particular
task. Now we can write a function manually
by itself. But Python has some built in function,
which you can automatically use. That's why
when we use abs, it automatically sees it
as a Python function. Now this ABS means absolute
does the full meaning of ABS, so we're going
to get the absolute value of this number.
Now when I run it, you see it prints only
five, regardless of this negative sign beside
it. So we have four and two. So now you know
that four is obviously greater than two. So
once I print these is going to give me four,
this is showing the is number of DS. So that
means for resupport to or not for is for us
to serve. This means we have these two numbers,
Max was going to get the highest number. So
let's say we have another number named three,
once I run it is to print four, because four
is greater than all of these for now what
if I have 16 once I run it, it gives me 16.
Because 16 is the highest number in this range
of numbers, I can also do the same to get
the minimum amount of numbers, I can say m
i n, so that is going to automatically print
true because as the minimum so once I run
it, you see it brings two so that's the basic
way of getting the maximum and the minimum
and then it goes around in number two. So
we can estimate a number. So you know, in
normal mathematics, if we have something like
3.2 this is estimated to three, but if we
have something like 3.5 this is estimated
to four we can also do this year in Python.
Suppose To do this we just a round the round
3.2 is gonna give us three was we round 3.5
is gonna give us for just normal estimation,
rounding off to a number. And then we also
have one, which is been let's see beam. So
what this being does is that it converts a
particular number to a binary string. Now
if you know binary numbers is this weird type
of text. So each number as is binary strings
zeros it gets the binary string of a number
Just run it, and it prints this. Now let's
run something like 334. It prints the binary
string for 334. Now, that is some basic functions.
But they are countless functions for countless
number functions. So all these, we're not
able to assess them, because we are able to
assess them because they're already built
in Python. But there are still more that we
can't assess. Except we input. Now there's
something in Python called inputs. Now we
have more number functions, the one that is
able to find the square root, the one that
can get the power, various countless. So now
the reason why we can't access those one,
because we haven't imported, the ones I just
show you, we can use them without importing.
But the ones I want to show you now we need
to import them from the Python mat function
before we can use it. So first to import,
we're going to say from math, something like
this. import all voiceover writing Oh, right,
esoteric. So what this is doing is saying
from the maths class, or the math function,
import everything which is there. Now in this
maths class of fine john, it might, they might
be the one that can find square roots, they
might be the one that can find the power,
everything. So we don't know the one we want
yet. So we're just importing everything with
this asterik. So now we're going since we
have this imported, we can find the square
roots. Now, we can just see square roots of
let's do something like Andre. Now once we
run this, it will give us 10. As you can see,
give us 10. Today, this point 00 K, but now
it gives us 10. So that's gonna be all about
working with numbers. So in this part, we're
gonna be getting users input. So what we're
going to be doing is to tell a user to input
a text, and then we're gonna save that text
in a variable. And then we're going to tell
the user what input. So let's go ahead and
protocolized that. So to use our inputs in
Python is pretty easy. We're just gonna say
inputs, then open and close parentheses. Now,
when is open or close parentheses, we're gonna
ask the user what we want him to input. So
we're going to put double quotes. And in that
code, we're going to say something like input
your name. So now this is going to tell the
user to input your name. And then once the
user type in something like theme, or Tommy
or john, anything users type, we want to save
it in this variable called name. So now this
variable called name is going to be the input.
So now let's try that we run it. You see now,
the first thing he says is input your name.
Let me say to me, when I click enter, so nothing
happened. What does how to use our input today,
just close, we can come back here and just
simply print to the user. Name. So let's run
it. What is our input name? unsafe, Tim, you
see the eye just prints team. So we can make
this more interactive by asking for the user's
name. And maybe asking for the user's age
and then telling the user Your name is this
and your age is this. So we have we need to
have two variables. Second, the age. So name
equals input your name and then age will be
equals input your age. So what we want to
print is, your name is and they just want
to add the name and they will close that.
And they will say and you the age, years boat.
Now when we run these, it says input your
name. Let me see Joan, and is 105 years old.
So he says Your name is john, and you are
105 years old. So this is basically how to
just collect simple data from the user. And
then use it the way you want tell the user,
your name is this your ages this. So this
is the basic concept. You can also link it
with how they do websites, like when you create
a signup to a website. And then they saved
your name, your email and everything in the
database. And they later Do you welcome john
are welcome, whatever your name is. So just
to link that concept is basically just getting
the user inputs, and then storing it as a
variable, in this case as a data, and then
we can print it to the user back. So does,
too. All you need to know about getting user's
input will also make it more fun. Now, when
we get user input, you can see that the age
is seen as drink, right, the Ice Age is string,
but we want the age to be integer. So we can
convert this string into an integer. So for
us to do this, we're going to say i n t, we
open the bracket, and then we close the bracket.
So everything is inside this integer function.
If I come back here, you see now that this
has been changed to integer normal strings.
But now if we try to run these inputs, my
name, I input a random age, you can now see
it gives us this error can only concatenate
strings, not integer. So for us to be able
to add age, you know what we need to do, we
need to either convert it to a string, which
we know what to do. Or we can just use a comma.
So let's just remove this. And then let's
run it. So let's input a random age right
here. random name, and age. So now you see
it works. It says Your name is john on your
13 now does how to basically just get user
input, use it how you want, and then you can
pass that information back to the user. In
this part, we're gonna be doing a simple Python
exercise. So what we're going to be doing
is a simple world replacement program. So
what is going to be happening is that a user
is going to input a sentence. And then let's
say you want to change a word in that sentence
or change something in that sentence, then
we're going to allow the user to be able to
do this. So if a user inputs A sentence, like
I am a boy, and he later wants to change our
boy to let's say, a guy or something else.
So that's what we simply want to do. So I'm
going to ask the user for three inputs, the
first input will be the sentence, the second
input is going to be what do you want to change,
and then the total input is what do you want
to replace it with. So let's get that on protocolized
it. Now the first thing we're going to do
is just to have those variables. So let's
have a variable named sentence. And I want
this variable to be an input. And then I'll
just say, and your sentence. Now, let me just
print the sentence to the user. Let's run
it. Now let's say the sentence I am a boy.
And he just simply prints that sentence. We're
gonna come back here, let's just say your,
your sentence is I am a boy, which is going
to be whatever the user writes. So then, what
we now want to do is to have another variable,
let's say what one should be an input. Now
this variable is the word you use that wants
to remove or replace. And then we can say,
and word to replace. Let's say the word to
replace. And then once we have that is going
to be stored in this variable named word one.
They're also going to have another way, let
me work through. This is going to be, what
do you want to replace it with. So let's enter
the word to replace it with. So now once we
have all this, we're just going to print sentence
dot replace. That means we want to replace
this with this open bracket to take two inputs,
which is word one, the word wants to replace,
and then word two, what we want to replace
it with. So what this is doing is that, let's
say we have a sentence named I am a boy, then
this word one is the boy wants to change,
and then we're two it was one to replace it
with. So let's just go ahead and test it.
So right here is running. Okay, it gives us
invalid syntax. That's because we forgot to
add a plus right here. Now let's do that again.
Right here, you can see says enter your sentence.
Now let me say I am a boy, now is bring to
us your sentences, I am a boy. And it says
enter the word to replace so I want to replace
this boy and enter the word to replace it
with or to replace it with dude. Now you see
it's print, I am a dude. So that's basically
how to do a simple word replacement exercise.
It takes in an input, which is a sentence,
and then it takes another inputs, which is
what want to replace. And then the third one
is what wants to replace it with. And then
it's basically just printed out to the screen.
So I hope you understand what to do with deed
in this part. If you didn't, you can just
go back and watch this part again, and make
sure you understand before moving to the next
one. So in this part, we're going to be talking
about working with lists in Python. So when
you're working in Python, you're going to
be dealing with a lot of data, or you want
to be able to know how to feed your data into
a list. So the list in Python is basically
just a list of different attributes of different
values fixed into a value. So let's just dive
straight into the protocol. Now to define
a lease is similar to define a variable. So
we can just give it a name of a lease, let's
say, a list of countries, and I can name the
list of countries. And I'll just use the equal
sign and the square brackets. When we're defining
lists, we need to use a square bracket, I
cannot give you some inputs like United Kingdom.
I can also give it another lease like xe,
Ghana, let me say Nigeria, let me give it
one more value. And I can see Australia. So
now this lists a list variable, it has four
values. So now once I print the list like
this, I'll just say print. And I give it countries,
which is the least you see that he just brings
me the old list the way it is right here.
So that basically the main thing you need
to know when to find the list. By list is
more broad than this, there are a lot we can
do with lists, like lists, I just want to
get the first attributes. Now each list has
the index number, like this is 0123. And so
on, just the way I said earlier in this tutorial
that in Python or in programming, General,
numbers are counting from zero. So the index
number of this value is 0123 is just similar
to when we have a variable, let's say we have
a variable named name. And we have to me so
these as an index of 0123. Now that's very
similar to at least each value as an index
of 0123. Now we can just delete that. Now
let's say we only want to print these we don't
want to print the whole list. I can just do
it like these countries with square brackets
and are fixing the index number in between
those square brackets. Now when I run these
you see now and that is brings me only United
Kingdom. I can also do the same thing. Let's
see how to print Nigeria. I give it to I run
it now you see Do you have Nigeria, there
are a lot of things we can do. Now, let's
say once we get this, we just want to bring
only n from it, we can also do that. So other
thing country's index number two, we can specify
the index numbers in zero. So once I run it,
you see it Sprint's me and now what does this
mean? It says countries gets the value with
the index number 2012. So now it has Nigeria.
And then I say from that Nigeria gets me the
one with the index numbers zero. And then
we see in Nigeria, n as index numbers zero.
So that's basically I'll just add some simple
things in Python, Python lists. Now let's
say we just want to get only all the lists
from Ghana to the end, we don't want to add
United Kingdom, or we just want to get the
list from Nigeria to the end, we can also
do that. So we just say countries want to
get from Ghana to the end, we can just say,
our square bracket, one and a column. Now
this is going to get everything from index
number one to the end. Now let me show we
close this. When I run it. You see now it
gives me the list without United Kingdom does
lt just get it from a particular index number
to the end, we can also do the same thing
we can see from to use it again, from Nigeria
to Australia, right here, Nigeria, and Australia.
Now I also specify a range. Let's say I only
want to get the list from one to two. Okay,
let me add one more value year, let me say
New Zealand. Yeah, so right here, I say New
Zealand. And this is 01234. Let's say I only
want to get from one to three, I don't want
the last one. And I don't want these, I can
easily do that, let's say from one, which
is from Ghana, index number one, that after
the column, I'll say three. So 123. As I run
that, you see our K, it gives me Ghana and
Nigeria. So this is 0123. Okay, so let's say
two, four. I, when I run this, it gives me
Ghana, Nigeria, and Australia. So it gives
me from here all the way to three. So this
is basically going to get from one which we
started to the one before which we end. So
does how to do that in Python. And then we
also get the type of the list. Now if I print
something like type countries. Now it's going
to print to me that this is a list down here.
So let me just type CLS to clear everything
I've done. Now let me print it, you see says
class lists. So this is showing me that this
variable type is a list. Now it is just a
normal variable as a string variable is also
going to show me that it is a string. Now
let's try that. Let's just divert from least
for a second. Let's say we have name. So me
and I said that type of name. When I run it,
you see down here it says a string. If I change
these to 12 you will see down here it says
integer so does how to get a type of a particular
value. So those are we know now that this
is a list variable. Now I can just simply
delete that. And then let's say I want to
change the value of one value in this list.
Now let's say I want to change this from United
Kingdom to United States. So what I'm just
going to do is just say, countries zero because
the index number of United Kingdom is zero
should now be equals to United States. And
then let me just add a print maybe print countries
now when I print countries Okay, you see name
is not defined as because we've removed this
very good I was gardening. So let's just remove
this line. I run it again. You see now the
first value is now United States. Meanwhile,
his United Kingdom right here, but that's
simply because we change it. The United States
here can also do it again, let's say we want
to change Australia, which is the third, we'll
say, three, unless they want to change Australia
to a country like Canada. When I run it, you
see, we have the United States, Ghana, Nigeria,
we don't have Australia, again, is not Canada,
then we have New Zealand. So that's how to
change a particular value in our list. Now,
let's say we want to get only the end of this
list. You know, we can also get it by just
let me just quickly delete all this, we can
get New Zealand by just typing countries,
which is index number, which is 01234, New
Zealand index number is four by type four,
and run it, it gives me New Zealand. But I
also do it in another way. Now if I add a
negative sign right here, let me delete these.
And I say one. Now this is going to get the
least from the last value in that list. Now
if I run this, you see it gives me New Zealand,
if I see minus two minus two is obviously
Australia. By run this now, you see we have
Australia. So note that when you're using
a negative sign, it gets you that list from
the last from the bottom, basically. But you
notice that from the beginning, we use zero
for the first, and then we'll get started
for the last we use minus one. Yeah, that's
because as we know, in normal math, zero is
neither negative nor positive. So when we
start from the back, we use minus one, not
minus zero. So we start from the front is
zero, we start from the back, it's minus one,
so does how to basically use that. Now there
are also a lot of other things we can do with
list, like we can get the length of this list,
let's say want to get how many values we have
in this list, because most of the times you
have large amount of data can start counting
them one by one like these. But you can just
say le n countries, which is the name of the
list. Now once I run it, you see gives me
five, which is because I have five values
in here. But note that when it gives me the
answer, it doesn't use me based on index value.
Now index value is just like the ID assigned
to each of these values right here. But when
I calculate the length, it gives me the actual
amount we are via which is five variables
are calculated from the index number into
before, I hope you understand that, we can
also do some other things like in the list.
As you can see, all of these are strings.
Now instead of printing strings, let me just
delete this New Zealand. Instead of printing
only strings, I can change, let's say this
Ghana, I can change it to a number like two.
So now we have the string, we have an integer,
if I print these, okay, this gives me four.
So let me remove length. Once I print these,
you see, it gives me what I want to see, if
I bring the index number of these, which is
one. And I press run, it gives me two. So
we can mix different data types in a list.
I can also change this Nigeria to true, which
is a boolean value. Once I run it, let's remove
this. I run this, it gives me that so there
is not going to be error, nothing is going
to conflict, we can just easily do that. And
you remember that we checked the type of a
list. So right here, once I run these, you'll
see that it gives me class lists, which means
this variable is a list. But let's say I want
to check the type of the values in a list
like I want to check the type of this value
or the type of this value. Now as you know
this value is a string, it is an integer,
this is a boolean value. This is also strings.
Let me over on it. You see it gives me i n
t which is integer on one side over on these
Let me see. k doesn't give me anything there
but this is a boolean value. This is a string.
So let's say I want to get this, I'll just
say type country's square brackets, and I
give you this index number. Now when I run
these, you see it says class is a string.
Let's say I want to give for the second one,
which has an Indian's value of one. Once I
run it, it gives me integer. Let's try for
the third one. It gives me a bowl, which means
Boolean, so does how to basically get the
type of a string. And we can also do some
other things like, let's see, the last thing
I want to show you for this part is another
way to define a string LMC to assign a string,
I mean a list sorry. So instead of using the
square brackets, we can also use something
we call lists. But now when we are using this
list constructor, is called the list constructor,
it is used to construct a list, where I'm
going to use square brackets again, we're
gonna use normal round brackets like this.
Well now, so let me just delete this line.
Now let's use the list constructor to specify
how to construct a new list. So I'll say list.
And I'm gonna use normal brackets parenthesis,
and it has to be double. So when I'm using
the list constructor, it has to be double
like this. Now you can have all my values
like Nigeria, I can have the default before,
I can have false, almost, I print these, we
don't want to print type, we just want to
print everything. country's nice, it gives
me everything which I want to see. So does
how to basically use the list constructor
to specify a list. So we can print a list
in two ways, the normal and the second list
constructor. And then we can also print them
with a normal way without lists like the square
brackets, like these countries too. So now,
if I said type, grants, the type of countries
you see is gonna give me least. And then let
me also print the type of countries to just
to show that both of them are still lists,
so lists and lists, so that it will be all
about the basics of list. In the next video,
we're going to talk more about lists, attributes,
there are still a lot of things we can do
with least
in this part, we're going to be talking more
on least, specifically, we're going to be
talking about lists, functions, or least methods
in Python. So in the last part, I showed you
about lists and plenty things you can do at
least 20 list attributes. In this video, we're
going to dive more deeper. Now let's say we
have two lists. The first one is list one.
And this list one is just a bunch of numbers
12345. And then we have list two. And then
we want this list to to just be let's see
a bunch of fruits so we have a banana and
then we have abuse men goes unless you're
English. So now we have these two lists. Now
let's say we want to join these two lists
together like we want to print it together.
We are going to do something like list one
dot append dot extend want to extend it with
listen to now also drains least one What is
this gonna give me is the these joint with
these. So let's print it. radiates you want
to drill for five then banana, Apple mango
oranges. So just give me these joint with
these the first least joint with the second
list. So does Wood stained doors, it combines
the two lists together. But let's say we want
to add a value to the ending of this list
like oranges. Move on to add water, what do
we have? I think we have cherries, but we
just want to add something else to these.
We can do something at least two dot append.
And then what do we want to append to it,
let me say cherry. Now we'll say print list
true, you're gonna bring me all these with
Jerry. Now Jerry is part of this list will
see not only bananas, apples, mangoes, oranges,
and it pains me cherry. Now if I see I want
to get the length of list two. Now we have
four year versus we appended one, it should
give us five. Now you see we are five. So
that just see is a simple way to append a
value to a list. And it's very, very useful
also. But let's say we want to put in a value
in between one of these, like we have multiples
in a value in between banana and apple. This
cherry, we want it to be right here, something
like this. Now if we want to do that, we're
just gonna say lists two dots insert. And
then this is gonna take two inputs, now it's
gonna take the index number, the index plays,
we want to put it want to put it to one, and
then we want to put the ACE cherry. Now let
me explain this further. So it says list two
dots instead want to say in the index number
one, that means right here, then cherries
should be right here. So 01 want it to be
want to input cherry. Now when I print Jerry,
let me just run this, you see now we have
a banana then we have cherry in between. So
in between bananas and apples, we have cherry.
So that is how to insert a value in between
a list. But now let's say we want to remove
a particular value from the list, we can say
this to dot remove, alleges remove bananas.
Now once I print list two is going to print
me and list two, without bananas. And that's
very easy is just by saying remove, then whatever
you want to remove. But now let's say we want
to do something I want to delete everything
in this list want to clear it up, you can
just say least two dots clear. And nothing
is gonna be in here. As I said at least two
dots clear, this is going to be empty, it's
just going to be an empty list. It clears
everything deletes all the values in the once
I run it, you see not I placed me on empty
list. So does algae just delete a list? Very
easy. But now let's say that we have these
values. And the mango, we want to get the
index number of mango, as we know this 012.
So the index number of Mongo is two. But we
want to get it let's say we have 1000s of
lists of values in this list. Want to get
with the Mongo is located in that list, we're
just going to say print list two dot index
of mango. So you just gonna print the index
number of mango. There's just run it right
here you see is these 2012. So it tells me
where Mongo is located in this list, which
is very, very helpful. Now let's say we have
a value appear in more than one. So we just
want to know how many times a value appears
in this list. Now it's very easy, we're just
going to see is list dot count. Mango. So
now it should tell us one because mango only
comes in this list one time. Once I run it,
you see here we have one. Let me come here
and input mango again. Now once I run it this
time, you see that we have to because mango
is in our list two times. So that's how to
simply do that. But now let's see we have
a list of numbers unless they are scattered
like let's say we have one yeah And let me
just delete all these we have four, five,
so we have three year. So 4351 unless I have
to at the end. So let's say want to print
this list in ascending order. You know, as
I said, in Python, you might be working with
a lot of data, and we have 1000s of numbers
that are scattered, I want to print them accordingly.
Let's see from Andre wants to print to 250
to 350, accordingly, not scattered, we can
easily do that was going to say, is least
one dot sought, like this, right here, I'm
just gonna print least one. Now once I print,
it is not going to print it 43512 is going
to print 12345 in ascending order. Now you
see now we have 12345. This also is very useful
when working in Python. But now let me just
remove this mango, we don't want to have it
twice. That was just for testing. But now
let's say that we want to print a list from
the back want to reverse the list. Want to
print it from the bottom, what we're gonna
do, we'll say lists to dot reverse. It's very
easy, we just released two dot reverse, almost
to print list two, you'll see that it's printed
from oranges, then two mango, two apples,
and two bananas. Let's run it. Now I see oranges,
mango, Apple banana models, how to easily
print a list from the bottom from the last
value in that list. Well now let's say we
want to duplicate a list, like we want to
just take this list and copy it again or something
like that. Let's test the four lists to let
me delete these two, let's have another list
named list three less than we wanted to list
three to just be exactly the same thing with
this in duplicate of list two. So we're just
gonna say is list theory can be equals to
list one. list two, I mean does copy. So just
going to copy all the values in this too,
and then paste it in history, I was referring
to this theory, I run it, we have exactly
the same thing we get when we print listen
to this exactly the same thing. And then we
can also do something more fun. Like let's
say we just want to delete the last value
from these I just printed everything else.
We can do that by saying guys that by saying
the pope method, so we can just say lists
two lists two dots, Bob. So when we say the
student Bob is just going to remove the last
value we have in Dallas, it will delete is
going to remove the last value we have in
that list, and then relive the rest. So when
I print these two now, if only three values.
So now you see we have bananas, apples and
mangoes, no more orange. But let's want to
be specific, we won't want to delete, you
remember that we can those remove a value
by saying these two dots, remove an avocado
specify tlsa banana. And then when we print
this, it will remove banana. But we can just
also delete or remove a value by using the
index number. So in pop, we're going to say
list dot pop just like pop out to remove something.
Let's remove the one with the index value
of one or say one and print us banana mango
oranges. It gives us that same list but without
the value of that index number. But we can
also use doodies. Instead of using pop, we
can do this exact same thing. But now we can
use delete. So when we say d L, I will say
least true. Let's say zero. So now this is
going to delete the value with the index number
zero in this list two lists. When we bring
list two, they're going to give us everything
without banana. Let's run it nicely. We have
apples, mangoes and orange. I remember that
we also showed you how to just clear lists,
I will just delete everything in our list.
We can also do this using this d l function.
So instead of specifying something here, we
just say delete the L Listen to. Now this
thing is going to be clear this list. Once
I run it, you see it says list two is not
defined. Okay? But we do have list two right
here. So let's do something like, delete just
one. Yeah. And then they just print. Oh, okay,
so um, the reason why it says lists to not
defined, you can see we have list one, not
here we have list two, which has banana, apple,
mango, and oranges. They were just doing with
deleted list two. So once we delete this list
two is quite different from the one we did
earlier, which was list dot clear. Remember
that if we do list two dots clear is just
going to remove everything here. But that
list is going to be available in our code.
But when we use this delete is just going
to delete a way that list is going to delete
that value. So it's not going to be in our
code again, that's how I will not try to print
list to Python does it seeds, again is a list
two is not defined, so it completely removes
it. So there's a difference between the clear
function and the Delete function. Now there's
going to be all four lists for now. In this
tutorial, we're going to be talking about
topples in Python. So topos used to store
multiple items in a single variable. So you
know least which we talked about in the last
but topples are very similar to lists. But
there are some basic difference, like tuples
are immutable. Now immutable means you can't
change any value in a topple. Now let me show
you how to write a topple in Python. Now let's
say we have a total of three numbers. I'll
say three underscore numbers. And I give those
numbers, I want your writing the top, which
means a normal bracket, no square brackets,
so 123. So let's say we have this now when
we print three numbers around that, it just
gives us this top bar, we can also do some
things like get the first value in that Tapu
using the index number, I can say get me zero,
which will print us one. So we can also do
all those type of things. But let's say we
now try to change the value of two to something
like 25. It's not possible because as I said
earlier on, it's immutable, which means we
can't change it. Once we have the top who
does well is going to be for our code, we
can't refine it or add anything from the top
level later in the code. So let's say we want
to do something like three numbers. Announcer
from the index number one, change it to 23.
And then I want to print three numbers. Now
this is going to give us an error. So yeah,
it says type error top object does not support
item assignment. So he's saying what we want
to do top who doesn't support it. So that's
the basic difference between topple at least.
And then we can also do some other things
like topples allow repetition of numbers or
repetition of values, like I have 123 uttanasana
input one again, when I just let me remove
this line, I have one twice, once I print
that is going to work fine, it allows repetition
of the same value. And I also do some things
like I can get the length of a toggle, I can
just say print le n and then it's just going
to give me the amount of values we have in
this top. As you can see it prints for because
we have 1234 values. And then I can also get
the type just to make sure this is a top like
a gundu type to know if this is a top or not.
Once I run it, you see this class top. So
that shows me that that is a top and top also
allows various data types. Like I can have
another top and see strings. And then I can
say oh lunch. Let me give you one more. Now
once I try to print strings, you see that
everything works fine. So it allows various
type of data types, we can also do it again
for like the Boolean type, I just say B Oh,
and the less true or false, and then true
again. Now when we try to print B Oh, you
see that it works fine. So it allows various
data types. And then it doesn't just allow
them on separate variables, we can mix them
together, like know we have one, I can have
another one, which will be a string, which
will be own. And then I can have another one,
which is going to be a Boolean. So once I
print the first one, we just three numbers.
Now you'll see that everything still works
fine. So topples, allow all these kinds of
things. And then in tacos, we can also check
the data type of the value of that taco. Now
we want to check the data type of this face
value, we can say, type of three numbers with
the index number zero, which is the first
one, they should bring to us int, which is
integer. So as you see it says class int.
Now does topple can also do that. Now, instead
of just writing these parentheses right here
are normal brackets or circular brackets,
anything you want to call it is totally fine.
We can also use the topic constructor, just
the way I told you about least constructor
there is also a topic constructor. So the
only difference is just our going to add a
pool right here. And it will have two brackets
like this, as I tried to print everything,
still gonna be fine, let me just print the
top of variable normally. Now as I printed,
you see there is still a top, nothing goes
wrong. And that's gonna be basically all about
topples the basics of tuples in Python, so
we might be using this topples less often
in Python, who mostly use lists. But in some
cases, we really want to use tuples. In Python,
something like let's say you're working with
coordinates, or just some numbers that you
don't want to change, or some values you don't
want to change, I suppose might be the best
option. In this tutorial, I'm going to be
talking to you about functions in Python.
So functions is just a bunch of code which
perform a particular task. Now functions allows
you to package your code Well, let me say
restructure goodwill is just like a block
of code, which performs a particular tasks
the way you want to use the function, you
just call it. So let me show you how to do
a function in Python. So for us to define
a function, we're going to use a keyword called
def. Now once we type this def, Python knows
that now we want to define a function. So
you can say d f, let's just do a simple function,
which is going to greet the user. Maybe it
will say welcome or something like that. So
we can just say greetings. So now, the key
word, which is def, and then after it, we
have Greetings, which is the name of our function
can say greetings underscore function. So
this is the name of our function, and then
you're going to be followed by open and close
parentheses, and then after it are going to
have a colon. So after this block of code,
Python knows that whatever is going to come
below it is going to be the task in which
we want that function to perform. So once
I click enter, then I notice that it doesn't
start from beginning it starts right from
displace, automatically it indents now in
Python, indentation is very important. So
now this indentation shows us that whatever
code we're going to write, let's like print
something is going to be on the dysfunction.
But if I just removed indentation, and I start
from here, then the function is cancelled.
This is an invalid syntax, because normally
there's supposed to be an indentation and
an indentation, one indentation, it goes to
four spaces. So if I go here, you can see
is 1234. So once it indents automatically
automagically. That means it's created for
species. Now let's say you are using a code
editor which doesn't does the indentation
automatically Like if you're using Notepad,
and then once you click on Enter, he doesn't
add the indentation, you can just ask for
space like this 1234 that does automatically
indented. So now we want this function to
just tell the user welcome or greetings from
me or something like that. So can you say
welcome user. So like these, this function
named greetings function is sprinting to the
user that welcome. But if I run this, nothing
is done. I'm just closes up. And why is that.
So when we have a function for that function
to be performed, or for that has to be executed,
we need to call the function. And I will call
this function we can just say, Now, once I
press enter, you see it's still indented.
But I want to go to this function, I'm done
with what I'm doing in this function. So if
I just press A Backspace, now, this is out
of this function. Now, if I just say, greetings,
function with open or close parenthesis, now
I'm calling this function. So that means this
is girl is just the same thing as everything
we have in this function. So now it should
print a welcome user. Also just run it you
see now it says welcome user. So that is how
to use functions in Python. But functions
is more broad, there are a lot of things we
can do with function. Now as you can see,
this then says welcome user the result. But
which user let's make it more fun, something
like that, we can pass in something called
arguments or parameters. So right here in
this open or closed parentheses, instead of
just leaving him blank with compassion, something
like, Um, let's see, we have name. Oh, not
this. So name, which is the name of the user.
Now, instead of saying welcome, user, want
to say welcome, name. Right here, we're just
gonna say, name. And this is just gonna print
welcome name. But instead of name, it expects
us to pass in something when calling this
function. If I just run this, you see, it
gives me an error. It says Greetings, function
missing one required positional arguments
name. So this is showing us that when we're
calling this function, now, we need to pass
in wolves Eva user that is, so let's say the
name of the user is john. So now when I run
these, right here, you see it says welcome
join. So let me just go back and make sure
to explain it very well. Right here we have
this function, it's having an argument or
parameter, which is name. So this name is
going to be able to tell the function which
user it wants to greet. And then it's just
going to greet the user with the print function.
So for us to give it this name, this name
is just like a variable. So when we're calling
the function, instead of leaving these blank
like these, but I was going to pass in the
string like john, but you know, we can also
pass in other data types. So you can see that
this john is a string. But let's say we just
want to pass in an integer or a number. Or,
you know, anytime we're dealing with numbers
in Python, we don't need the quotes, we can
just say 34. Once I run these, you see it
says can only concatenate strings, not integer.
So if you follow this tutorial, from the beginning,
I showed you how to convert an integer to
a string. So right here, it says if count,
concatenate string an integer, that means
you can add them both together. So for us
to be able to use these, we must make sure
that we convert this integer to a string.
So I'm just gonna say string like this. Now
this name is a string. Once I run it, he says
welcome pitiful. So that is how to basically
do that. knowledges go back. So let's do make
sure we're passing in john. So that is how
to pass in parameters or arguments. Now you
can call it parameters. You can call it argument,
whatever you want is fine. And then we'll
also pass in more than one parameter or argument.
So we can pass in name can also pass in age.
And then we can say welcome then the name.
And then we can say something like let's do
these you typed the name, let's see, age.
Yes board and a full stop. So right here,
when we're passing in these, john, we're going
also passing the age as an integer is C 27.
But remember, now this is an integer. If we
run these, obviously, we're going to have
an error, which is cannot concatenate string
and integer. So you know that we now have
to convert this to a string right here. And
then run it. So you see it says, Welcome,
john, you are 27 years old. So does what does
how to simply do that, you can pass in two
arguments or parameters. Now, let's say you
don't know the amount of argument that's going
to be passed in you. Let me particularize
that Before explaining. Now, let's say we
have names. Let me just remove all these this.
Welcome name. So let's say we have these.
Well, we don't know how many is going to be
passed in here. So we're gonna have to put
something like esoteric. Now this asterik
is showing that we're passing various amounts
like a tuple, a topple of which is like a
list of values we're passing in here. And
then we don't know the amounts that is being
passed. So let's say right here, we have this
topple, john. Let's see, we also have another
one named, Tim. Let's give it one more. Okay,
right here. One more named Tom. So right here,
we're passing this tree list these three values
a year as names. So these names is like a
topple now, that's always a steric. Because
we don't know. So for us to now show the name,
which we want. Let's say we only want to grease
the second user, then we can create the user
using its index number. So you can say names,
the index number is one. Now when I run these,
you see it says welcome, Tim. So does how
to pass in various values, more than one value
if we don't know what we are passing. Now,
let's just go back. Let me press Ctrl. C,
but to name and age. Quickly, okay, like these.
Yeah. So let's print this and make sure that
our code is working. Welcome, john, you are
27 years old. Right. Now, we can also pass
this instead of just passing the values we
can pass is true, the variable names now catches
up to like name is equals to john. And then
age is equals to 27 is still exactly the same
thing. So when we run it is still going to
print those welcome, john, you are 27 years
old, is basically the same thing. So let's
make this more fun. Instead of just passing
out these values, statically, or by just add
code into values, we can first ask the user
to give us an input of his name and his age,
then we're just going to print that. So let's
quickly do that. Right here. No, right. Yeah.
So right here, we can see name, inputs, and
your name. And then let's give it another
one named age. inputs, MSC and your age. So
now asking the user for the value is one I'll
just type in these. And then once the user
give us these are those gonna replace that
year? So by placing it with name, and replacing
this with age, so let's run this. So if I
come down here, ask for my name. I say team,
it does for the age, I say 101. Now it says
welcome team. You are Andre, our. So I hope
you get the concept of functions in Python.
These are the basic thing you are going to
be dealing with in Python. In this part, we're
going to be talking about return statement
in Python function. Now return statements
are just being used to get a response from
the task being executed in a function. Now,
as you know, in the last video, when we define
our function, then we just simply printed
out whatever we want to return. But normally,
in Python, we use what we call a return statement.
So this return statement is gonna like give
us an output or give us a feedback of what
has been executed. So let's personify this
right, let's say you are, you are being sent
an errand to go, let's get some information.
And then when you come back, you want to give
a response or you want to return like a feedback,
you want to say what you want to get, or the
task which you executed. So that's the same
thing right here in Python function, decode
block, goes for the errand, and in the return
statement, give us a response. So let's show
you how to do that. We're just gonna define
a normal function, let's just say my function.
And then it's not going to take in any argument
for now. So in Yeah, we just want to return
let's say, five blows four. So this basic
function now is just simply going to return
nine, because that's 5.4. But now, if we can
just print out my function, so once we print
out my function, you see, well, it says function,
my function is just you know that as a function,
but we also need to add our open and close
parentheses, when I run it again, we see nine.
Now we're gonna make this like more interactive,
we can just have a function that adds up to
numbers or subtract numbers or something like
that. So we can say, add numbers. And then
want to add two arguments, number one, and
number two. So what we just want to return
is number one, plus number two. So right here,
we can just passing no more number two, and
number two as three s3. So this will give
us, you see, says my function is not defined
as because we've changed the name to add numbers,
we're just going to run it again. You see,
now it gives those five. But let's make this
more interactive here. Let's say number one,
is equals to input. And first number underlays,
avinoam. to aim boots. And second number.
All right, yeah, so same to give us number
one, right here we'll give is number two.
So now when we run this is going to ask us
for the first number, let's say 80. Or let's
say 20, as the second number is going to add
this up and give us 100. Now it is you see
it says 88 8020. And the reason why it says
this is because it's seen these as an status
drink. And so, when we use the addition is
seen it as concatenation. So as I just said,
8020, but I wanted to add you by coming out
over very juicy says the stringed Well, we
know we are collecting an interior what Python
does, you know that so, we have to tell Python
that a what you want to collect is a number.
So I want you to add it to do that convert
it to an integer by saying i n t. Now, we
close it right here, then we also do the same
thing i n t and then we close it right here.
Now, when we run this is going to add it for
us at this 20. Now it gives us Andrea. So
does the basic concept of return statement.
And I also want to point out something that
whenever wisened return statement in Python
function, we do not write anything after that
code block. Like that return statement shows
the end of the function Call me an hour save
print. Hello. Once I run it asked me for the
numbers, you see just gives me 80 just return
these, it doesn't print a low, because it
is outside our function and is not a normal
indentation. So that's code is not seen in
our code block. But if I come here, if I delete
it on inside the function, I paste it is going
to print that for us. So let's say for for
now you see we have Hello, and then we have
the answer of the audition. So that is how
to use return statements in a Python function.
In this part of the tutorial, we're going
to be talking about if statements in Python.
Two if statement is basically just giving
Python a condition. Now, this concept is very
easy to grasp, not only in Python, but in
programming in general, there is always if
statement, but maybe with different syntax.
So if statement is just a line Python to execute
code automatically by itself. So assuming
that if a particular condition is true, then
Python should do this. But it is not true,
then Python should do that. So why does give
me Python a condition before it runs the code?
So let me first type a simple little notes
so you can understand the concept. So I can
say something like if I write a number, so
now I write a number. And then if the number
is divisible by two, then we know that the
number is an even number. What if is not divisible
by two, then it's an odd number. So something
like this, this is not how to write code.
This is just plain text. But I'm just showing
like yeah, use I wrote a number, then if the
number is divisible by two, then we can tell
Python to tell the user though, okay, this
number is even. But it is not divisible by
two, then this number is odd. So now let's
protocolized is on his right, it's a real
Python code. So now we have a variable named
a is equals to true. And then we have another
variable named P and b is equal to three.
Now go have a simple if statement. checking
if two is greater than three or three is greater
than two, or if variable a is bigger a variable
b. So say, if a is greater than b, then we
can just print to the user a let's go catenate
is greater than B. Okay, boy, yeah, we know
that b is greater than a. So let's just make
this greater. So cool. We run. Now let's run
this. Now you see cannot concatenate string,
I know those types of stuff. So let's just
convert it to a string. So let's run this
again. You see now it says four is greater
than three. So we checked if a is greater
than b. Now it also check, obviously, if b
is less than b. Now you see that nothing happens.
Because we said it should run this code. Only
if a is less than b versus is not less than
b, the good news a cuted. Now we can also
check if A is the same thing as B. So if b
is equals to B legends make a equals to B.
And we run it. You see it says four is greater
than four because that was the third issue,
say, but we can just simply say A equals B.
So as you run you see is this A equals B,
where we change is now to three. Now four
is no more equals to three. It doesn't run.
So that's the basic concept of if statements.
I will also do this for different data types.
Now let's say we have a string, which is Team
B is also team. So now we know that A is equals
to Team A, B is equals to team. So obviously
a is the same thing as team. And then you
say A equals to B. When we run it, you see
it says A equals to B, then we can also use
the Boolean. So let's say true. Now we can
see if a is equals to true, that means if
A is true, then we can just simply say, A
is true. And then we can just run this. So
A is true. So does the basic concept of an
if statement. Well, you know, we can also
say if A is not true, that means is something
like false. They will say a is not true. So
you know now is false. When we run it, he
says he is not true. We can also add two different
types, like if let's quickly change this back
to integers. So let's see, if a is greater
than or equals to b, so you know, a is greater
than B. Or if a is greater than or equals
to B, then we'll say ratio say true or something
like that. So let's run it, you'll see says
true because A is greater than B. And if a
is also equals to B, it resists a true because
A is equals to B. But now let's say a is less
than b. When we run it, nothing has been executed.
So now we want to add more functions to this
if statement. So it says if a is greater than
or equals to b, so let's just check if A is
equals to B, no, say A equals B. But what
if a is not equals to be watching the Python
two? What should the cause do? Surely Joe's
not run anything? So we can now add else this
else means if a vigils correct this, if A
is not equals to this, so as an IF is equals
to B it should print A equals B else means
anything except that, then she just print
a not equals b. So if a is equals to B bring
this, then else means if it's not the opposite
of that, then issue just print a is not equals
to B. So when I run these now it prints a
is not equals to B. So that is how to use
a simple if an else statement. We can also
do that with like a Boolean, does make this
true. So say if A is true, let's say A is
true. If not, let's say not true. So when
we run it, you see says A is true, with our
changes to false. Obviously a is not true.
So it says a not true. So that's how to basically
use a simple if else statement will also go
further. Now let's say want to add more than
one condition, like if A is equals to true
leaf a is equals to false. Print A is false.
Else is known of the two. So if a is equals
to true it should print A is true. A leaf
means require adding another statement is
the same thing as if both else if does mean
you have if so if a is not true, then you
cannot check if A is false. So if a is false
print this bereave is none of these two, then
just print a is none of the two. So now it
should print a is false when we run it across
You will see a is false. now know how to add
a simple elsif statement. Now we got add any
amount of Elif statement want to add, we can
say, Canada when I say leave a, let's see
not equals to, let's see. A something like
that, then we can print we can just bring
anything wants to do. So it got any amount
of Elif statement is, does the basic syntax
and we to use an if else statement. But now
we can make this more, we can step up a little.
Now instead of saying if A is equals to true,
so we can say, if A is okay, let's let me
specify a variable, let me see. Boy, is true.
Let me say short, is also true. So I can say
if boy is true, then print is a boy. Now,
since boy is true, right here is nothing like
that. So let's just change this to boy, since
boy is true, then we can say is a boy, we
can also do something like if boy is true,
or shorts is also true. So that means if any
of these two conditions are true, you will
print is a boy or he is shot. So when I run
the AGC is a boy or he is short. So since
both of these are true, his prints this, if
this is false, it still like he was saying,
If boy is true or short is false, is still
going to print this. Now the reason why I
still printing this is because all we're raising
the O is going to check for only one. So if
one of these condition is correct, he just
runs this. So when I run this, you see is
a boy or a short, both, if I change this now
to and you see that it doesn't print this,
it will print a is none of the two. So let's
just remove this else if for a while. So now
you see that it prints the L statement a is
not only two. And that is because we're realizing
and it has to check that these these conditions
are both correct. So if one of it is not correct,
is just going to go to the next statement
and skip that statement. So that's different
between all and and so now that we know the
concepts, the basic concept of if else, and
Elif statement, let's just go ahead and do
some simple exercises. Now let's say want
to use FL statement to check for the data
type. And until the user Okay, these data
type is, let's say a string, or it's a lease,
something like that. Now, first of all, let's
do the user to input something. So let's say
value should be input. And they will tell
you user inputs of value. Now once user input
a value, we're gonna check for the value and
tell the user that oh, this is your value.
So we can use an if statement for that. So
we want to check if the statement is a string.
So we can say if type. If the type of value
is equals to a string, str, then we'll print.
Let's just print out value value is a string.
Well, let's add an Elif. Let's say we want
to check if the type is an integer. type of
value is an int does an integer, we will print
value is an integer. And then we also want
to check let's see if it's a list to say a
leaf If the type of value is a list, do print
See, value is a list. Ball is none of these,
we just say, we don't know. So right here,
I wanted to add this, but obviously it says,
Python says I've closed it. So for me to add
this calendar codes there, I have to use the
backslash. So now once I use plus slash is
going to be printed with it. So now we can
say we don't know the date, I have the measures
or whatever they use our routes of value.
Now, let me just close this quickly. And then
let's test this out. Now we input the value,
let me input six is this six is a string does
nice to year. Now the reason why this is a
string, because anything we put automatically
gets it as a string. Now, if we want to get
this as let's say an integer, we have to type
int, we have to convert it to integer. So
this type of exercise only works for string.
So now we're changing the name of this exercise
to check in if it's a string only. So what
we just want to do is we cancel this, we're
not checking for age or list or any other
data type, we're just checking if it's a string.
And that's because Python automatically sees
it as a string. And we have to convert it
to an integer if I don't want to know if it's
an integer. So we can also go for that to
check in with an integer by using some complex
if statement, or some reg x we usually don't
need to bother about for now. But for now,
let's stick to this basic exercise. So we're
checking if it's a string. So if the string
who says the string is not to say, is not
a strange. So we just bring all these to the
tub. So right here is where it should be if
a space and then there's run it again. Now
when I print the value now, and I say, I know
you can see that I guess that is a string.
So that's basically how to just, you know,
do it. But if we want to, like change it or
save and say integer. So now anything we input
is automatically seen as an integer. So it
will automatically say value is not a string.
So even let me pull six. Now I say Conoco
cut, nice drink. So that's simply because
we have to convert this to string before concatenating.
Or, let me show you a better way to do it.
Since we're just dealing with one. Instead
of using plus here, I can just use a comma.
So when I run this, again, I input an integer,
he says seven is not a string. So now the
second is a size we're going to do is to check
if a number is divisible by five. So we knew
that we have numbers, multiples of five, or
something like that, that means the numbers
which five can be divided by So we have five
itself, we have 10 1520, where we give you
like 17, we want to tell us that 17 cannot
be five cannot be divided by 70, something
like that. So we're just gonna automatically
get an input First of all, and make sure it's
an integer. So we'll say inputs a number.
And then we'll see if there's just a gay,
what wants to see now is that if the value
so what this is doing is add value is basically
the number the user input. And then this percentage
sign means the remainder. So we'll say if
the user input 20, so 20 divided by five is
four, then the remainder is zero. So when
we do something like 2025 in Python, it means
give us the remainder. So first of all, let
me just cut this out. And let me show you
what that does. So if I say print 20 percentage
five, now you're gonna see that it's going
to print zero is going to print the remainder
of that division. When I say print 22, it
should print me true, because 22 divided by
five is four, then the remainder should be
too noisy, right? Do we have to do them just
quickly bring that back. Right now we're saying
if the value percentage five, that means if
the remainder is equals to zero, then obviously,
that just means that value can be divided
by five else value can not be divided by five.
So since we're using an integer, let's add
a comma here, like this. So this should work.
Now it gives us a number, let's say Andrea
now says Andrea it can be divided by five.
Let's run this again and give it a number
that can't be divided by five like 106. He
says 100 and sees cannot be divided by five.
So that's how to build a Basie program with
Jack's even number can be divided by five.
Now the last exercise, which we're going to
do on FL statement is going to be the exercise
to check if the length of a sentence is less
than 10. So again, we're going to collect
a value, but this time, it shouldn't be as
drink, because it's going to be a sentence.
Now, once a cake if the the length of that
sentence is less than 10. So if the length
of the sentence is less than 10, they will
say value is less than 10. Else Z value is
greater is more than j. So gases lead to this
list typing random things like my name is
my name. Now this is obviously more than 10.
I eat enter, he said not supported between
instance. So because this is not seen as a
as an integer, we can do this. So right now,
anytime we are using this less than or equals
to, it has to be as does basically be an integer,
we can do less than or equals to four string.
What are some other ways we can do this, we're
going to talk about seats. We could have solved
this now. But I'm leaving this to for the
tutorial, because I don't want to jump in
some steps. So for any tutorial, we're going
to come back to this exercise and I'm going
to show you how to do this with strings. But
for now I will be get the concept of use an
else statement. So before we continue with
more concepts in Python, we just want to do
a simple Python program with Jack's even number
is an even number or an odd number. So as
we know an even number is a numbers we can
be divided by two, an odd number is the one
which count. So this shouldn't take us up
to like two minutes to do. So I'm just going
to call it an input from the user and name
is number we'll say input will say and a number
and then want to make sure that these is an
integer. And then we're going to say if number
percentage two is equals to zero, then obviously,
this is an even number. So what this is doing
is that if the remainder of number divided
by two is equal to zero, then is an even number.
Else. We just see, odd number. Now when we
run this, we put the value of licence to cease.
Now since this is an even number, we run it
again on the booster to 767 is an odd number.
So does also do a simple exercise. sighs like
that using if statements in Python. In this
tutorial, we're going to be talking about
dictionaries in Python. So dictionaries are
used to store data values in the key value
pairs. So dictionaries also data type, just
like least just like strings. dictionary is
also a data type. But this dictionary stores
value in a pair of keys and value. So just
like a main dictionary, like an English dictionary,
where we have the word as the key, and the
value as the meaning of that word, so that's
basically our dictionary works. Now dictionary,
D are changeable, which means you can modify
them even after like configuring assigning
them. But they don't allow duplicate, not
liking lists are tuples, that you can type
in a value more than once in dictionary, you
can do that. So let me show you how to write
a dictionary in Python. So let me just name
this dictionary, my gait, how to write a dictionary,
we're gonna use these curly braces, and then
we're gonna give you the key. So the key might
be something like, name, and then I'm gonna
use this column. And then the value can be
same. And then I'm going to put the comma,
I can have another key and value in, let's
say, age. Unknown, let me say something like
nationality. I can see something like African
or something like that. And then let's just
have these two. Let me give it one more. I'll
see qualification. Let's see college degree
or something like that. So this is a basic
dictionary in Python. Now, let's just start
with the basic thing by just printing this
dictionary to our screen was this. Let's just
print my dict. Now once we print this, you
see that it just gives us the dictionary name
theme as now the African qualification college.
But now let's say we just want to print only
this name, value, what to print the value
of this name. So this is the value and this
is the key assigned to this value. That means
if we want to get this value, we need to search
for this key. Just like when you go online,
and search for meaning of order, meaning of
anything, out of words, meaning of anything.
So play, for example, meaning of order, so
order is the key, then the value you are looking
for is the definition. So does our dictionary
work is very similar to the normal word dictionary.
So now once you get the value of this name,
we can just use the square brackets after
these n in the same name. So what this is
going to print for us is team right here you
can see team, which is the value of this name.
Now there are other things we can do, as I
said, duplicates are not allowed in, in in
dictionary. So now let's say I have two names.
And the other one is john. Now when I tried
to print these, you see his prints only the
first one, it doesn't say I mean prints only
the second one does the most recent one, it's
automatically because this one out of it now
does what I mean by duplicate not allowed
in dictionaries, you can't have two t with
the same name, we can have two values with
the same name. Now what I mean by that is
this is the key This is the value. So two
keys, we can add them with the same name book
I have two values. Let's say this is named
two. unnamed two can still be the same. Now
if I print these, you will see that name is
same name two is the theme. So we got out
the values the same we can repeat that. But
the key being assigned cannot be repeated.
It cannot be a duplicate. Now let's say we
want to get the length of this And it is very
easy to get just seen Len. Like this, then
once we print you see tells us for that because
we have four keys and values in here. And
then we also mix data types. Now you know
that let me just remove this, do you know
that this name, the value been assigned to
it is a strange devalue, besides the nationality
is also a string, and the value been assigned
to qualification is also a string. But we
can change it, let's say want to add like
age, and we know that age will obviously be
an integer, we can just add it here, let's
say it's a seven. Now normally, we will write
an integer without the quotes that are going
to write it in there. And then once we print,
we can still go ahead and print. Ah, it's
gonna print into cell phones with no problem.
can see it right here at seven, we can also
add a Boolean, we can say is tall. So it still
can be true. And then once we print age, I
mean wants to print my dictionary. So you
see it's print true. So it tells us that okay,
this person is talk. So we can add different
data types. And then what is very cool is
that we can also add a list, so we can list
of his friends. So can the data type as a
list like this, so we can see, one of his
friend is Peter. We can say Paul, we can see
precious and odd, so lightyear wants to print
friends. Just gonna print those at least.
Okay, right here, it says invalid syntax error.
And that will because we forgot to add a comma
right here. So we should make sure to add
a comma before adding another value. So once
we click enter, you see it gives us Peter
Paul, and precious. So now let's just bring
the whole dictionary without anything attached.
Now we go down here, we see that it prints
everything named team on everything we need
to know about that dictionary. And then, to
check if this is a dictionary, we can also
use the type. So also, just put type here
is going to print dictionary for us. So you
can see right, yes, this class is dict, which
means that these is a dictionary. So we can
also make it more fun. By specifying a variable,
let's say we have a variable named x. And
we want this variable to be equals to one
of the values of this. So we can just simply
say, X can simply be equals to mod. My D.
Name. So x now is name. Now once you print
x, obviously it prints the name. Now, those
are busy dictionary functions and dictionary
methods. So I hope you get the concept of
dictionary in Python. This tutorial, we're
going to be talking about why loop in Python.
So while loop is a Python feature, which allows
you to loop through a block of code, while
a certain condition is true. So let's say
you have a condition like if a number is greater
than 10, then it should just loop through
a bunch of code below. So just like a function
with an if statement or something like that.
So we are giving it a condition that under
age, we have a bunch of code which we want
to loop through. So let me just show you how
to use while loop in Python. So first of all,
we can specify a variable named I can say
is equals to one. And now to use a while loop
we can say a while. One is still legs down
six. So this is a condition we're saying as
long as one is less than six. Then we just
want to print I I mean as long as i is less
than six, not one is this very good. That
is still one that we want to print, I and
then we just want to increment i by one So
we can see i equals two, i plus one. So this
is just gonna run this while loop, as long
as one is i is less than six, it's just gonna
print it to the screen, and then it's gonna
increase it by one, then run it again, run
it again, until it makes sure that it doesn't
pass six, it doesn't reach six. So you can
also increment these by typing, i plus equals
one, the same thing, anyone will walk. Now
when we run this, you see now it is 12345.
So what happened was that is loops through
this block of code. So we said while i is
less than six, so that means it should move
to this block of code the printed I, then
after that we incremented it, there, now i
is equals to two is still less than six. That's
why we have to, then it did the same thing.
incremented it we have 345. But after five,
it did the same thing. incremented by one,
but now i is equal to six. So because that's
this condition is really false, is no more
less now seeks then the wild loop to stop,
you just like caught in a way from that wild
loop. So that's basically what while loop
is about, it's very important in Python, there
are a lot of Python programs, you want to
build that we needed to use a while loop to
loop through different things with a condition.
And then you can also do more things like
e while i is less than six, or i is equals
to six, something like this. So now you know
that when we run these, it should print those
126. Because there's no more just only when
y is less than c so so when is equals to C.
So now it gives us an error, because when
writing equals two in Python, it has to be
double. So let's run it again. So now you
see 123456. So why loop in Python loops through
a block of code at a certain condition being
true. So because this is true, one of these
is true. It just prints I increase it by six
comes back does looping does that code again,
increase it by six come back, and then it
makes sure that it goes to six. Now go. So
say i equals to 10. Once I run this, it gives
us 12345. So if we say and and now we run
it, it doesn't give us anything. So sometimes
a wide loop. I put this in why loop conditions
is not similar to if statement, you know,
when you state where we can do Eva is less
than six and is this, then you should do a
certain thing. So now you can see that if
i is less than six, and i is equals to 10.
So the reason why this didn't run is because
at first i is less than six. So that's you
drawn, but we'll say and it's mostly equals
to 10. But we know that i right here is not
equals to 10. So if I change this to 10. It
still won't run. And the reason why it won't
run is because one of these is not correct.
So I is not less than six because 10 is no
less is what we say is less than 16. Now,
then we can run it, I guess see it's print
something now. So why is he and all in the
condition? Where is he Oh, as long as one
of it is one of the condition is true, then
that while loop we run both way. And the two
conditions must be true before that, why do
cross so now they just don't bother about
the and and now let's change to one less changes
to 10. So now when we run this we should get
129 let me just expand this we see that we
have 123456789 now this is basically the basic
concept of why loop in Python. In this tutorial
we're gonna be talking about for loops in
Python. So follow disease for iterating over
a sequence. Now this means is used looping
over a sequence. And this sequence can either
be at least a tupple, or dictionary, even
a string, a range of numbers, it can be anything
that is a list. Now we use for loop to loop
through them. Now a for loop is very used
in Python is used a lot in Python, actually,
because most of the times we have lists of
data we have data, large amount of data now
for loop is used, again for loop to loop through
each amount of data each value in that data.
So let me just show you how we do a for loop,
or we call the for loop in Python is very
easy. Now for you to type a for loop, the
first thing you need to do is to type this
for keyword, fo R. Now this keyword shows
that we want to loop through something. So
we can see four letter in four letter for
letter in. Let's say something like, hello.
Now this is a for each letter in ello, which
is h e l l, we just want to print a letter.
Now when I run these, you will see the experience
he differently, it brings everything separately.
So it's looping through each letter in that
ello string, like iterating through the sequence.
Now we can also do these by having a list.
Now you can see my lists, I would get up this
list to be anything ledger, C, gi j Yu Gi
Oh, now we can look through these and say
for, let's say like for x. Now not that this
can be anything, let me just this in which
I put later it can be denoted by anything.
It can be represented by anything. So when
I first got started with Python, I was kind
of confused in this for loops, just simply
because of this letter. So I thought that
you know, we're since we're using a low, and
each is called kereta. Ages got a letter is
got a letter, so I thought we have to use
later for each. But now I just want to clarify
that so that nobody will have to go to that
confusion. So this can be denoted by anything.
If I say four eggs in a row, and I just say
print x is going to do exactly the same thing.
If I say for gi or for anything I do, it can
be denoted by any single thing. Now let me
just so now I just want to say four items,
or four values will be better for values in
this my least. So I'm going to remove this
string as in my list. Now I just want to print
both values. Now once I press run, you see
nice prints everything j ij Yuju, which is
gi JU and J. So that is basically how to just
loop through a list. Now you can look through
anything, actually, you can look through a
dictionary, so they just have a simple dictionary.
And then let's say we have curly braces, and
then we have name. JOHN, we have age the thing
that I just leave those two. Now you can see
four values in my date, print values. Now
as I bring these you see it says name, age.
So you just basically sprint, these two which
we have name and age. So that's iterating
over words over a list of values. And then
in for loop. There's also something we call
the break. So now let's go back to our list.
Just Yeah, so now we are we still have this
or at least I would say four values in my
list print values, but I cannot see if values
is equals to Jeju then I want you to break.
So what this is going to do is that it's going
to look Do it one by one, it goes from j i,
then he goes to J au. So I've seen, once it
gets to this j, you It should break, then
you should stop that loop. So once I run these,
you're gonna see, okay, right here is supposed
to be double. Once I run these, you're gonna
see Justin j, i and j U. Now, why is this,
I said that it should continue looping brings
all the values, but once it gets into that
value is equals to j, u, m is once in a loop
to this j, you then break, break me stop the
loop. So that's why I want to get to J, you
it stops, does Oh, we don't have j Oh, right
here. Now, we can also, instead of having
the break here, I can do something like this.
So even before printing values, I can have
my if statement. And I can say, for value
in values, if value is equals to j, u, I can
say break. And after that break, I can print
values. So if you haven't gotten by now, the
difference is that if value is value, so is
looping to these values. But if the value
is value, it should break. You know, in the
last time, it first printed value, if as Peter
is Jay, you before it's broke. But now, if
value is J, you should break before even printing.
So it's gonna guess that Okay, we have j you
want to break, then we're going to print so
Python runs code line by line first runs this
code and runs this then runs this, then like
that. So the first thing he sees is that we
are checking if what want to look to next
is j U. And we see that yes, it's true is
j U. Now we just break, then after breaking,
we print values, so the only value I want
to print is G because we're broken when we
go to you. So when I run these, you see that
I only have gi we don't Prince j au again.
So that's basically how to use the break in
for loop. But we can also loop through a range
of numbers. So let's say we have 4x in range.
For now, what I can just do is to print x.
Now once I print x is going to give me a list
of number from zero to three. So it's gonna
give me a range of numbers starting from zero
to the non last number before four. So I also
change is only like 10, you're gonna give
me from zero to nine. So as you can see, it
gives me from zero to nine. And then we can
also specify for each to loop through a particular
range of number. So now we're given 2010.
But we can say each loop for each loop from
three to seven, or from 10 to 70, or any amount.
So if we wanted to loop from three to seven,
is our going to do it, we just say for x in
range three to seven, look to this number.
So when I run these, you see it gives me 3456,
it doesn't start from zero. So it looks from
three all the way to this seven. And that's
how to loop through a particular range of
number. And the final thing I'm going to show
you in for loop is that we can also use the
else statement. So now let's just loop to
for a range of seven. So after looping, we
can see else, what this else does is that
once this loop is done, once it's finished,
we can just print finished looping. So now
once I run this sprint from zero to CS, and
it says finished looping, so that's what the
the else statement does, is that it just simply,
first of all finish the loop first of all
finished iterating over the sequence, then
it just tell us whatever is in the L statement.
So that is an introduction to for loops in
Python. In this part, we're gonna be talking
about 2d lists in Python. So to do lists also
mean two dimensional list. So it's like well,
we have multiple lists inside a list variable.
So right now we can have a normal list like
my list which can Just a numbers like 1234
I was reprints my list, know that we're gonna
get 1234, which is a normal list. But now
we want to have a to do list, first of all
is recommended to press Enter just to organizing
the rotation, then we're gonna have a list.
So this can be 123. And then we can have another
line, which can be 456, then we are they've
come up on another line can be 789. So now
this is a to do list, because it has rows
and column. This is obviously a list in a
list. So dislike the high level list and his
like his sub sections or something like that.
So now once we just print my list, you'll
see that I just give us this normal list.
But let's say we want to get this value of
one or two. So we're gonna get it using the
index number. So we know that the index number
of this is one of zero, which is the first
one, then we also want to get the face value,
which would be zero. So once we print this
out, you will see that we have one. But let's
say we want to get the value of five. So we
know that the index number of this is one
that was indexed number five, it's also one.
Now once I run these, you see now that I have
five. So that's basically navigate on like
brains, or get some certain values from your
2d lists. And then we can also look through
these. So I'll introduce you guys to nested
loops. So nested loops is where you have a
loop in a loop a for loop to be specific when
you have a for loop in a for loop. So now,
instead of just printing, let's just say for
something like lists in my list, they initially
just print my lists. Now as I run these, you
see just print my list, have one list in my
list, it just loops through that. One, instead
of just looping through this or just printing
this, or I can do is I can add another for
looping the so for least in my list, and I
cannot see for maybe the rule or the column
for row in lists. Then now we want to print
row. So when I run these, it gives us an arrow
does because in Python must have indentation
to show that this is on the DCE. Let's run
it again. Now you see it says type object
is not iterable. So for row in lists, must
make sure that everything is intact. So I
put the list, but the name of this is lists.
So after that is now when I run this again,
you see it gives me let me just open this
up. You see it gives me from one to nine,
which is every single thing via 1234 all the
way to nine. So that is how a nested loops
work. So is like looping through a loop already.
So a loop in a loop. But I have not tried
it before. But I think we can also have another
loop again on looping through something like
Yeah, yeah. So there are various things you
can try out with Python is very great. So
I hope you understand the basic concepts of
Sudhi least are nested loops. So in this part
of the tutorial, we're going to be talking
about comments in Python. So comments is being
used to prevent a particular code or block
of code from running with your actual program.
Now let's see we have print. Hello. And then
we also have print one. Now when I run these,
you're going to see brings a low one. Now
if I call me and I put an ash tag, right beside
D Like this, you see that this is grayed out
is no more part of our code, it's still there.
But when I run, it is not going to be wrong
with our code, the only one prints. So that's
what comment is for, mainly in Python comments
is are mainly programming in general, is useful,
explaining our code or is useful, taking down
notes in our code very well, like making our
code more readable. In Python, you can also
just add comment, let's say you just want
to quickly test your code without a particular
code block, you can also use comments. So
you can also add comment at the end. Like
you can see ashtag this line prints Hello.
So you can just use it to explain your code.
Or you can just use it to block the code from
running. And as you seen, if you're two comments
more than one line, you can put hashtag on
this line on the second line, then everything
will be commented out. But there's also a
better way to do this in Python, you can just
easily add the let's say you have a code block,
or you have a function like my phone, Shawn.
And then this function just prints. Hi, now
let's say you just want to comment out this
particular function. Now what you're going
to do is above of the function, you're going
to add three quotation marks like this. And
as you can see, it automatically commits all
your code out. So if we run these now, nothing's
gonna run at all. It's, it says we have a
syntax error and stuff like that. So we have
to close these comments by putting those three
codes back on there, we'll want to close it,
so want to close on the beginning of this
function to the end. Now when we run these,
we will see that print ello and print one
run. So now we try to execute these by seeing
my on scarf. You see, that's gonna give us
an error. It says name error is not defined,
now means it doesn't even see this part of
the code will define the function when we
try to run it, it doesn't work. So that's
what comments are used for in Python, mainly
two things useful removing your code, or judges
or taking notes or making your code more readable.
In this tutorial, we're going to be building
a basic calculator using Python. So we're
going to be using all the skills and everything
we've learnt in the previous sessions are
going to be adding them together and then
building a simple calculator. So now what
wants to do is to have three inputs collect
three inputs from a user, which is the first
number, the second number on the operator.
So the calculator want to do this very basic
is just the one that is going to add, subtract,
divide, multiply two numbers together. So
want to collect a number, which would be number
one, and the second number, which would be
number two, and the operator, the operator
is whether you want to add or subtract, or
whatever you want to do. So now let's define
that to say no one should be equals to input.
We can say enter first number. And then we'll
also do the same thing. I'll say num, two
inputs and second number. And then let's see
Opie, which is the operator inputs, and, operator.
So now that we have the three inputs, when
I went to use an if statement, so what's going
to happen is if the op, which is your operator,
is equal to addition. Now we just want to
basically add the first number and the second
number, then we're going to use an Elif to
get his sub subtraction, whatever, then we're
going to do, according to the operator, the
users input. So let's say if op is equals
to plus. Then is equals to close by just going
to print out number one plus number two So
now let's just test that. So right here, let
me say two, three. And I want to add nice,
he says 23, which is very wrong, two plus
three is supposed to be five. Now the reason
why it says 23 is because he still sees this
as a string. If I over need to see it says
drink, what is meant to see it as an integer.
So because it's a string, he's just concatenating
it together, but we want it to be an integer,
so it can perform the normal operation. So
we have to say, ain't no ain't gonna pay stub
bugs are gonna do the same thing for the second
one in a beast. Now, when we run these, it
should work. And our first number, let me
say 75. Our second one should be 25. I want
to add nice, it gives me 100. It adds it up
together, that is what we want to happen.
So let's just do some gestures. Or let's say
the addition is no one plus not two. But now
want to check what if a user inputs subtraction,
so if a user say subtract, then we just want
to print this subtraction is number one, minus
number two, bow must make sure to disclose
sigh right here was your no we can do these
we can do the audition is no more close no
to because this is a stream, this is a number.
And then this is a string. So what we can
do right now is to just put a comma, right
here, so we can just cover. So let's test
it out. If I see 17 and 20, I'll just subtract
it gives me the subtraction is 50, which is
nice. And then let's do the same thing for
multiplication. So we just say the multiplication
is number one, times number two. So that's
the basic arithmetic for multiplication. And
then we're also going to do exactly the same
thing for division. So if it's equals to divide,
then we just print out the division is no
more one divided by num, two. So now this
should work. Now when I run it, and I say
6020, and I want to divide, you see, gives
me the division is 3.0. What if I do something
like the absolutes of these? Oh, no. So absolutes
of these, let me run it again. Now if I say
60 and 20. I put divide. Okay, so you gave
me three points. You I was expecting you to
give me three. But we're going to bypass that.
So this is how to build a basic calculator
using Python using getting user inputs and
then using if statement. If statement Elif
statement. So let's add one more thing. So
if the user doesn't input plus, minus times,
or divide, what we want to just tell the user
that will be on iOS was in print, and can
just say, invalid, operator. So let's test
this out by running it. As a user says sisty.
All 90 this time on seven, and you're gonna
do something like dollar sign. It says invalid
operator. But now let's run it again and test
from beginning. So let's test for the addition
nighty 20. Paddy showed us me one 110. Now
let's test for this subtraction. We are 50
we have 70 So pratiques, it gives me minus
20, which is the correct answer analysis for
the multiplication 40, we have four. And then
we have multiplication. Now it says wants
to see, which is correct. And therefore the
division also, we have 80, we have five, we
have division, sustain point zero, now everything
is working fine. So I hope you understood
what we did by building this basic calculator.
In this tutorial, we're going to be talking
about try accept in Python. So what this does
is that it prevents an error. So most of the
times we are working in Python, you're gonna
get a lot of errors, you might do some things
on the program is going to draw an arrow or
an exception. So most of the times this error
just stops, our programmers cut our program,
if our program is running during a specific
task, once an arrow comes up, do program is
down. So to prevent this, we use the try accept
method. Now this is going to get automatically
get an arrow, and then just print whatever
we want to tell the user. Now for example,
you know, when we want to do an addition,
we want the user to input an integer. But
let's say the user inputs a boolean value
or string or something else. So instead of
the, but you know, Python telling train an
assertion or train has an error, we can automatically
tell the user that invalid input that this
is not a string or something like that. So
let me show you how to do that in Python.
So now, let's say I have x is equals to inputs
mfsa integer to be specific input, they will
say, input an integer. And then we print x.
Now when I run this was the inputs are integer,
it print x, it prints seven, the interior.
Now let me run it again, and input a string.
Now you see that it gives me an arrow named
value arrow, in Valley literal for int. So
it's saying h J, K is not an integer. So we
can just automatically get this arrow by ourself,
and then, you know, tell the user instead
of Python, train this exception, which can
stop our program. So for us to do these wants
to do, we're going to say, try, like this,
that oh, this is gonna be in try it after
it, we're going to say, except, don't, we're
just going to print value, not an integer.
So this dry is saying, try all this code,
then if there is any exception at all, just
print value, no an integer, or we can just
print something with drunk because we don't
know what's my cost. The exception is might
not be that user inputted a string, it might
be something else. So there's just say something
went wrong. Please try again. So now when
I run these, and I input theme, now you see
it says something went wrong, please try again,
it didn't roll this error, like the last time,
so does how to basically use try except in
Python, but it's more deep dandies, we can
get, we can use the exit method for some specific
type of exceptions. If I scroll up here, you're
gonna see that this exception it gave us is
called value error. Now we can say, except
there is a value error, then say this. This
one I'm doing right here is just guessing
if there is any error at all, but let's be
specific. Let's see if there is a value error.
So now, if there is a value arrow, a value
error means the user inputted what we don't
want to ask for a string and then input something
else. There was say there now we cannot say
value. Not a string, but not an integer. Now
when I run these Scroll down to something
else. Now it says value not an integer. What
is it getting for only this type of error?
Now let me try to add another arrow intentionally.
So let me say, let me try to call cat needs
with a name. So right here, I'm trying to
concatenate with a variable named name. But
we didn't have any variable like that before.
So it's going to give me a name error. So
when I run these, I would rank. Now you see,
like, if you scroll up, the shows me name
arrow name is not defined. So what if I just
put only accept and I run shows me name is
not defined. So this is because we're trying
to define something that is not like a variable
that is not the so that arrow is from us,
which you can pass something like this. But
now we're trying to pass an arrow from the
user, we're trying to make sure that the user
doesn't input anything wrong. So now we say
except value is not an integer. So I hope
you get the basic concept of try accept method
in Python. Now it also do something like this
changes, but something went wrong. Because
see, something went wrong. Now, when we say
something went wrong, after this, we can say
else. Print, nothing went wrong. Now what
this else is doing is that after typing after
running this code, if there's anything that
went wrong, you should do this. But if everything
went fine, then you should say nothing went
wrong. Now let's run this is asked me for
an integer, I want an integer. Now it prints
out the integer and he says nothing went wrong.
But if I run it, again, inputs A strange noise,
it says something went wrong, but he didn't
say this. So this else is, if everything is
successful, if there is no error, then he's
gonna say something, nothing went wrong. Then
the last one I'm going to show you is called
Finally, is also a key word. Now this is going
to run either there is an error or not. So
I can just say, try accept, finished. So whether
there is an error or not, this is going to
print f seven, there is no arrow, it's print
seven and says try is finished. If I run it
again, and I print a string, so it says something
went wrong, which is these and it says try
accept finish. So that's just saying that
after everything if there's a problem or not
just print that try except finished. Now I
want to talk about reading files in Python.
So sometimes when coding with Python, you
might want to work with some external files,
let's say like a text document, or like, like
a spreadsheet, like an Excel spreadsheet,
or like an HTML file or any external file.
So he wants to know how to read and write
that file. So let's put that to practice.
First of all, let's create a new file right
here. And let's just name it something like
it's been saved these and then I'm just gonna
save it in the same place. I saved these.
So let me see all files. DSR, I'm sure is
located here. First of all, let's cancel this
and make sure we know where this is saved.
Yeah, if I come here, yes. So I see where
it is saved. Project john. Good to right.
Yeah. So now I can create a new file and then
save it. So right here, I can save it as something
like countries. t x t. See, it's ready on
the txt, I can just change it to all files.
So in this countries, I want to have just
a list of random countries. So I can say Ghana.
I can say Mexico. I can say Morocco. Let me
say Spain. I don't have any spelling errors
there. So Ghana, Mexico, Spain. Yeah. Think
as Okay, give me one more see France. So I
think that's okay. So now for us to read this
file, we have to like import it into this
our Python file. So it's very easy to do,
what we just need to do is to say open countries,
which is the file name dot txt. Now, we need
to make sure that these countries are txt
is in the same folder as this Abdo pure so
we can easily navigate to it. And then after
saying this, the second parameter This is
going to take is R. Now what these are means
is we want to read on this file. So once we're
only read this file, we don't want to edit
anything on it. Then there's also something
like W. Not w means want to write on this
file, we want to edit this file. And we also
have our plus a, this a means what to append
to the file, so we can add in the middle of
the file or modify the file or make any changes,
we just want to append to the ending of the
file. And then we have one more call our plus,
this means we want to do both reading and
writing. So give us full capability. So that's
what the outflows is for. But for this part,
we're going to be working only with our so
we're opening this file. And most of the times,
we always want to save it in a variable. So
let's just name a variable file, country file.
And then it should be equals to this. So if
we print and anytime that we open a very file,
and then we open a file, we'll resolve to
make sure that we close the file. So down
here, we can also say, country file, dot close.
So this is to make sure that our closing the
file. And then in between those, we can do
anything you want with a file. So now I can
just simply print golf file. So first of all,
I want to check if this file is readable if
I have access to read it. So I'm just going
to do is to say cow file dot readable. Now
this is just going to return a boolean value
true or false. So let me run this. So now
it says no such file in directory, countries
dot txt. So let's make sure. So what we're
going to do is to navigate into this folder,
and make sure we create that. So let's go
there. I think I have it in right here. So
this is in project. Okay. And then Django.
So I think I'll be right here. And then there
is countries dot txt, c o u n t ri is CE o
u n t ri ES. So it says that we can't open
so it says no such file or directory. So what
we just need to do is to do something like
this. These, although this is not the reason
why we're having this error. So when we run
this thing gives us that error. So the best
thing to do is to just take the main directory
to dads and then paste it needs this slash
like this. So now let's try to run it again.
Now you see it says it gives us this error.
Now the reason for this error is this slash
right here, so we're just going to change
it to slash the forward slash right here also
And then when we run it again, now you see
it says true. So the reason we add the arrow
is because right here is always in a backward
slash, but we are using in Python, it has
to be in a forward slash. So now we are successfully
navigating to dat countries dot txt. So when
we say, print confer the redo, so we're asking
is, do we have access to read this file, it
says true. So we don't have access, we can
read it is going to tell us false or not that
this is true, then I think we are good to
go. So now that we can read this file, what
we just want to do is to bring something like
we can see curl file dot read line. Now when
I say this red line is going to print the
first line of this file, which is Ghana. So
once I print these, you see now that it's
printing Ghana, and this is like a sequence.
So if I print this file, again, if I say print,
and I see a cow file dot read line again,
now what is it going to bring the second line,
and knows that I didn't make any change the
same code, but when I run it, it prints Ghana,
unmusical, secondary, do this and just print,
everything I have in the body most recommended
way is to just say, Gulf print lines, now
brings lines is going to print everything
for you in a list, so it's going to print
everything out, do lines of your vendor file,
and then store it in a list. And now we can
just get let's say the first one, I say wants
to get the first one. Now we are willing Ghana
gang kids. Last one. Now you see we are France.
So that's how to use the realize function.
And then we can also making more cool by looping
through this. So we can see for, again, changes
to a for loop for fells in curve dot read
lines, like this, then we want to print we
just basically want to print files. So now,
when I run it, you see just basically print
all the old lines in which I have. So the
best way to call this is lines not Hell's
so lines. So when I run it again, same thing,
it just print all the lines if I was a commie
and make some change, like say Ghana is a
country a free on the nice CV. As I run it,
that changes automatically made by move up.
You see right here, the first line says Ghana
is a country in Africa. So I'll be getting
the concept of reading files in Python. These
are you can read files read by lines, really
by text and stuff like that. Now let's move
straight to the next part of this tutorial.
In this part, we're going to be talking about
writing files in Python. So in the last part,
we talked about opening or reading by reading
files, reading external files in Python, but
in this part, we're going to be talking about
appending. This is some text to the file,
or those writing the old file again. So first,
to write a file, right here, we need to change
this R to W. So now when we change this out
to W, let's just remove these as then we can
just say golf dots, right. And then what you
want to do is to just write the ofa. Now you
can see that this is the file, but if I input
something, you know, like, this is the new
text. Now when I run this, you'll see that
nothing happens with that coming year, you
see that it has been changed. Everything I
was there was gone. So we wrote the whole
file again. Now this might be useful. Let's
say you want to write a new file. It's very
useful. So the The reason why it ruins everything,
again was because it was an existing file.
So it overrode like a router need. But this
is mainly used for creating a new file. So
let's say we want to have country now. Now
let me say, this is the new country. Now once
I save it, and run, if I call into this directory
right here in my command. So I'm going to
do C, D, enter the directory. Okay, it
doesn't go to that directory. But what this
does is that it's created. It's great this
new file called country dot txt in that directory,
so let's go there normally. So right here,
you see that we have a new file called country,
let's change it and just say new file. Now
when I run it, let's remove this space. When
I run it, you see nothing happens, we're right
here, new file is created. Now, that was all
to create a new file and automatically write
something inside it. So let's just Ctrl Z
back to the countries we were using. So now,
I have this country's file, let's say I want
to append something to the bottom like a new
text, what I can just do is something like,
well, to append, I must make sure I changes
w two a. And then right here, what I'm just
gonna do is you just say, file dot right,
then this is a new line. Now when I run these
knots in opposing determinar, or when I come
here is a pen, this is a new line to eat.
But you can see it joins it together. Now
let's see how to form a new line I want this
to be aligned to I can just come here. And
I can see backslash n. Now these are magically
going to take you to a new line, when I run
it, again, are kamiah, you should now know
that this is on a new line. So that is basically
how to append in Python. Now you can do this
for various types of videos file extension.
As you know, we did this for the text document,
which is dot txt, you can even use a Python
file to open a new Python file. Now let's
put that in action. Now let's say want to
open a new file and name it new dot p y. And
then in that new dot p y i want to write and
they weren't allowed to write in it. So right
here Now, let me just crude, these, I can
just easily write a Python code, I can say
print. This is a new file. So right here,
I just wrote a simple Python code. And then
obviously, we have to use the backslash before
we can write a code. So right here, I use
this print, this is a new file, and it's gonna
be in this new dots pure. So now when I run
these, you'll see now that we have a new.py
file. And then I can just when I come here,
I can run new dot p y, you see now that it
just simply prints out this is a new file,
which was the command or the line we put in
yet. So it is also very important and very
useful writing the new files in Python. Now
we're going to be talking about classes and
objects in Python. So I must say that Python
is an object oriented programming language.
So this means that anything that deals with
classes, objects, and things like that, were
classified as object oriented. So classes
is just like a feature in Python, say something
like a function. A function is a feature that
Python as their classes is also a feature
that Python book classes now is like a constructor
of objects. So you might not understand what
I'm saying now, but when I show you the code,
I'm sure you get it more easily. So a class
is like a construct of different objects on
the class, we have various objects. So let's
just go ahead and show how to do a class.
So now I want to go to class, we're just going
to say class using the class keyword, then
we can say, my class. Or then on the year,
we can see x equals to five. Now we have this
class. This is the class, the name of the
class is my class. And then we have a x, which
is an object on that this my class on x equals
to five. Now want to create an object, this
is actually a value, or I can say an attribute
on the class. Now, let's say we want to create
an object using this class, we're just going
to do is to do something like p one, something
like that. It goes to my class. Though we
initialize it, there will gossip print be
one dot x. Now this is going to print five,
because we're saying that P one is equals
to my class, which is this class, then we'll
just say print p one dot x, once I run this,
it brings five. So that's how to basically
print dude that now let's talk about the init
function. the oddest thing I just said, Now,
those are the basic concepts of class where
we can basically use them in real life lesson
you reward things and reward projects. But
the init function allows us to initialize
different values in our class. Now, for example,
we have this class, let's say this class is
named person. And then on the other class,
we're gonna have a function. Gonna take two
underscores in it like that, then you're gonna
have some parameters self. Now this stuff
is gonna be there is just there. That's the
way it is. And then let's say it does name,
which we are going to put our, let's say,
as age. And then. So we put our colon just
like a normal function. So let's remove these.
And then to determine the name of this self,
dot name, can be equals to name. And there
we go, oh my god. And then we're gonna do
the same thing for the age. So that age is
equals to age, just like that. And then let's
just initialize it the way we did here. So
P one equals to my equals to person this time
around. But now we have to give it this name,
and this age. So we'll say the name, we can
say the name is john. And then the age is
87. Now once we print p, one does name. You'll
see that it gives us, john. Okay, so now it
says indentation error. So this is under this
function supposed to be indented. So let's
run that again. Now you see that it's printed
john, we can also print B one dot h. And they
want to see that it prints at seven. Now also
make this allow user to input. So we can say
name is equals to input alkazi, enter your
name. And then we can say age is equals to
input a, which you can say, and your age.
And then once we have the name and age of
the user stored, we can just replace it with
these as a name. I say Ah, now when we run
these, first of all, it asks us for a name,
but I said team, it's the NIH, NIH just prints
team at night. So we can also use a class
to do something like that. So classes are
very broad in Python, and it is very, very
used in Python. But there are still some other
objects properties that we can do that let's
say we want to delete a property from these
icons or delete this age. So let's just remove
these and then let's give it the 10 Join.
Now, let's say wants to delete his age from
it, what we can just do is to just say, dl
p one dot h. Now, once we delete p one dot
age, this is not going to have this age in
it again. And then we can just even delete
these objects in total by just saying delete
p one, once we run this, this is gonna be
deleted. If we try to print p one after that,
it won't work. Now, he says, Your name not
defined that because we've already deleted
p one, there is nothing like that. So we can
print what is not. And then we also have one
feature we can use in the class. So right
here, let's say we have a class that is named
person. And for now, we don't know what to
put there. We don't know the values, and we
just want to continue coding. Okay, so to
encode pass, so this pass allows us to bypass
any error. So if we have like, this class
that is empty, we can just put pass for now
they come back, like add attribute. So it
was I put pass, and I run, this could not
innopolis. But if I just only put class person
and I run you see is gonna give me an arrow.
So this passage just to bypass the arrow,
so we can continue with our code for the main.
Wow. So I hope you get the concept of class
and objects in Python. Now we're gonna be
talking about inheritance in Python. So Narita
simply means taking from an existing class,
and then getting all the metals and everything
in there and putting it in a new class. So
you're gonna understand what I mean in a bit.
So let's say we have an existing class in
this file name new dot p y, I just created
this file we actually created earlier in this
video, let's have a class name, student. And
then let's say that name is equals to same
age is equals to 34. And LSA gender is equals
to mu. Now we have this class here, we can
easily import it by saying count can see from
new.py import student, which is this right
here. So now we are importing student. So
instead of saying from noodle spy, we can
just say from New without adding p y, the
extension, it automatically gets that we are
importing from this file. But before we got
impulse, we need to make sure that this new
up I in the same directory. So let me just
cancel this, we need to make sure the same
directory. So now I have this new class named
person, what I just want to do is to just
see this student. So I'm getting everything
from this to dance class, which we narrated,
I'm just putting in this space in clubs. So
I just put pass to avoid any error. Now I
can say p one is equals to person. And I can
now say p one dot name, I can just said print.
b1 does name. Now once I run this, you see
it prints theme, all the way from New Wi Fi.
bunchgrass is running up.pi. So that is the
basic concept of inheritance in Python. It
inherits every single thing which we have
in this class. And it does bring gates right
in this class. So it's like a duplicate of
that class was not a duplicate because different
names in different file. So it's called inheritance
in Python. In this tutorial, I'm going to
be talking to you about the Python interpreter
or the Python shell. So the Python shell is
an application that is automatically installed
whenever you install Python on your computer.
So let me just quickly open up my python shell.
So this is my python shell right here. As
you can see, Id issue So let me show you how
I opened this up, you can just come here and
just search for ID l II. If you have Python
installed issue automatically bring that out
and just eat open. But since I already have
this open, so the Python shell is just like
a smaller environment where I can run on quickly
test some Python code. Like everything we've
learnt in this tutorial, I can easily code
them yeah, like, let me say, print you enjoying
this tutorial. Once I press enter, you see
it prints that immediately, it automatically
runs that code. As I press Enter. And we can
also says like a very, we're gonna say name
is equals to theme. And then we can now print
name. variety in the Python interpreter, we
can also print the name without even writing
print. If you just say name, it automatically
prints it out. Well, that's only when you're
just testing your code yet in your Python
shell, you can do that in your main editor.
Now we can do a lot of things like I'm sure
we can use a for loop. Let me say for letter
in same Yeah, like that. Then I can just see
print later. Now you see it's automatically
prints team, I can do anything in year I can
even write a class. And I can see the class
in the person. And then I can see name is
equals to john. And then right here I can
say p one is equals to person. And then I
can say p one dot name. This is just gonna
print me john. I can basically do everything
I do in the code editor right here. I can
have an if statement. Let me say if b wonders
name is equals to john, then print Yes, it
is. So now he's gonna print Yes, it is because
pianos name is obviously equals to john. And
then we also perform our basic arithmetic,
like two plus three gives us five, nine minus
zero gives us nine. And everything which we
can do on the normal place. Because we'll
define a function, let's say we have a function
to say, I and then let it pass a name. I let
the name be unnamed. Under let's say print.
I name now let's see I give it john. Now you
see it says I joined. So almost everything
which we can do in year, we can also do it
in our main editor is this like the same thing
but is not advisable to use these when building
normal projects or stuff like that. This is
just basically for testing or anything like
that. So let's also try more things like try
accept. So try, let's say age should be equals
to any of the inputs of enter age under this
glues that so I wanted us to be age and then
we just say exit Yeah, we must make sure we
have the right indentation. So except it gives
us an error because of the interpretation.
But we can basically do all these writing
in our Python ideally is what I want to show
you. So sometimes you might run into this
error of indentation syntax. Because is the
indentation is not really obviously clear.
Just like the way it is right here in Visual
Studio code. So that's why it's recommended
to use your normal editor and not basically
an ideally for editing, but often get the
concept of a Python shell. That's going to
go above the Python interpreter. So now we're
going to be creating a simple signup and login
system in Python. So we're going to be putting
in everything we've learned in this tutorial,
and then building this simple program. So
as you can see here, it says, create your
account. Now it says the input username, I'm
just going to input admin, and it says we
should input password. I'm going to input
admin. As the password now says user admin
created successfully login now. So what this
program does is that it creates this user,
obviously one or Jenny, we read database,
we're just storing this in variable. Once
we run this program, again, we have to create
again. So it's just four practices. So once
we create an account, and he says use our
greatest This is really, it says login now.
Now when we try to log in, if what we type
is the same with these, then automatically
will be logged in what is different if our
username is wrong or password is wrong, then
you just say invalid credentials. Now let
me try to log in with normal. And I say admin
now says user logged in successfully. Let
me run this again. Let me let me now create
another one admin, again, admin. Now it says
admin created and wants me to login. If I
now say admin, by the password, and I add
to n, I click enter. You see now it says invalid
credentials. So this Python program we're
going to build is gonna get whether the password
is right, or the username is right or not.
So let's go straight into that. So let's just
quit these come back here. We can also quit
this. So what's one to do? We're going to
take in four parameters. So the first one
is going to be the user name and the password
for creating accounts. And the second and
the third, and fourth is going to be user
name and password for login. So let's do that.
Let's say user name will be equals to so this
is the first is our new for creating account.
Because to our inputs, I will say and user
name. And then for the password, say the same
thing inputs into a password. And there was
users enter the username and password, we
can just print to the user and simply say
that your account has been created successfully.
And then now we know how to tell the user
to login. So let's print again, login now.
So now once you have another variable, which
we use our name to, should be close to input
and user name. And then the password for the
login. password to input and password. So
now we know the Jq DS is equals to this. So
just simply say if user name is equals to
user name two, and password is equal to password
two. So this is our if statement saying this
and these must be equivalent. That's why we
use and if we use all is going to be wrong,
because if the user name is correct, and the
password is wrong, it's still going to look
to us I so want to make sure the two are correct.
It took correct response before we log in.
So once it's correct, we can just say print
logged in successfully. But it was wrong else.
We just want to print invalid credentials
like this. So let's just come on to the top
here and print something like that. Create
accounts now now this should work let's run
it was just so we create a user name let's
just say to me the password see me now your
account has been created successfully log
in now see me on the password see me now it
says login successfully. Let's run it again
and try a wrong one others hai hai hai, hai
hai hai. Now when I say the user news, ah,
ah, ah, ah, ah y. But the puzzle is Ui Ui
Ui. Now, you see, it says invalid credentials.
So that's how to build that basic Python program
using getting user input. And if statement.
I hope you understood what we did here, if
you did it, you cannot go back in like five
minutes ago, and just watch from there, I'm
sure you're going to get it. In this tutorial,
we're going to be talking about modules in
Python. So modules basically allows you to
get the function class or everything present
in another file, it allows you to implement
it and use those same functions in your own
file or project. So modules is very, very
versatile is very widely used in Python. Everybody
use modules. So let's say I have this file
named noodles py. Now, I have a function named
say I. And then that say, I function, I just
wanted to print. I know, Bob is functioning
here, I can import these, I'll just say imports
new. Now this new is starting as a module
for this my file. Now right here, I can just
simply say, new, don't say I was I CDs, I
run this file, you see that it automatically
says, so does how to use modules in Python.
Now there are a lot of things we can do with
modules. And modules are very versatile. So
if you want to, like I wanted to use a function
that says, instead of coding from scratch,
there's possibility that someone out there
already written that same function, or similar
to what you want to do. And rarely as he does
a module or library, in mutual gain, get and
implement. So now modules are in just on your
local laptop or your local PC like this, modules
are hosted online. So Python as something
we call Pip, which I'm going to talk more
about in the next video, the next part. So
all the modules are more hosted online. Let's
say you're looking for a module that wants
you to just do a specific task. And you know
that yes, of course, someone else would have
done this, then you can just go and search
for that module, or search around research
there, you're gonna see that module online.
In the next part, I'm going to show you how
to implement peep and then install all those
kind of modules on your computer. So in this
part, I'm going to be introducing you to something
will go beep. Now P is used for installing
external modules from the web to your local
PC. Now, as I explained in the last video
was modules, they basically allow you to get
us function from another file of Amanda library.
So PIP allows you to install a module from
the internet to your laptop. Now, if we go
online, and then we just search for something
like Python modules, then we can just see,
let's see. Let's go to P ypi. So there's a
site called pure ipi. Now, this is where all
the Python modules almost all the Python modules
are being boosted. As you can see 200 and
H 2000 project. So he just basically saying
200,000 libraries or modules that are hosted
on this site. Now you can see that each one
has different tasks they do. Now see this
module is for Spotify recommendation. Let's
say ah, let's say we want a module like, let's
just go to the home page. And let's see what
we want. So you can also see trending products.
As training modules, a lot of different things.
And then let's say, we want to let's go to
browse development of framework. Let's just
click on this. So now this is the name of
a module. Let me look for Swan the as a description.
So Django deep serializer. Django is actually
a web framework, which allows you to build
websites using Python. So this one is saying
a Django deep serializer. So that's what this
particular module does. So while doing studies
on our computer, we just type pip install
Django, deep serializer. The way it is being
said here, then how do we now where do we
run this command, if you're on a Mac, just
open your terminal, move your new windows,
open your command prompt, and the Angelus
basically the pip install Django, I think
deep ip serializer. Now, if this is the library
or module you want to use, you can just run
this command line, and then it's good to go
I installed this module or this library on
your local computer. Now you can see it says
down collecting Django, deep serializer, then
downloading Django deep serializer 0.1. Point
three and all those. So it's setting up all
these. Yeah, so you see it says successfully
installed Django deep serializer. Now I have
this on my computer. Now very sure that if
I want to import this, I'm just gonna look
for our say we got imported. Those guys good.
Okay, they didn't mention that here because
we are not running a Django project. So you
don't need to understand what I'm saying for
now about Django. But this is how to basically
install a module or library using PIP on your
computer that does what PIP is basically about
the and this beep. You don't need to listen
download peep externally, once you install
Python be automatically installs with it.
That's why Well, once you install your Python
is good. If they ask if you want to install
our component is good holistic, yes. And they
just add Python to Python just tick everything.
So the oldest components will be installed
when you want to use them later. So PIP is
automatically installed with Python. So if
I come here, we just say for Pip. You see,
he says, Let me say Python, let me be specific.
So PIP Python, is a package management system
written in Python used to install and manage
software packages. So as I said, Pip is used
for downloading, or in this case, installing
packages. So modules are Swick also called
m packages. So P is the manager is what downloads
it and store it on your laptop or your computer.
So does the basic concept you need to crash
about peep. So guys, that's gonna be all for
this tutorial. I hope you learned something
and enjoyed the video. Welcome to the Django
Crash Course. The main purpose of this video
is to introduce you to Django and show you
all the concepts you need to start building
your own project using Django. In this tutorial,
we're not going to be building any full project
bow we're going to be doing is taking each
Django concept step by step using it in a
practical use case. And then by the end of
this video, you will know how to build your
own projects using Django. Now, this tutorial
is mainly focused for beginners, because we're
going to be starting from the basics to the
more complex stuff in Django. So a quick introduction
to Django. Django is a Python web framework.
This means that using Python, we can build
web applications with Django. So without wasting
any time, let's get straight into this video
is a list of what we're going to be covering
in this video. So let's get straight into
introduction and installation of Django. Now,
the first thing we need to do is to install
and set Django up on our computer. So I'm
on a Windows as if you're on a Mac or you're
on a Linux, the installation process is quite
similar, just only some differences in the
command line. But I'm also going to see what
you need to do if you're on a different OS
from mine. So this is just the job Go official
site. But now before you need to install Django
before you can install Django, you need to
have Python installed on your computer, because
we're going to be using a Python package manager
called Pip. And that only comes when you have
Python installed. And Django is a Python framework,
so why not. So if you don't have Python installed,
just go to Google. And then it's very easy,
you can just search Python download, and then
just click on the first website. Yeah, so
you're gonna see the latest version, yeah,
and you can just easily click on this to download
it. Now when you download it, you're just
gonna install it like a normal application.
So I'm not going to do that, because I have
that installed already on my own laptop. So
if you don't have this installed, just come
here, download this, and then everything is
going to be fine. So now we can quit this
tab. So now we have Python installed on our
computer. What we just need to do next is
to open up our command prompt. Now these are
command prompt zero are going to be doing
most of the server running the installations
and everything we need to do in our Django
project. So the first thing we want to do
is to install Django, it's very easy, what
we just need to type is pip install Django.
Now this command line is going to install
Django on our computer, so it's going to install
Django on the system, so we can access it
from anywhere. But I have Django installed
already. So what is going to tell me is requirement
already satisfied. If you work with Python
very well, you know that once you have Python
module, or library or package installed is
going to tell you requirement already satisfied.
So as you can see, it says requirement already
satisfied. So I'm gonna do I'm just gonna
close these, and then just keep it like that.
Now, you can see that we have Django installed
on our computer. And the version that is going
to install is the latest version. Now I'm
not really sure if it's 3.2 or 3.1. I know
that won't Django three or so right now. And
that is what is going to install the latest
version. But let's say for a different project
for each Django project, you want to have
some particular packages just for only that
project not for on your entire computer. I
also have a different Django version just
for a specific reason on each project. Now
what we need to do is to create a virtual
environments, virtual environment, I will
see it's like a little box where everything
your project is stored in. So it's just like
a mini environment where you can assess everything
about your project. So the Django version
of that particular break is different, the
whatever version you are using for any of
that package installing can be different.
So it's just for that particular project is
not going to be available in the old computer.
So for it to do that you need to first of
all install a virtual environment on your
computer. Now the counselors my driver mate
you can have, the one I use that I recommend
is called Anaconda. But that also has his
installation process. And that is mostly using
Anaconda using machine learning because of
the packages that comes with it. But for this
project, we're just gonna stick with a very
simple virtual environment. And this virtual
environment is very easy. We are just going
to install it on our command line right here.
But it was Anaconda you have to download the
application, just like we did for Python and
then install. So if you want to check that
out, there are countless tutorial series on
YouTube about it, you can check it out. But
let's just install a virtual environment right
here on our command line interface. And this
virtual vironment is called Virtual env wrapper.
So to install it, we'll say beef install Virtua
envy, rubber, and then after doing this put
on iPhone, and then we'll say when and this
command line is going to install it on our
computer. So again, I have this installed,
so he's going to tell me requirement already
satisfied, but for you, it should say should
go ahead and install it. So I'll just say
show the loading bar downloading or something
like that. Now note that if you're on a Mac,
when you are installing all these packages,
you need to type PIP three. So you can see
that right here on the windows we type pip
install, then we type the package name, but
if you're on a Mac, you will type p3 install
Then the package name. So that's just the
main difference within the windows and the
Mac installation. So now that we have these
virtual environment rapa installed, let's
now go ahead and create a virtual environment
in Java Django project. So first to do this,
we're going to say MK, which is short form
of MC, then virtual envy. So now when we say
MK virtual MV, we're gonna leave a space,
and then we'll put the name of the virtual
environment. So you can give it any name,
let's say you are working with a project named
online dictionary, that's your Django project,
you can also give the virtual environment
name as online dictionary. So just so that
you can easily access it whenever you want.
You can give it any name you like. But I just
personally love giving it the name of my project.
But now, they just give it a name of my app.
So MK MV might help them get it Enter. Now,
this is gonna create a virtual environment
named my app. And then once it's done creating
that particular virtual environment, what
is going to do is automatically going to activate
that environment. So this will take a few
seconds. As you can see, we have this installed
already. And then before we installed it,
besides the directory of where we are, we
didn't see anything yet. But after now you
can see we have my app. So this is showing
you that it does is it has created the virtual
environment called my hub, and it activated
it. So as I say, you remember I said that
we were using a virtual environment, it is
like a different box from the old computer.
But before we can assess that box before ourselves,
our small environment, we need to activate
it. So now that we've activated this virtual
environment, we can, anything we are doing
in this particular command line is going to
be in Dev and drive vironment. So now, I'm
going to install Django, I when I install
Django by saying Pip, install Django knows
that if you're on a Mac, you should be free
install Django. So now when I install Django
and hit enter, is not going to tell me requirement
already satisfied again. And by now you should
know the reason why that's because we have
Django installed on our computer. But we don't
have it installed in this virtual environment,
which is separate from what we have on our
computer. So as you can see, it is installing
Django again, which is let's see if we have
Yeah, installing three points two points to
the latest version. So that is the difference
between your virtual environment and your
normal computer environment or whatever you
want to call it. But as you can see right
here, we add this environment as we created
the virtual environment, it automatically
activated. So for you to know, if you've actually
if you are in a virtual environment, or if
the environment is activated, you are going
to see these brackets and then the name of
the environment in it before the directory.
So you know, when you first open your terminal
or command line, the first thing you're gonna
see is the directory where you are in a virtual
environment, you will first see the name of
the virtual environment in brackets, and then
the directory that should show you that you
are in Dev and driver match. What if we close
this command line, or we close this command
prompt and come back, you know, we aren't
going to see this my app again. So I will
now tap into that environment or we activate
or enter the environment. So I'm also going
to talk about that in a few minutes. So for
now, you can see that we have Django installed
in this environment. That's very good. Now,
we're in a virtual environment for a while
let's move straight to Django. We have Django
installed. The next thing we want to do is
to create a Django project because we want
to work with Django. Now Django has this command
line, which allows you to create a project
a new project. So first of all, you need to
make sure that you are in the directory you
want. Let me open my folder real quick. So
this is my folder. This directory is what
is in this command line. So you can see right
here, project slash Django tutorial. By komiya.
You see down in projects Django tutorial.
So this command line is open is open in this
direction. So anything I'm creating, I'm creating
a new Django project is going to be created
in this directory. Now, I'm just gonna say
Django admin, start project. And then let's
give it a name of my app. So yeah, my app
is okay. My project. Let's just give him my
project. So you can see Now we are the virtual
environment in my app. And then this is the
command line that we're gonna use to create
a new Django project. So once I hit Enter,
and I'm just gonna give it a few seconds.
So you can see, it didn't show anything here.
But if I come back into this page, you see
now that I have a new project named my project.
So let me come back real quick. We did was
Django admin start project my project. Now,
this is going to allow us to create a new
project Django admin start project, then the
name of the project after so if you're working
on, let's say, an online search engine, or
you want to name it, getting search, auto
massage, or whatever you want to name it.
So you can say Django admin start project,
then online search engine, or whatever you
want to name your. So that is how to create
a simple Django project. Now, if I press dir,
I see that I have a new file, a new folder
yet, let me opt into that folder, CD my projects.
So now I'm in my project folder. If I press
dir again, you can see I have money that was
on my projects, I'm going to explain all these,
they may look confusing at first, I'm going
to explain all these I promise. So I'm just
going to quickly explain how you can also
do all these things in Mark. Now creating
a new project is exactly the same thing. Just
like Django, I think admin start project my
project exactly the same thing. And then right
here, when I press dir, what I did was to
see all the files on folders in this particular
directory. So if you're on a Mac, what you
need to type is LS. Once you type l s, let
me just quickly type it right here. This so
this if I click enter is not recognized because
I'm on Windows but the only mark is going
to show you a list just like this of all the
files and folders you have in that directory.
And what I did was to go into that my project
folder, exactly the same thing with Mark just
type cd, my project you're going to go in.
So now we have this let's come back. Let me
go into this project. What do we see here
we see a file Monday money.py. And then we
see a folder, which is given the name of our
project, which is my project. Let me open
it. And we see like, a bunch of files here.
And I'm going to explain all of these. But
before I do that, let's bring this project
into Visual Studio code. So now, we have talked
about doing everything in the command line
interface, creating the project. But what
do we actually want to code. So we need a
to an ID, a code editor, whatever you want
to call it. And the one I love using is Visual
Studio code. So you might want to use auto
me my own is pi charm in my own or use warehouse,
why Sublime Text, but I use Visual Studio
code, anyone you want to use is fine, as long
as you know how to use it. So now I have Visual
Studio code here. I'm just gonna say, Come
here, click on file. And then I'm going to
open up a new folder. I'm not Oh, yeah, I'm
opening up a new folder. So she'd been project
Django tutorial, my projects. So I want to
open this folder, select folder. should take
a few seconds. Good. That's why I like Visual
Studio code, because it's really quick and
lightweight, compared to some other extent
from other ID. So this should open right now.
So give that a few seconds. And, yeah, so
as that is opening them quickly say something.
So it has opened right there. But let me just
close these. So remember that I said, What
if one of us says this particular virtual
environments, let's say we close this command
line interface, I want to assert this virtual
environment. I'm going to show you how to
do that in our Visual Studio code. So let's
just come here. So first of all, this is the
files we get when we create a new Django project.
This money does py file, you don't want to
touch it throughout your coding throughout
when you're building anything you're building.
It is I personally, I there might be some
developers will manipulate this fiber. Normally,
as a beginner, even as an intermediate Django
developer, you don't want to touch this file,
there's nothing you want to do here. This
file is just to allow us to do several things
in our project, like run our project on the
local host. So we can see what we are building,
migrate databases, and I don't want to get
into details, because you might not understand
now, but you understand later. But for now,
you don't want to touch this file. So let's
just close that up. And then when we come
into my project, we have an INI file. Yes,
this file is empty. For now, there's not much
to explain in this file legislatively like
this. So what's it gonna use all these files
later in this tutorial, so I'm just showing
you like a boilerplate that Django brings
up when we create a new file, so we're gonna
use this as gi is an important one. It we
don't need much manipulation in this is just
one line of code or something just to assess
some socket and stuff. So just leave that
for now. And then this settings file is like
the bedrock of your whole project. So if you
do anything wrong in this settings file, it's
going to affect your project. So we need this
file, we need this file a lot. We're gonna
use it to like this installed apps, we're
going to do some things in this, we scroll
down to see where we have templates. This
is empty. For now we're gonna do some things.
And then we keep going, Yeah, we're gonna
do a lot of things in this settings file is
just the file that has all the everything
we need in our project. So all the configurations,
and the apps when installing anything in all
our data bases is inside this file, we're
gonna configure it. So now we have this URLs
dot p y file. Now let me explain what is your
spy file does this weird up to y file, what
it does is what we're going to come in here.
And then we're going to specify all the URLs
we want in our project. So for example, let's
say we have a website named www dot COVID
tomi.ml. Now we have that website, when a
user just comes to code return mi.ml. What
page do we want to open is you are going to
specify it, but whatever user goes into COVID
tomi.ml slash newsletter, or slash blog post
or something. Now slash is another web page.
Another URL is here. We're gonna specify it
this year, we're gonna configure each URL
we have in our project to us. We're gonna
go talk about that later in this course. And
then these Ws gi, yeah is kind of similar
to the SGI. But for now we're gonna leave
this. So right, we have all these. Now, what
I want to do, I actually love working in this
command prompt. But what I want to do now,
first of all, I want to deactivate this virtual
environment. So it's very easy. All I just
need to do is type D, arc safe v. Now you
can see we're not in the virtual environment
again. But now I'm away from Java travelmate,
how can I assess it back? Let's go into VS
code. In VS code, we can have our terminal
our small terminal right here. So we don't
need to jump back to command prompt every
time we need to do something. So right here,
you'll see that we have this terminal, it
was going to give it a few seconds to load
up. That shouldn't take too long. So right
here in this terminal, we're going to Yes,
this is a we're going to assess our project
is ready in this project directory. Now let's
say we want to go into the virtual environment
very, very easy. We just need to do say walk
on a shame of this. And then we'll say the
name of the virtual environment in Mr. Vijay
Verma was my No. Normally, we should have
something like this right here, what is not
yours? Let's come into our Vish command prompt
and say work on my app. So right here, you
can see that it brings out the virtual environment
back that showing that we are in this virtual
environment. So in VS code, it is supposed
to do the same thing, but I'm sure that is
because it's using maybe another type of command
line interface or something else. But yeah,
that's gonna be a minor problem. We can just
overlook that. But this is how we can deactivate
from a virtual environment and go back into
the virtual environment is very easy. So let
me just quit this. Now, what we did was, we
created a new Django project, we installed
Django, we talked about virtual environment,
I explained all the files for this files,
which was created when we created a Django
project, I explained the command line interface,
we've done a lot to introduce Django. So now
I'm sure it should at least have a graceful
just understand what Django is about. And
now we can start working with it. So now that
we have our Django project created, what I
want to talk about is the Django app. Now,
this might sound funny, but there is a difference
between your Django project and your Django
app. I'm going to explain it using a popular
site. Now the Django apps are like subsets
of the main project, we have this project
created right here. Inside this project, we
can have multiple Django apps, so they're
like subsets of a particular app. But why
would we use a Django app one, we just already
have a project here. Let me use for example,
like Instagram has come to explain. So we
have Instagram. In Instagram, you know that
we have different sections, we have the feed
the photo feed, we have the marketplace, we
have the direct messages, we have the story
and plenty of other things. So Instagram might
be the main project, just if we're using Django
For this example, let's say Instagram is the
main project, then we have the direct messages,
that can be a particular app, another app
just for only that direct message, we can
have another app for the marketplace, we can
have another app for the reuse, we can have
another for your stories, we can have another
app just for the photo feed. Now, each app
can just have a particular function is doing.
Now, in plain most projects, you don't have
too much apps, you might just have one project
on one app with the project, I've been doing
that as well. But if you like have a very
big project that you want to do that will
require plenty apps, there is no problem doing
that. So that's what apps are in Django, they
the main project, and they are the subsets
of that project, which are apps for different
features. You can also have one up your one
project or one up and you can just have multiple
features. That is also totally fine. It depends
on how you just want to arrange your project.
But one project I want at least I will create
a Django app very easy, just like we created
the Django project. First of all, we need
to make sure that we are in the environment.
And then there we are in the directory of
our project, the root directory. Now when
I say root directory, what I mean is the directory
which goes contains the money.py file. That
is the root directory of this Django project.
So we can confirm the wind is the root directory
by saying Dir. So we see money.py. This tells
us that yet you're in the root directory.
Now to create an app does when we use this
manage dot p y, in earlier I explained that
this money does pure y, we don't really want
to code anything inside it, but we use the
file a lot for different things. Now, creating
an app is one of the times we use that money.py
file, we'll just say python manage.py. Start
up. And then we can name this my app, since
I do have my project name in my app. And then
when we hit enter, is not going to give us
a response right here on the command line
interface. But if we go into our Visual Studio
code, by Come here, you see now that I have
a new folder named my hub. And under the I
have a new, another folder and a bunch of
files. So let me just quickly go around and
explain if so this in it, we really don't
do much inside. This is just for the migrations
for the models, I don't understand that later.
This admin.py Django has this beautiful admin
interface, which allows you to control your
size or maintain your size you view or the
database is everything you need to know about
your site. And this admin spy file is where
we register some database you want to put
in there, and some other things we want to
do. And then this ABS Wi Fi, we also use it
but not too much. But let's just keep that.
And then these modules are py file is the
file where we create all our database. Now
dealing with database in Django is quite different.
Because we don't need to write a single line
of SQL code. I'm also going to explain that
later in this course. And that's what the
model is a PDF file is for the tests, we we
use it in some cases, but not four times,
so it's not frequently used. And these views
are pure is where all the main thing, Apple.
So what we're going to look at this video,
if you want in this video, is where we're
gonna start from. So now, let me just quit
these. Now, f of these. Now, let's say we
want to start with the URLs configuration.
Now the URLs configuration when I say that
what I mean, as I explained earlier, I said
is let's say you have a project, and then
each each link, let's say you have a website
like youtube.com, then each particular link
is a different URL. So that's what the URLs
configuration is about, you're going to understand
that in a bit. So what we just want to do
now is to configure URLs, let me just make
this more understandable. So we have this
Django project.com website. If I click on
overview, or I click on downloads, let me
call me I click on download. Now you see I
have Django project.com. Slash download. This
slash download is another URL. This Django
project is calm, the main one is the main
URL as the URL when what the user should see
when it enters our site. And we are slash
download because I know that URL, we have
to configure all of these inside our Django
project that is what is called URL routing,
or URL mapping, or URL configuration. I can
call it anything. So to start with, these
are not going to come into my app, and then
in my app, but what are the URLs file. So
we're gonna create a new file and name it
urls.pi. And we need to import something from
Django called path. So say from Django dot
URLs, import path. Now this part is going
to allow us to us multiple URLs in our list.
So we're going to have a new list called URL
patterns. And this list is going to take all
the URL we have in our project. So we can
see path. This is how we specify a new URL.
And then I just have to I think there's a
called codes or whatever they're called. And
then now I say views that index I'm going
to explain all of these, and then name equals
to index. So we import a path from Django
dot URLs. That is what allows us to configure
each URL you can see we are using the paths
that we imported. And then we just have a
new list named URL patterns. And then we have
multiple Like, if you want another URL, you
can just add a new URL new arrow like that.
That is to shoot is a list. Now let's use
pat on open a parenthesis. And then we have
this empty quote or Yeah, I think, then one
is empty. That means that is the root URL.
Let's say we have something like slash download.
Slash download now means that when a user
goes to our website slash download, then this
is what you happen. So but for now, when it's
empty, it means the comeback, just the main
sites, a main project, where we say slash
download is miss our site slash download.
So for now, this is the main site, and then
views dot index. So the way you are works
in Django is that we enrich your recipe file,
we configure the URLs, but when a user comes
to this particular URL, what will happen?
Now that is going to be done in the views
dot index, we may render an HTML file, we
can just send a restful HTTP response, a JSON
response, we can do anything. So that's going
to happen in the views. But before we can
use that views, we need to import it. So we
can see from imports, permission is correct.
Import views. So now that we have views imported,
we can say views dot index, what does this
index mean? It means a function. So these
views we imported is basically just as views.py
file here, when I come here, I have a new
function named index, it does take a request,
I'm also going to explain all of this, and
then I can pass for now. So right here, I
have a function named index. So whatever we
do in this function is one is going to be
assigned to this particular URL. So this is
the way it works, the user comes to this URL,
and then it sees that it needs to go into
views, and look for look for a function or
a class or whatever called index. And then
whatever is done in that index is what is
going to be rendered to the user. And then
we're just going to use name, you can make
this name anything you can name it index or
own, but is advisable to name it the same
thing, your name in that particular URL, so
you don't get confused or stock, or just get
some kind of errors. So this name is also
give this like a kind of ID is the name. So
later, you're gonna see why we will give a
name for now we'll leave it like that. So
let's save this file. So as I said, most user
comes to the UI is gonna go into views dot
index. And then whatever we do in this in
this is what is going to be rendered. Now
what we just want to do see is what am I just
doing here is what is going to be lender let's
do something, let's return something. And
we can just return an HTTP response. So that
before we can read out, we have to import
it from Django URLs from Django dot HTTP,
import HTTP response. And now say return HTTP
response. And then this HTTP response isn't
gonna be can be like an just an HTML tag,
like an h1. And then it gets a welcome. And
then we can close that h1. So we were just
having a simple HTML code inside this. Now,
if I run my project, I'm also going to show
you how to run your Django project. If I run
my project, you're going to see that we don't
have anything. So let's first of all, run
our project. Before we continue. Let's come
back into our command line and say Python
manage.py run server. Now remember, I said
we're gonna use money Wi Fi a lot in our command
line. So for us to run our project on our
localhost, so we can see what we are building,
we need to press Python manage py run server,
I'm gonna hit Enter, and then you're gonna
see what's going to happen is going to run
our project in localhost with a port of 1000.
So we don't need to copy this. coming to our
browser, and then just paste it. So as you
wait for that to load, so you can see what
it shows us what he shows us, right, he has
a default Django template of a new project,
to create a new project and just run it, this
is what you're gonna see. But obviously, we
don't want to see this. What we want to see
is our own website, our own templates, our
HTML file, our response, whatever we want
to do. So now, let's come back to Visual Studio
code. We've done everything here. We've said
when a user coming to the homepage should
go to the View does indeed And interviewed
at index, we're just sending an HTTP response,
which is a welcome to this year is supposed
to show a welcome Wiener. Now this is because
everything we've been doing sees as being
inside this app, this my app. But remember
I said my app is just a subset of the main
project, we also need to tell the main projects
where to look for the own URL. So that is
our is going to see it. So what we're just
going to do is to come into my project, writing
URLs dot p y, we're gonna, first of all, import
something named include. So from Django dot
URLs, import path from Django dot URLs, we
can also import include. Now this is going
to allow us to include a similar URL from
an app path, just like we're making another
URL, same thing. For righty now, we're not
saying views or anything, since we're already
configured that in the app, but I was gonna
say, include my up those URLs. So if you know
Python very well, you should kind of understand
what this is doing here. What is doing is
that is including my app that URL, so it's
going to go into my app right here, that URL,
which is this URL file, and it's going to
look for a similar URL to this. So anyway,
with the series home, what is being done there,
what is going to be rendered. Now we got quitted
this. Now we'll come back here it refresh,
you're gonna see now that we have a welcome,
we don't have that default Django template.
Again, what we have now is this particular
age to this particular HTTP response. So that
is basically out to do a basic URL routing.
Nowadays, most of these URL routing that we're
going to talk about later in this course,
is how to just basically do a simple URL routing
in Django. To this point, we have seen how
to get rid of the Django default templates.
For one, we just create a new Django project,
that template I was going to show you see
now to get rid of that and input our own response.
So as you can see, right, the agent says,
Hey, welcome. That was what we did, right?
in Visual Studio code, we just returned a
simple HTTP response with an h1 HTML tag saying
they welcome one. Now, one more than this,
we can code all our HTML in here, we can put
all our P tags are law firms, if you know
HTML very well, you know what I'm talking
about the guys that everything he wants to
have our own external HTML file, which we
want to render, when a user wants to access
this index page. Now, that is easy. Django
is quite easy. What we just need to do, we
need to configure Django to be able to see
our HTML files to be able to see our template
files, or to be able to look at those files.
That's the right word. So when we request
for less index dot HTML, Django knows where
to locate that file, and then it renders it.
Let's do that quickly. As closes up, closes
up also. So right here in our root directory,
remember I said the root directory of a Django
project is the directory which contains the
money does b y file? Night, yeah, we're gonna
create a new folder. Now this folder is going
to be called templates. And in this folder,
we're gonna store all our template file. That
is all the HTML files we're gonna use in this
project. What if I just stole my template
file right here, and I come here and I say,
okay, Django show index dot HTML. We just
created a temporary file. But we didn't tell
Django that this is where it has to look for
index dot HTML, or whatever template file
we're using. So we need to tell Django that
we're going to do that by using this settings.py
file in our project folder. So we're going
to have to open settings.pi and then we're
going to scroll up. And then we're going to
come, let's just make this full screen right
here where we sit templates. This is the configuration
for the template are going to look forward
within this. So this is a short form of directory.
So a saying which directory should Django
go into to look for the template file? So
it is very easy since we already have the
template for the year. We're just going to
say base there. Comma, and then we're gonna
say template. Now this template must be the
name of This folder. So what we're seeing
is that it should go into the base directory,
which is also the root directory, and look
for a folder named templates. Now, let's say
we named this template without an S, we also
need to call me I removed that as an empty
template. So whatever you put here, must correlate
with whatever is the name of the folder. Now,
we can just save this. Now Django knows where
to look for our template files, that just
closes up. What we just want to do now is
to go into that template folder, and create
a new file named index dot HTML. So in this
index dot HTML, we can have an h1 now with
a normal HTML file in a normal HTML file,
and then we can just say, let's say are you
doing today. So in our views, now, we don't
want to be returning this HTTP response, or
what to do is to render this HTML template.
Django knows where to look for the templates.
Everything is simplified. Now, we can remove
this HTTP response, I say return render, is
taking a request. And then you just put index
dot HTML, which is the name of the file, or
tried to render, which is right here. So we
have our function index, which is having a
request, now it retorted returns is that it's
rendering index dot HTML. Now let's save this
file. And then we come in here. And then we
hit refresh. So this should change this back.
So it doesn't change right here. Let's see
why. It's gone. Yeah. And made sure. Break
out of the server. And then let's run it again.
For let's get a minute to run. And then let's
come here, and it's refresh. So you can see
now it says are you doing today? So this shows
that it is coming from our index dot HTML
file, not from an HTTP response. Now, the
reason why it didn't load before, I'm sure
that it has been cached or something. So when
we opt out of that Django away, we close the
server and we started it again, it reloaded,
so sometimes you might need to do that. So
you see now it says, How are you doing today,
we can just have an image. In here, save it.
We have that saved. Okay, it's refresh. And
then you can see that that image, so is typical
HTML, so we can close out these now. So now
you've seen how to render an HTML template,
or template file in a Django URL. So up to
this point, issued starting to understand
how to work with Django, how to create a new
project, if you know the difference between
a Django project and a Django app. If you
know how to go about the URL configurations,
you should know how to set your views functions,
then you should understand the Django template
rendering. Now wants to talk about sending
dynamic data to your template file. I'm going
to explain what I mean by this. Let me come
into my Visual Studio code. Right here, I
just have the plain Tex named our you're doing
Let me explain the difference between static
and dynamic and when something is studied,
it means 88 is the same. When something is
dynamic, it means it changes to a particular
letter to a particular function or whatever
is given. I'm going to explain these more
when we're doing the practical things. Now
these How are you doing? It is static is just
a static text right? Now we say that because
if I reload this page is there there is it
is not changing. It's just there because that's
what I gave it. When something is dynamic,
it might be like a variable is different for
each user. So just like when you come into
facebook.com, you see your name they can say
welcome Tom does for if does your name. And
then if someone named john login, you'll see
welcome john. But when you go to Facebook
and you see your newsfeed you will see newsfeed
of your own Free is not the another person's
friends, or there are countless ways you can
think of it. So that is what dynamic stuff
is. Now, that's apples because of it is actually
the same page, like the same HTML file, or
the same whatever the same code, but is different
for each user. And that is what we mean by
dynamic when something is not the same for
everybody. So we're going to talk about sending
dynamic data to our template file. What I
mean is, in Django, because Django is a back
end framework, we implemented some programming
functionalities in the HTML, some things like
variable, something like if statement, some
things like for loops, we're able to code
that in HTML, using some particular language,
some is a template language called Jinja.
We're going to talk about that later. For
now. I will I send this, whatever I call it
this dynamic data to my file. What I just
need to do let's see, I have a variable called
name. I'm just saying this name is john. Right
here, I can see. Welcome. JOHN, let me just
see, john, CV. Fresh welcome, john. So this
is static, because it's john, if another person
named Tim login, is going to say, john, if
someone else name rules login, is going to
say john, was he will call me and now let's
change his name to like Patrick. I can send
this variable into my index dot HTML file,
and I can access it from you. I can do this
by just coming after the index of HTML, you
just add the curly braces, and then the name
of the variable name. And then we're giving
you this name variable, which we have here.
So this is like the key of value. It's like
a dictionary, this is the key, he says the
value. Now I'm going to be able to assess
this variable, because of this key in my index
of HTML. If I come here, now, instead of saying,
john, to assess that, I'm going to use the
curly braces twice. And I'm going to say name,
if I save you right here now, so as you can
see, now, it says welcome, Patrick. Now, this
Patrick is coming from our back end is not
coming with just as a plain text, right here,
we are saying name, but what is printing there
is Patrick. That is because that is what we
assign deeds rights here. Now, this can be
different for everybody. When we go further,
you're going to see how we're gonna use authentication
to allow each user to have their own data.
Now, let's say this data is coming from a
database. Let's say we log a user in, and
then we get this name. And let's say it would
be something like user dot name, I show this
and something like user name. So now this
name is given a value of user dot name, which
is now coming from the database. So it's intuitive,
it will be different for every single person.
So is john are logged into St. JOHN, visiting
the login his theme that will be sent into
the front end. And as always send dynamic
data using Django in Django? Well, now we
can also send, make this more formatted. Like
let's say we have multiple, it's not a good
practice to come in and do comma and say,
age, and then give it know that you can also
do that. But that's not a good practice. So
we can just have something we call context
does popularly using Django, and this content
is going to be a dictionary. In this dictionary,
we're gonna just have all the fields one of
us listen name. And then we just give it Patrick.
And then I say age, we can give me 23. nationality.
We got some British, and then we can just
continue like that is basically a dictionary.
And then if we want to pass this into the
HTML, we don't need this curly braces again,
we can just say context. Now this contest
is being sent to this index of HTML for recall
me and now I will say name is going to print
the name that is in here, which is still Patrick.
So that didn't change. Say welcome Patrick.
And Ella, just give it a break. And then we
can say you age years old, So now let's eat
refresh, I see says you are 23 years old,
which is the variable age coming from the
views. Well, we can also use a nationality
and say you just give it a nationality. I
will call me on it refresh and says you are
British. So this is just how to manipulate
the data. As you can see different data coming
from the back end coming from the views are
later Well, I'm going to show you how to get
all this from database, not just you typing
in dummy data or static data. Now, I hope
you understand the concept of sending dynamic
value is from your views to your template
file in Django. Now, we're gonna take some
of the features we've learnt in the previous
parts, and then with some new features, and
then we're gonna use it to build a very simple
word counter in Django. So is just a very
small projects, way in which a user is going
to be able to put a couple of words there
are like a sentence or an article, and there
was the user ID summit is going to show the
user the amount of words that are present
in that bunch of text. So let's do that. The
first thing we need to do, let's quickly come
to our server, which is running right here.
So we want to have like a form right here,
which a user will be able to put all the text
in, and then we should have a submit button
beneath it. So let's do that. First of all,
writing VS code, we can get rid of all these
right now. And then we just have a form can
just leave it blank for now. Okay. So in this
form, let's have a text area. Give it a name,
or message text. That should be fine. And
then there's our Submit button that I shouldn't
be Submit. But yeah, we can have a break.
So now let's save this on it refresh right
here. So this is just what we have. Now, let's
see, we can add something like rule rules.
And then let's say just to give it again,
longer, I think there's something that comes
close. Give it 10. Also, wait, refresh. Okay,
so let's make this like 2525. Wait, refresh,
good. So let's make this a little bit bigger,
a double of 50. Let's see. Okay. So I think
this is good. And then right here, we're not
really specific about the design, we just
want to know how to add the back end functionality.
So let's come up here above the form, right,
is have an h1, which just says inputs, your
texts below. So now, this is our form. Let's
refresh and just see. So this is our form
right here. And then this form, let's give
it a method. If you know HTML, you know that
there are two methods when you're submitting
a form, which is get under post. So we're
gonna leave this blank for now. And we're
going to talk more about get on POST method
when you're dealing in Django. So we're gonna
talk about that later. But for now, we're
gonna leave this blank. So what wants to do
now is that once you get up to the text here,
and it's submit, not the URL, we're still
in this URL, this page, and then it just passes
some data, everything which was written in
this place when it's submitted, which in another
is passed into the URL, and is saved in like
this variable, this key named text. And the
reason why I saved in text is because we gave
it a name year of text. If we give it a name
of words. I will come here into fresh I'll
say, are you doing, and then we call me out
on it. So meet, you see, now you save in a
variable key of so meet with all these values.
So now the oddest is being passed to the URL,
it's very easy for us to now get all these
values in the backend. So let me explain what
we're going to do. So once the user hits submit,
we want to send it to another URL right here,
you can see that it's just sending back to
this home page, we're gonna create another
URL, maybe like a counter, maybe like slash
counter, that URL is going to count the amount
of words, and then he's going to send him
back to the template file, and then showcase
the amount of words for us. So it's going
to make sense in a bit. Let's just do that.
So first of all, we're supposed to have an
Action. Action is where we want all this data
to send to. So now we don't really have any
other URL, let's go and create that. So right
here in URLs of p y, let's have another URL.
And then we can just name this counter. And
then let's say views those counter. And then
let's give it a name of counter. Now, you
know that we said view dot counter where we
come into our views, we don't have any function,
the name counter, so let's go create that.
So right here, just want to have a new function
named counter. And then wants you to take
your requests. Now, we can also return render
requests. And then want to have just a way
we have index HTML for this page, we want
to have another HTML file for this counter.
Let's come here and just create a new file
and name it counter that HTML. So that is
blank for now, let's leave it blank. Now we
can render this counter dot html. And then
we can leave that for now. So we don't need
all of these again, get rid of that. So now
what we want to do, is that we want this action
to go to counter is very easy, we're just
going to do in action, we'll just put the
name of the URL, which is counter. So now
once we eat some meat, it takes all this data
to this counter view. Now let's go to is the
house become your eat, refresh? Okay, no,
not like this, and then a What's up, then
we need to submit. Now you see, it goes to
slash counter. With this words, I say, what's
now that this counter as this particular data,
these yo yo can get that data. So first thing,
get this data, we're gonna come into views,
we're gonna have a new variable, or let's
just name this new variable like words. And
then first, to get it to see requests that
get getting worse, I'm going to explain all
this. So what we're just doing now is setting
a new variable, and there was a request doesn't
get. So I want to send a request to whatever
is being passed to this particular view. And
then we want to get it so and then what wants
to get is this words, now we come to the index
at HTML, you're gonna see that we're sending
this particular data into this counter. And
in this count our getting that data. So request
dot get words why we have this word is because
it is the name we gave the particular text
collator, like the text area, which collected
that data, this is the name assigned to it.
Now we change this to text. What we want to
be now should be text. So let's just change
it to testicle does looks more makes more
sense. Now you see that, once we are collecting
yes should be the sandwich was easier to because
as a name assigned to it every changes to
like t x. Now this can't, when we try to collect
data from it. It doesn't see any form with
the name of text. So it's not going to collect
any data, give it x is going to collect our
data. So what we can just do now since we
already have that data, we collected our data
and stored it in this variable named x. So
what's going on now let's go back to the old
way We just write some stuffs. And then we
hit submit. Now we collected our data. And
then this data a revise after it is now stored
in this variable named text. So you know,
in Python, you can, there's a way we can count
the amount of words present in a text. So
let me quickly open up my command prompt here
and show you what I'm talking about, then
we'll come back here. So let me open my python
shell real quick. And then let's say I have
a variable named text on it as a sentence
named a. Oh, are you doing. So you can see
now that this is 123455 words in it. Now we
can count this by, let's see, we can just
print it straight, and say, length of sex
dot splits. So what this is doing is that
we're just printing the length of text, the
splits, the splits means you get each word
present in this text. So once it's split everything
into one different value, then you're going
to count the amount that is in the event.
Now. Let's do that again. Okay, so that is
because I didn't close the print function.
So let's just get out of there. And then one
more. So now you can see that we have five.
So that was because this print is for this
closes and these lenses for these and these
for the so we need to add one more. And that's
where the show works. So now you see that
it's Prince five, that's because we have five
words here. So does exactly the same thing
we're going to be doing right here in our
project is already our word to use our routes
stored in this variable, by just going to
add a new variable, I will say amount of words,
we can name it like. And then the amount of
words will be the length of text does please
like this. So now we have the amount of words
present in what the user root. And we studied
in this way we named amount of words, what
we can just do now is to send this amount
of words straight into this counter dot html.
Very easy. Just have a key and a value, who
say amount of words to say amount, and then
want to give it amount of words. Very easy,
we'll save that. And now we can say the amount
of words is, and then what is the key, the
key is amount. So this is the key, this is
the value. And then we use the key together.
So the amount of words is this. Now let's
go back. And nowadays writes full text that
makes sense to say, A, you good. You are doing
well. So let's count these 1-234-567-8910.
Now we hit submit. And he says the amount
of words is 10. So you can see now that it
says the amount of words is 10 does exactly
what we want to avoid. So let's just come
here and just give us back an h1 copy, save,
visit, refresh, and I see see the amount of
words is 10. To read just go back and add
something to remove these and now we should
have 12344 with submit it says the amount
of words is four. So now you can see as we're
starting to turn though these are features
I notice Django stopped our learning into
project. So you can see now we just get the
simple text counter it counts auditors. Now
this can also be very useful. You might see
just a simple project where sometimes you
can beautiful personnel use if you have like
a blog posts. So let me just open up a blog
post. And then you can copy all the text and
then just paste it in to list take something
from here. And then we can just copy all of
this tray. Okay, there's a bunch of code.
You get what I'm talking about. Then we come
here, paste it in. And then we hit submit,
and it counted for stereo Jan 28 words. So
you can see that it's also very useful. Sometimes
we just need it. So right now we've done this.
So, but there's something I want to talk about
more invites submit, you'll see that everything
that we wrote in that text area in that text
was, it's been sent into the URL, and it's
quite lengthy. So as you can see a lot, that's
a lot. And that's the reason why we're able
to access it. But why we don't want all this
to be in the URL, what do we just want it
to be slash counter. And it's still going
to be able to count this text without having
all this in the URL like this. Without having
this, we just want this, and they want to
be able to count. So we're also going to talk
about that more in the next part. Now let's
talk about GET and POST requests. So in the
last part, we'll build the simple word count
out where we'll be able to put a bunch of
text. And then once we hit submit, it counts
that takes for us, we are going to notice
the other text in which was submitted is being
passed in this URL. Now, let me explain why
all this happens. If we come back to our code,
right here in our form, you're going to see
that when we specified metode, we left it
blank. So this method is for you to know the
type of request you are using the type of
method you are using in this form. So it's
either a get method or a POST method to those
are the two types that are being used. And
a get method are mostly used whenever we are
not passing any personal information or any
very safe information. Because as I said,
it is being shown in the URL. But it was in
a POST method. This app, when we use a POST
method, the information in which was sending
is not going to be shown in the URL. Now this
is mostly used, because it weighs in again
matters, let's say for when a user wants to
sign up to a website, we don't want to pass
the user username and password right here
in the URL down to make sense, or user wants
to pay online with his credit card, we don't
want to put the credit card details in his
URL. That's why we use POST method because
that is more safe. And it prevents some attacks
on our website. So right here, as you can
see, it was blocked, I didn't specify any
method. So when I live in blank like this
in a default automatically, it uses a get
method. So if I don't put any method right
here, but I just put a method and don't specify
it, it automatically uses a get method. So
I can also call me I just tried to get that
is still a get method, or I leave it blank
is still a get metal wave. Now I want to use
a post metal I need to put that year is post
I want to use. So I'm going to do two posts.
So now we're just going to build this word
counter again, but now using this POST method,
so you get the concept of post. So now our
changes to post method. Let me save this.
And then go back here and hit refresh. So
now we will put a bunch of texting. And it's
Submit. Yeah, so right here we have this arrow.
Now it says forbidden CSRF token verification
field, request aborted. Now this happens because
as I say a POST method is used for more personal
information. And anytime Why isn't a POST
method Django expects us to use something
we call CSRF token. Now CSRF stands for cross
site request forgery. So it's like an attack.
Now when you're passing data through URLs,
an attacker or someone that has bad intention
on your site can tap into those and get those
information by using this CSRF token. Django
provides a default CSRF token which allow
us to prevent that attack. So let's just quickly
look it up CSRF token. So this is going to
come up as you can see CSRF tokens a unique
secret unprintable value that is generated
by the server side application and transmitted.
So this is just a boring definition of it.
But that is what the CSRF token does. It prevents
that so let's open up the CSRF Yes, CSRF attack.
So, let's at Yup. So in a CSRF attack, an
innocent user is tricked by an attacker into
submitting a web request that they did not
intend. So is like stealing information. But
when we use CSRF token, it prevents that.
So I hope you get what that is for. So if
we don't use CSRF token in Django, it won't
allow our form to work. So we need to add
that. So it's very easy, just a line of code,
or we don't need to do is to put two curly
braces to percentage size, and type CSRF underscore
token. Now, when this is done, everything
is fine. If we go back, does it refresh, as
puts these in a new we click Submit? I'm very
sure an error is still gonna come up. Yeah,
so it says multi valued error, slash counter.
So we have an error. But now it's not. Because
of our post request. We've covered everything
for this. So this is how to do your post method.
But why we're getting this error is because
right here in our views, the poi, you're gonna
see that we say we want to get what the user
sent to say request dot gets. But now we are
using post. So we also need to do the ads
and just say, requests, dot posts, is that
easy. No, let's just go back fresh. As we
put that to reload, let's come back, the garbage
is running. Because it refresh. Now, with
type three, knowledge, it's amici. Say it
says the amount of words is three, and then
our URL is completely clear. We don't have
any information being passed in our URL. So
the POST method is very, very useful whenever
you are dealing with some more safe and secure
information. So I hope you understood the
difference between GET and POST requests or
POST method. Let's talk about static files
in Django. Now, what is this static files
in Django we're talking about is any external
file that you use in your template file. Now,
template files are the HTML file we use in
Django. So this index of HTML is a template
file. This is a temporary file. Now any external
file we use is our static files. Like do we
have an external CSS file that is linking
to this HTML file, that is a static file,
if we have an image, we have an external video,
all those are static files. So just the way
we configured for the template file, remember,
earlier in this tutorial, we actually go to
the settings of this project, and we are to
tell Django where all these template files
are located. Now we have to do the same thing
for the static file. Let me close this up.
Let me close all of this. Now, let's say we
want to add an external CSS to this page.
Let me just remove this form, we don't need
it again. Let me say, a welcome to my projects.
Now, let's say we want to add an external
CSS to this particular file. And then we want
that CSS to be linked to it. In a normal HTML,
we don't need to use our link tag. And then
we just specify where the CSS file is located.
Boring. Jango is quite a bit different. Just
the way we store all the template files in
a folder named template, we need to store
all the static files in a folder named static.
Now let's do that. Create a new folder. I
will say static. This static file, as I said,
is going to contain all the external files
we need. But now we need to tell Jango where
to locate all the static files. And then we're
also going to do it in the settings.py file.
That's why I said earlier in this video, the
settings.py file is like the bedrock of the
whole project. It is very useful. So what
we're just gonna do now is to come right into
my project, and then go to settings.pi. So
this was where we configure for the templates.
Before the static files. We're going to configure
it down here. But before we come down, we
have to go up first of all, and they're right
here, we need to import something we've got
OAS. So let's type inputs OAS. Now what this
always does is that it gets a specific the
operating system of which we're coding on
like, oh S stands for operating system. So
this gets you on a Windows only mark or whatever
we are on. So now that we have imported OS,
but we just want to do is go Going down. Right
below static URL, we can have something that
goes static files, there's static static files,
underscore days with an S are going to say
equals to open a bracket, I'll say who is
the path, the join, and then open another
bracket on the same page. And then we just
leave like a comma, static. On the right,
you also live in a coma. So what it is doing
is, is from r o s is going to do base directory,
which is also the root directory of this project.
So when I say the base there, I mean the rooster.
So right here is the base directory, the folder
that contains the money.py file is a base
directory. And then is going to the folder
where we have static. So right here is that
folder. Now we have that set up. in that folder,
now we can create a new file and name it style
dot CSS. So now we have discussed style, the
CSS, let's style this h1 and give you like,
color of red. So you can say h1 is say, color,
red. So we have that. And now we have to link
this static right here into this HTML. We
do that on top of the file. And then you know,
in normal HTML, what we just need to do is
to say, link, and then we just say real data
sheet. And then we just say, F, and then we
just give it like style dot CSS, the name
of the file, and then we close the file. Now,
if I save these, and I come here, and it's
refresh, you'll see that we just have that
text, which is in black, and then the CSS
is not reflecting on it. And that is because
this link is not seen by Django. This is too
detailed, we're gonna use both in this HRF.
Instead of just writing styles, we need to
add something we call static. First use our
study. Before the name of the file, we'll
put a curly braces, a percentage sign, no
write static, leave a space, add one of the
codes, we'll close it right here like this.
So this is how to use static. So like this,
Django should see should know where to locate
this style dot CSS. Now receiving a copy or
a refresh, we're going to get an error, a
template error. Now we see it says template
syntax error as slash. It says invalid data
on line one, did you forget to register or
load this tag. So now it's saying we forgot
to load this taco static. So right here, this
static way, it's like a tag that Django sees.
Before we can use a, we need to load it. So
that's very easy, we just got to the top of
the file. Whenever I want to load something
in Django, it needs to be at the top of the
file. And we'll say, open and close curly
braces, percentage sign and load static. Now
when we save this, we come back and it's refresh.
Boom, you see now that it shows it in a red
color. That is showing that the CSS is working
on this HTML file. It is connected to it.
So let's go right here and just change this
to like blue. we'd save weight refresh, you
see now that is blue. So that is how to link
a static file into your template file. But
now let's go further. And then let's work
on more real projects. So what I want to do
now is just go to Google and then download
a free HTML template. And then I'm not going
to show you how to link different types of
static files, not just only the CSS now elimelech
images may be JavaScript, anyone we download,
so I didn't prepare for this. I was gonna
search free HTML templates and anyone we see,
we're gonna use so let's see. Let's see. I
think this should be good. And then loser
screw down. Okay. Let's see. Check them out.
Yep. So one of all of these should have a
look. Okay, this should have a lot of CSS
in it. And then we're just going to download
it. The free one. Scroll down. Okay, this
is a free, let's just scroll all the way up
unless a free HTML template download or something,
and they just get one to download on the legends
as you know, Django project. So we should
have a free ones actually. I know one sites.
So bootstrap me. Yep. But this website, I
know they are free. And then they just come
here and get one to download. Jump Jump on
then. Let's see. So let's work with this one
page, download. Pre download. bootstrap five
does download while subscribing to the newsletter.
So let's see. Okay. It was downloading right
here, as you can see. Okay. Give it a second.
And then that should be done. Okay, so let's
go to the Downloads folder and look for this
extra, and then drop it into Visual Studio
code. So we'll know our gonna use it. So that
should be done downloading. Let's come here.
Go to downloads. Page. Yep. So right here,
we can just drag this or we can just copy.
And then let's go back twice, or three times.
And then so right here is the our Django projects,
we'll paste it in there. That should take
a few seconds to base. So now we can close
all this, we don't need all this again. Now
we can just start with what I say we're going
to do changing different or connecting different
static files into our projects. This is done.
And then this will open it up. So we have
all of these right here. Good. Now we come
in here, we should have that one page here.
And then we can delete this index of HTML.
Let's just delete that. And then from year,
one page where we have index HTML, let's drag
into the templates for Yeah, we move in the
now that we are moved, we moved that next
thing we want to do is to just move this asset
into the static file, because that's where
the static files are located. So as I said,
we see the CSS image JavaScript here. So let's
close this one page for now. And then right
here in index, this is what is going to be
rendered when the Index page is called index
dot HTML. So let's close this up. And now
let's go back to our project, and then it
refresh. So you can see the title is changed.
And then we have all of these. So you can
see, it is linked with the age the static
files, but not seeing the way Django recognizes
it. So all these are linked, but not the way
Django recognizes them. So now let's just
do change everything we need for this file.
Does gonna come here and do node static. And
then let's start from year and then can actually
make it quicker by using the boats like these.
Anyway, we see this we just put it in there.
So we judge the odds. A good trick I use and
then we do the percentage sign space static.
And then we put this right in here. And now
we come here we do the same thing. Now we
do it right Near the end of all these files,
and then we just close a percentage are close.
So now if I save these, and I come here and
each refresh, I should see a massive change
in the website. So you see now we have the
pre loading, tag, or div tag, style or whatever
is loading. And then our page should load
as expected. So that's loading for too long.
And I'm very sure is because we've not linked
all the files, we were supposed to link measures
copied this static analysis, continue linking,
we continue linking. So let's see the scroll
down. So now when we come here and into fresh
tissue work, and it shouldn't load forever,
good. So now you can see that this is what
we want. Right? Yes. So we can see that the
website loads successfully. So this is how
to basically take a template file, then it
will the static, it might the static files
might be linked differently, or doesn't use
it or link it in Django. Now, I hope you understood
everything we talked about in static files.
So now let's talk about models in Django.
So in Django, we have something called the
models. And these modules are mostly used
in configuring our database. So most of the
times in Django, you don't need to write a
single line of SQL code to get your database
up and running. That's why we have something
we call model view template. So the model
is what we use for our database, the view
is what the user See, and the template is
right, all this HTML. So from the model, we
just pass all our data into our template for
children understand all this in a minute.
Now, the models is very easy to configure,
instead of using like a date, a database table
SQL code, we're just gonna use the classes
in Python to build our database. For now,
we're just gonna be talking about the classes
and inheritance in the view, then later on,
we're going to move to our gonna integrate
it into our database. Let's go into a file
called Moodle dot viewer. And these files
is always located in our app. So right here
in this file, we can create a new Moodle.
So by just creating a class, and then we can
just name it, whatever we want to name it,
let's say like, let's come into this come
right here. So let's say fixtures right. fixture,
and then we can use this like this. And then
we can give this like an ID of which should
be an integer. And then we can have the name
of the feature, which you want to be a strange.
And then we can also have something like the
details, service details. We should also be
a string. So right here, what we know is the
name, we have an ID and then the details of
the fixture. So we have this right here now.
Well how can we use these in our views is
also very easy to just need to do is to come
into our views.py and then right here in the
index, where we can just do is to first of
all import that model from you. So we can
see from those models import feature. Now
that we have that imported Well we can just
do is to say, let's say feature one. Should
we curse shoo inherit from the feature model.
So now that this feature one is inheriting
from the feature model, we can now easily
specify the detail of the attributes of this
feature. So we can see if you join. But Id,
let's give it an ID of zero, and a feature
one. Name, let's give it a name of say, fast.
So is a feature. I remember that this is a
string. And then we add one more, which was
I think details as details. So feature and
details. Let's say, service is very quick.
So now we have this year, where we can just
you know is to pass this into the index of
HTML. So we can just say, feature should be
equals a feature. Let's see. Now if we come
into index at HTML, and then we look for these.
So this should be beneath the Get Started
of this, let's crew all the way up. And then
you get started. So that about a minute ago.
Scroll down a little bit. So we should see
I get started. And then yeah, right here,
we have this. So instead of Lorem, or whatever
this is now, we can just have feature fixture.
This is fixture I regard here as drag just
beside this because I've ever needed an alert.
So this is fixture can see a feature that's
name. Once we hit Save icon here and it refresh,
what we should be having now is the name,
which is fast. So let's wait for this page
to refresh. So now you can see what we have
is fast, we don't just have whatever was there
again. And then we can also change the details
of dat. So let's delete all of these. And
then we can say feature. A feature the details.
And then if we come here, and it refresh.
You see it says all services very quickly
as that detail. Now we can also do the same
thing for all of these for what we can do
is to come into our views. So we are feature
one, we can just copy all these bass, bass
bass. Okay, let's take two bass bass. So now
let's just change out these two feature two.
And then let's change all these to feature
three. And then all the way to feature four.
So now, we have feature 1234. And then the
ID should be 123. So this is fast. Let's say
this is reliable. Easy to use, and affordable.
To now guys a service is reliable, is easy
to use, and our services vary. So now we have
all these 1234. Well, how do we pass them
into the front end. So we can do the same
thing doing something like this. So we can
change from feature to feature one. On the
right here we can just say feature two should
be feature two. And then feature three should
be feature three and then feature four should
be feature four. And then we got come right
here and assess it right here. And then we
can just do exactly the same thing. So we
change this to one, which one take us away,
Sunday is just chain DS and then no feature
to feature to the details. They receive it
now on Comm. You see that right here, we should
have the feature to the details. So see fast
service is fast, reliable service is reliable,
I see that these data are now coming from
our views are coming from the back end. So
let's just do the same thing here. And then
you can see, I'm going to show you a false,
or something that we can do to make this quicker
and a better process. So I know why I'm doing
all this from scratch. So we have feature
very, and then the details. And then we have
the same thing right here. feature four. Right
here. We come down, it's your fresh data,
in which we add right here. I was I've been
rendered right here in the view in the template.
But I'm sure you can, we are gonna agree with
me that what we just did was time wasting.
And let's say we want we have 1000s of data
is this how we are just going to render them
each. And it's not possible to make this dynamic,
right. Because this is obviously static data
is just whatever we're passing from the database
from Yeah, is what is shown here, we can make
these more dynamic. Now when I mean more dynamic,
we know we can have just one bunch of code.
So you can see that this code is repeated
four times in our HTML, we have it here 123.
And then we have vgf. For now let's cancel
this for as cancelled three, or leave just
only one. So we can see it was repeated four
times. But now we cancelled everything out
left only one. If I save it and call me and
eat you fresh. And then I see that I have
only one. But I'm going to show you why I
did this in a minute. So let's come back here
into our views. Instead of having all these
Joe just pass in here, like these feature
one, feature two, this is probably not a good
practice, what you can do is to have a list,
I can name it features. And then we're just
going to purchase feature one, feature two,
feature three, feature fourth. So now that
we have all these four, you can just do. Let's
remove all of these, which we passed. And
then let's come back. So instead of feature
one, we can just see features, and then we
can pass this features. So now what you see
now we have a list that contains all the data
we have. So all this data, which we have here,
they are stored inside these lists, named
fixtures. Now this is a very good practice.
And this is the way you should do it. And
now we are just passing it to the HTML with
the features and features. So now when the
HTML, we can look through this list and get
the attribute for each of these lists right
here, so feature for us all these attributes,
Victoria, all these attributes. So from the
HTML, we can look through a and get all those
attributes we need. Let's go there and see
the safeties. So right here, what we're gonna
do, we're going to look for that particular
code block, in which we want to loop through,
so we want to loop through these particular
books. So is the amount of data we have. That's
the amount of books that we show. Now, if
you can reason that way, where you see that
that is now dynamic, in depending on the amount
of data we have that shows the amount of texts
of card or block being outputted. So and that
is this block of code right here. So we can
do something with a for loop. And then we
can see for feature a features. So what I'm
doing is this features which I passed in HTML
is a list. So I can look through the list
it is ethereal. So I can say for feature in
features. So instead of feature one dot name,
I'll say, feature that name, and feature the
details, just the way we do in Python. And
then what we also need to do is to make sure
that we end our for loop right here, by saying,
and for because you know, in Python, the for
loop is being ended automatically by using
indentation. So if you get what I'm saying,
for example, if I come here, and I've folio,
so I'm going to have a fixture in fixtures.
So now when I just do something I can just
pass for now. So anything under this indentation
is under this folder, promise I've come out
of the indentation of continued coding, the
follow up is being broken. So only this block
of code now is part of their for loop. We're
in HTML, we don't see indentations, what we
see is just code tags and code blocks. So
that is what we also need to use to enter
our for loop. If we don't put an for loop
here, what is going to happen is it is going
to loop through all the watch code below these.
And they are going to see all this code multiple
times we're going to get all the images multiple
times. And it's not what we want. So let's
go back up here. And then this ends the for
loop. So now we look through that, and then
just get each of the image each of the names
and these, I will save it. Now when we come
here at refresh, you're gonna see that this
code, this block is going to appear four times
to see fast, reliable, easy to use and affordable.
So now we're making it dynamic. This is what
we want. So we have just only one code block
here, one div tag here, but it's appearing
four times, because we are looping through
that. And that's because we have four values
right here. 1234. We also have one more, let
me just show you the, from our back end da
we're good, we're not gonna touch the HTML
file. But when we come here on each refresh,
we're gonna see one more minute. So let's
say we have fixture five. So let's use our
odds. So we are feature five, and we have
just asked for, and then what we can say trustworthy,
just like our service is a few with trust.
So we can also put that into the list. So
feature five, and we save it. So now we just
added a new data right here in this our small
database. And then I'm not gonna touch the
index, HTML, will not call me on it, refresh.
Okay, so now we got office error, it says
look available feature reference before assignment.
So let's see where that is coming from. So
that is just an error because we say fixtures
instead of feature five. So that is what we
need. And then we need refresh. So before
that load, we can see now that we have a new
block here without touching the HTML. But
that's how easy it is to make stuff dynamic.
So now if we think about it, it let's say
we have all this coming from our database.
That is how we can make our website very dynamic.
Let's say we want to show a list of users.
So once a user sign up automatically, just
gonna add right here or something like that.
You can just make do anything you want. And
so that is the basics of this models in Django.
So let's do some more things that we need
to know. So right here, we did a for loop.
We're going to do an if statement, just like
we do in Python. We have the for loop where
the statement we have the conditional STD
FDS member. Let's also do that in our template
file. So let's set something like in our models,
let's have a Boolean. So let's say is correct
or is true. So what these So I want us to
do is, let's say is this features true, let's
say is fast. Now we added a new attributes,
which is just to show if our website is really
fast. If it's true, then it should be true,
unless there's a lie, and it should be forced.
So that's just the basic stuff of what this
is for. Now, our website is fast, let's see,
feature one dots is true. And then we'll say
true. So this means that it is truly fast.
And then they just do the same is truly reliable.
So that's a feature to true. And let's say
it is not easy to use, let's say we're just
lying about that. So now feature three is
false. It's not easy to use and feature for.
affordable. Let's make that true. Yeah, true.
So now first of all, let's come here, refresh
and get rid of the stress, worry. So, again,
give that a second. Okay, so we just have
this. And now each of them have whether this
feature is true or not, we can come here in
our HTML and see, when beneath this detail,
we can have a p tag that says, true. And then
we can have just less of a p tag that says
true. What if I saved these said this. Come
on, this feature is true. Now, let's save
this. And hit refresh right here. So you're
gonna see that he says, This feature is true
for each of these features. But remember,
in our database, we said, It is not easy to
use for easy to use, it is false, but easy
to use, yet he says This feature is true.
So how can we fix this outcome we get with
a fixture is really true or is wrong. Now
against the conditional statement. So we can
say if fixture.is true is equals to true,
then we want to say the future is true. And
then we can also end our if statement. So
let's do that. So to call it braces to percentage
sign, and then we can say if that is true,
is equals to true. Then let's say this picture
is true. And then we need to end that if statement.
Just the way I told you that in Python using
the notation to end our if statement and our
for loop. in HTML in the template for we used
a code block for the tag or whatever you want
to call it. So now only get in if this feature
is true, does when it says true? So let's
save it and go check. So we is refresh. And
now we should not see true for a year. Okay,
so as you can see, it doesn't say true for
any of this. And that is because you know,
in Python when you want to use an if statement,
you use this columns. For right here. The
Boolean even in Python, we don't need columns
when assigning a Boolean. No does not column
does the parentheses or codes, I think that
equals So let's save this and this should
work. It didn't work because we put those
codes. So let's hit refresh. And each of them
should say is true except for this. So he
says this fixture is true. This picture is
Drew. He doesn't say anything and say this
picture is true. So we use Annie's data to
get whether that particular feature is true.
And note the fun thing that we're doing here.
Everything we're doing is to under one code
block, what is generating different data from
that same one code block with different values
is very fun and very good. Everything about
it. But now right here is false. Let's move
on to our VA and see that this feature is
false. How can we do that? Just in Python
we have the if we have the L statement, we
have the Elif elsif statement. We can do that
year also. So we can say if feature is true.
Else So LCM is if the feature is not true,
then we just want to have this that says,
Come on, that says This feature is false.
So if feature is true, say true. Any features
to else that means a feature is not true,
that is obviously false, say this feature
is false. Or let's come here and hit refresh.
Let's see what we have. Now this feature is
true, true or false, which is what was and
is true. Now this is very, very, very good.
That is exactly what we want. And then we
can also use the LC in this. So right here,
so they'll say else, we can just say a leaf.
feature that is true. is equals to false.
Now, this should give us exactly the same
answer. Let's hit refresh. You see, it says
This feature is false. So we can also use
the leaf statement or the statement. Well,
most of the times want to use the Elif statement,
and we have multiple conditions we want to
set, but for this case is just two conditions
is either it's true, or false. So for that,
we can just stick with the L statement. So
else, if is not true, then is definitely false.
Now, that is how we can do some busy dynamic
data rendering in Django. I hope it has been
fun to this point for you. So now I've introduced
you to the basics of the Django modules. But
obviously, all these are just normal Python
classes, which we are inheriting in our views
right here. But we can make all these more
advanced by turning them into real databases.
First of all, let me collapse this and this.
So if you come to this root directory, you'll
see that there's a file named DB dot SQL lite
three. So this file is what stores all our
database in Django. So when you create a new
Django project, it would define default automatically,
you have your databases saved using SQL Lite.
So as we know, the various database provider
like Postgres, Oracle, MySQL, secure light,
like what is here. So, as a default, Django
uses SQL Lite. And that's what we're gonna
continue using for this video. Most of the
times when you're working with Python, you
might want to use Postgres, you may want to
switch was also very easy. We also talked
about that. But for now, let's just stick
with the sequel light. So we want to change
this class into a real jungle model and Tony
to a database, we need to add some things
right here. For example, where we have this
fixture, what we just need to do is to say,
open the bracket, I say model dot model. Now
this converts in this basic class into a model.
And then whenever we're using this model,
we don't need to add an ID again, because
automatically each attribute or each object
as an ID when it's created. So now we can
remove this. So now when we have name, we
can change it to equals to. So now instead
of writing str, write something I'll say models
dot current field. Now this model dot char
field simply means character field, it means
like a string of food accolades characters,
now we're gonna open a bracket, and it takes
one attribute, the attribute is Max length.
So this max length is five the maximum amount
of characters that can be inside this character
field. So for this name, we cannot specify
Andre it shouldn't be more than 100. And then
details as you might have guessed, he should
also be a character field. And they are various
type of fields a lot of fields in this jungle
module the integer field to Boolean field,
they is their present a few ways you can use.
So catch if you do so the max length, we can
set it to 500 because the detail and then
for did is true. I'm sure we don't need these
again. So let's just have the name and the
details right here. Now we can save this Now
there's something we need to do before this
can be saved into our database. For now, this
is just code in a file named models spy, we
need to send all these fields into our database,
so it can be registered right there. But before
we do that, this app, which we are doing all
our project a, which is called my up, we need
to register it in our main project settings
file, went to come in here, go to settings.pi.
And then we can scroll all the way up, I will
look for where we see installed apps right
here. And then we can just add a new attribute
and say my and this is going to add this my
app into your main project. So you need to
add that before you can start integrating
databases of this my app into your main projects.
So now we need to migrate these data into
our database. Let's go back to our command
prompt, and they just open a new command prompt.
And then we come here. And then they just
got the screw up. So right here, that should
be it, we screw up again. Yeah, so that should
be right here. And then we just go into that.
So what want to do now is to type Python manage.py
make migrations. What this command line does
is that any changes in which you made in the
modules file. So if I come back here, you
see that we made some changes right here is
gonna like save that changes. And then as
you can see, it says we created a module named
fixture. So it's gonna save that changes.
And they forgot to send all these changes
into our database, we need to migrate it by
saying Python manage.py migrate. So it's a
two step method. First of all need to make
migrations and migrate. So that make migrations
we need to do it. Any time we add or change
anything in these modules with pure alpha,
they will come in now I removed this detail
attributes, or let's say we add another attribute,
we need to come in and do this two step again,
my make migrations and migrate. So it can
be reflected in our database. As you can see,
everything that migrated. We have content
types, out admin content types, authentication,
all these, and then applying my up 01 inicia.
So what this is, is all this module we have
in here. So right now our database has been
migrated. But I'm sure you like to where did
our database go, basically. So we're just
upon right now. We have something we call
the Django admin panel. So all these data
bees are being pushed, be moved into these
into the SQL lite database. Why can we view
it and edit it and control it as we like that
we are Django data, or Django admin panel
comes in. Now, obviously, we are using Postgres
or using any other interface, you can just
easily use those interfaces because they are
more advanced. But because we are starting
from the basics of Django, I would like to
introduce you to the Django admin py first.
So if you come to your project now, and then
you go to slash admin, so your project slash
admin, and you enter, you're gonna see what's
gonna happen, is gonna ask you to log in.
So right here, you see says we should log
in, with what details we don't have any details
we've never added, sign up and sign in, into
our project. But this is an admin site, it
is not your normal site, again, it will go
into another part of that site. We're only
we developers can get credentials to this
particular site. And to do that, we're going
to come into our command prompt. And then
we're gonna say python manage.py. Create super
user. Now this command line creates super
user. What it does is it creates an admin
user. So right here you see us for user name,
I can say admin, and then it asks for email
address, I've asked him that, and then it
asks for password. I can't say that again.
So now these UCC supplies are created successfully,
what I just input I can, does not be created
successfully. And I can use these to log in.
Yeah. So if I say admin, and I come here and
just input the password, and I enter, she's
gonna take me to an admin dashboard, as you
can see right here, right here, I can maintain
and control my size, any hour, like, without
even having an external database UI. So if
I come to this users, you're gonna see that
I'm going to see all the users I have in my
project. So right here, I only have one user,
which is admin. And that is me, which was
the user I created, right here in the command
line interface. So later, we are also going
to integrate our going to add sign in and
sign up. So once these are registered, it
will be saved to this list, also going to
do all those. But what we want to do now,
we created this database name feature. And
as I told you, we migrated that into our database.
But why aren't we seeing it here? Let me explain.
So this admin panel, there's a file in our
project, which is controlling the admin panel,
if we come right here, you're gonna see we
have admin dot p y. So this file is really,
we need to register our modules, because he
says register your modules here. So this Module
Database, which we created, we need to import
it here and register it in the admin, once
that is done, is automatically going to reflect
here. So what I just need to do is to say,
from does modules, import feature. And then
now I can just say, admin does, sides does
register. And then this is just gonna save
feature. I was I saved these, like, come on
each refresh, you're gonna see now that I
have a new database table new features. And
now I have no database right there. So let
me just create a new database a new data,
let me see, quick, let me see, our product
is very fast. And they let me just save it.
So now that I've saved the, we have one new
object in our database. Now I can come here.
Since I have one object in my database, I
don't need to use all these that I created.
Again, all these right here. So now these
are old, we don't need all of these. Let me
add another object in my database and say,
reliable. Say, we are very, very, very, very
reliable. I know I'm gonna eat safe. So now
I have two objects. Well, how can I get all
this data that I have right here in my views,
or in my project. So what I need to make sure
I'm doing First of all, is that I'm importing
that feature, a feature module. So this module
right here, is linked to this database linked.
So once I assess this feature in my code,
automatically, I'm assessing all the values
we have in this database. Now I'm gonna have
a new file, I'm gonna have a new variable,
I'm gonna name it fixture fixtures, and I'm
gonna say fixture objects. So, I'm gonna explain
what this means. So we have this new variable.
And this new variable is getting from this
fixture that we imported. And it's saying
dot objects dot four. So this feature that
we imported is this database. Now, each of
the value we have in this database, each of
the data is an object. So as you can see these
objects one object to so it saved from that
feature database gets all the objects we have
here, get every single thing as storage in
this variable. And now this variable is a
list. And then right you are passing it to
the HTML. Let's come here. And then illegible
statements because we don't have a boolean
value again, we just have the name And did
you. So while looping through the data we
have here, let's go into our project and see
what we're gonna get. So let's see. It says
fast, reliable, easy to use affordable. And
I'm sure this because we've not saved our
file, so let's come here is safe. And then
let's refresh and see what we're gonna get.
Good. So as you can see, it says, quick operates
is very fast and reliable, we are very, very,
very, very reliable. So there might be some
errors in the code, as you can see right here.
And that would be because of the way we put
it here, I'm very sure. But you can see that
those two are shown. So they just have the
control Z here. So that was where we added
a problem. Let's save it. And once we hit
refresh, we should have that styling arrow.
So you see, we have quick, we have reliable.
So now you see where we linked from our database
right here. And we linked it right here into
our project. So what I'm going to do now is
that I'm not even going to go to my code anymore,
I'm just going to come right change my database,
I'm going to add a new data. And now let me
say, a fully let me say, we very affordable.
And then when I eat safe, noisy after objects,
if I come and eat you fresh, you're gonna
see now that I have three objects, which is
affordable, and we are very affordable. So
what is my database is now what is reflecting
you, because of what I call it. So I hope
you guys understand and enjoy what we've been
doing in this Django course. Because this
are the basics you need to know to get started
really coding with Django. So now, let's continue
with some things. We've seen how to create
our modules, we've seen, we've talked about
the admin panel, we've talked about how we
can add on fetch data from the database. And
those are the most important things are going
to need anytime we're working with any projects
in Django. For now, let's use the if statement,
just like we used before, but now we're getting
our data from here. So let's say if the name
is squeak, then we want to just add something,
we can do anything. So I just want to show
this to you as an example. So right here,
we can see. See, if the feature does dad's
name is equals to quick, then we can just
say, can never be and say this fixture says
sides is quick. And then we can end the if
statements. Now let's save the outcome, you
then hit refresh. So as you can see right
here, it says this feature says our site is
free, because it says that the name is quick.
So of course I'm sure it's because there is
an error. So let's just do the best right
here. And then let's refresh it again. And
you should be beneath this. So you can see
these features is our site is quick, because
it gets that the name of this particular data
is quick. So you can see that that is how
it is easy and doable to manipulate your database
using Django. Now, this is very important
in Django, and I hope you understood what
we've been doing so far on to this point.
Now let's talk about user authentication in
Django. Now, when I say use authentication,
what I mean is signing in as signing up to
a platform, like when you go to facebook.com,
and then you sign in to the platform you're
dedicating to your account into that platform.
So let's add that fixture in this our project.
The first thing we want to do is to allow
a user to be able to register into our site.
Now this can come with a bit of complexity,
but just follow me along as we do this. So
the first thing we want to do is to Have a
new URL, which will be named register. So
we're gonna have a new URL right here. Then
it should be views, loads register. And then
let's give it a name of register. So we can
save that. And then second thing we want to
have is in the views. So first of all, we
can get rid of these on these on these. So
let's have a new function. And limit register.
lets you just take your request for no less
return render request, register dot html.
So for now, we don't have registered with
HTML. So let's create that real quick. And
then right here, we just create a new file
name is registered HTML. So right here in
this register that HTML wants to have a simple
form. So see, sign both below. Now, we're
going to use the form tag on this shouldn't
mean like an h1 right here in the form tag,
we want this form to be a post. So same method
should be posed earlier. In this tutorial,
I talked about why we're going to use suppose
for this kind of form, and then the action
should still be this register. So I want you
to come back to this page. And then we're
going to have an input. The type shouldn't
be text. And then let's give it a name of
user name. And then let's close it. Before
we close it, let's give it a bit. So let's
see user name. And then we can just add another
one for the email. So right here, we can say
email. And any type of this one should be
an email. And then the name should be email.
So if we go to slash register, so you can
see user name, email, and then let's have
for the password, so this should be passwords,
the first password, and the type should be
password. And the name should also be password.
And then this should be repeated password.
And the type should be a password. And the
name should be like password to finally have
one more thing, which would be the input for
the Submit. button. So this is a Brb, so it
should look good. Now let's hit refresh. And
as you can see, we have the user name, email,
password, repeat password as Submit. So we
fill this in an installment now, nothing is
gonna happen. So they say, just a team. And
then as you go, live your random passwords
and random tweets, I mean, nothing's gonna
happen. But it gives us this error and says
CSRF verification field. So the reason why
it's given us this era, as I explained earlier,
is because why isn't a POST method, and then
we didn't add the CSRF token. First, come
up and add a route Quique to CSRF underscore
token, we save it. So now we have that done.
What we want to do now is that right here
in these views, we want to be able to collect
these, all this data. And then that is gonna
be quite easy. So what we can just do is right
here can just see the user name should be
equals to request dot bulls And then username.
So what this line of code does is that whatever
we're posting into this register view, we
want to get it as storage in a variable named
username. So we're going to do the same thing
for the email. And then you get the email,
the password, the password, and then password
to get it as password to. So now that we have
all these details that we need, what we can
just do is to save all these details into
our database. And the database we're saving
it in is this database right here, users,
this database, so this database is for the
users active on our platform. So let's go
back. And now we get these. So what we can
just do is to just simply say, first of all,
before we get all these, we want to check
if requests, the method is equals to post.
So we're checking if there is a POST method
being like if this if this page is being rendered
with a POST method, they want to get all these
dummies something is being sent to this view.
But if this doesn't happen damage, a user
is just looking for the normal registered
with HTML template. So if his post metal damage
the user as filled in the details and clicked
on submit, and then is waiting to be signed
up. So what we can just do now is to just
see, firstly, we want to make sure is that
this first word is equivalent to this puzzle,
we want to make sure that they are the same,
they are equal. So we can do that by seeing
if password is equals to password two. So
if password is equals to password today, we
can continue with what we want to do. And
then before we continue now, there are some
things we need to import. And then what we
need to import is, we're just going to scroll
down for over a year we need to import redirect
is redirect is going to allow us to say we've
created a user successfully, I want to take
the user to another page, it will allow us
to redirect the user to another page. And
then want to say from Django dot country,
the report dot models import user on both.
So this user is this basically this user model
a senior and then auth is the function are
the methods that allow us to dedicate. So
another thing I want to import is messages.
So from Django, does country input messages.
And I'm going to show you why we need our
messages later. So now that we have all these,
we can continue with our authentication. So
we said if password equals to password to
so even the user, that means right here if
Okay, I know why this is happening. So because
we are just using a request. That's cool.
So first of all, let's save this. Let it refresh.
Let's see. So this is for server to run back
up. So we didn't use the column right here.
After these, we should use our column. And
then let's see. Okay, so let's quickly fix
this before we continue. What we can just
do now is to first of all, got to this, of
this, like this. So now when we save these,
and they will come here. Let's see now it
does work. Okay, that works. So we can call
me on it, refresh. So we have this running.
Let's come back and continue. So now we are
checking if If password is equals to password
to so if this first word is equals to this,
it must be equal, then we can continue with
our signing up process, then want to check
if this email already exists because a user
might use an email that already exists in
our platform, we want to check if the email
the user is providing already exists or not.
So right now, we can just say if user dot
object dot filter, email, because email does
exist. So this is gonna check you the email
already exists. So if it exists, want to throw
an error and say messages. Does info request
email already used. So what I just did here
was I said if use that or talk to the future,
so this user is this user model, which we
imported earlier on. And I said that is our
model is this user database to say I want
to filter the database unchecked, if there
is an email, which already exists with this
email that the user just submitted. So if
that already exists, want to send a message.
So this message was, Remember when I said
I'm going to tell you what this message is
for. So that is what is for is used to send
a response back if there's an error or anything.
So since there's an arrow, which is that the
email is ready in USD, so we say messages
or info requests email already used. So I'm
going to show you how to show all these messages
in your template right here. So if there is
any message you already used, is it going
to show up over here in like a red color or
something, I'm also going to show you how
to do that. So right here, now we say email
already in use. And then we now want to return
the user names, we don't want to continue
with the signup process since the email is
already used. So redirect the user back to
register. So what I just did, after sending
telling the user what happened, we just redirect
the user back to register with just details
right here. So the user has to go through
that form again, and use another email leave.
So want to use another condition. And what
we just want to do is to check if the user
name also exists, because it is almost non
existent the email and the user name, we might
look at, we cannot have one account with two
emails or one account when to use our names.
It just doesn't make sense to because the
leaf user objects dot filter, and then user
name equals to user name that exists just
exactly what I did. Didn't even oppose just
say messages, that's info. And then we'll
say request. on there we can see user name
already used. And after that want to return
the user to the register. Turn reader rich.
Now after doing this, what we just want to
do now is so if password is equals to password
to then want to continue with the signup process,
and then if you don't object or future dot
z is show the user this error. Or if the user
name is existing showing this error. Else
that means if any of these is false, we just
want to do is to create the user. So if any
of this is false, that means the user name
is brand new, and the email is brand new.
And the password is correct. The initials
created our user. So we can see user cannot
be equals to the user. Objects not create
user. Now we can say create user in which
the user name is equals to the user name Then
email, it goes to email. And then password
is it goes to a password. So what I just did
know was, I said it should create a new user
with these credentials. So these are the credentials
in this credential. So when the user name
equals to this user name, the email equals
to this email and the password, I just picked
one from this one of these two passwords,
since they are the same thing. So I just think
the first one. So now that we have all those
details, what I just want to do is to go ahead
and save that user. So the user does save
the code. Then after doing this, I just want
to redirect the user. All First of all, to
the login. So since the user can guess been
created successfully, unless redirect the
user to the login, so the user can try to
log in and see if the E was created successfully.
So we use the if statement, if the password
is equals to this, and then you should just
go ahead and do this. But what if the password
is false, like if they are not equal, they
will need to have an else statement that says
those password is false, they send a message
I say messages dot info, requests, and then
received buzz words, not the same. And then
we just redirect the user back to the register.
So after that, we can just say, after everything
is also loaded these so if it's not a request,
the method is not post and you just get, it
can just do these. So let's see right here,
we can see else like this. So it is just a
normal request on this page, he can just render
this registered with HTML. But now what we
want to do is I want to show all those messages,
if there is any error, see these messages,
we need to show it right here if any error
occurs. So first, to show these messages we
need to do is very easy, we just come up here
and say we'll use a for loop. We'll say for
message a messages, like an H five, that just
showcase the message. So whatever messages
they just shut cases, and unless they ended
the folio. So and for now, let's just do the
messages, a simple styling, so we can see
this. And then let's give h5 color of the
rich. That's to show a warning. So now all
these is working. What I just want to do is
to come here. First of all, since I know I
have a user name with admin, I'm going to
try to register with admin. And then let's
say admin@gmail.com. I'm just going to use
a random was. Now you'll see it says username
already used does because we already have
a domain user right here, it automatically
gets that this user name has been used and
it tells us user name already use it. We'll
do the same for the gym, you get right now
we don't have any Gmail, but we can come to
this admin user. And then let's see if we
can add this admin user ID via an email. Today's
given an email, say admin@gmail.com. And then
let's just see, try to save it. So now he
does admin@gmail.com. So let's copy this now,
let's try To use that email, well, let's use
a random username, random password. We enter
now what it says is your email already used.
So it gets all those arrows on them. For us
it was. So what I want to do now is let's
use a brand new information so we can see
theme. And then we can see theme geo.com.
It should be under let's say, just give me
some password. Enter. So it says reverse for
login, not fun, I was expecting this error.
So the user, the person has been created successfully.
If I come here and eat refresh, you see now
that I have seen this email address on everything
we need. But the reason why is because of
line 29, where we say return redirect login,
let's quickly go back and see what was going
on. So in line 29, after saving the user,
after creating the new user will redirect
the user to log in. But we don't have any
login function for now. I wanted us to be
able to log in. So we need to do that next.
So now to this point, we've been able to create
a new user, let me just register a user on
our platform. And what wants to do now is
to be able to allow the user to log into our
platform. So when we created a new user, and
we tested our code, we saw that the user was
successfully created right here in our database,
which is Tim, but it gives us an error, which
says return redirect login. So this error
is because we don't have any URL named login
for now. So let's go ahead and fix that we're
going to create a new URL for the login, our
gonna allow a user to log into the site, then
when a user logs into the sites, instead of
just showing all these dummy or starting data.
Let me quickly open our site. So quick, quick,
quick. So instead of showing like one page
or so it can just say welcome team, or welcome
admin or whoever the user is, we can do that.
So let's go ahead and do this. So right here,
what we just need to do is to make sure to
become into urls.pi, we need to create a new
URL named path. Then is given login views
dot register. Now view the login. And then
the name should be login. So now that we have
this URL, we need to create a function named
login. So right here, right below the register
function. Let's create a new function for
the login. Take a quiz and then press pause
for now. No, no, no, let's return render request
and then login dot html. So let's copy these
and this should be your login. So let's save
that. Right here. Let's create a new file
name login dot html. Right in here, there's
an h1, which is looping now. I'm below it
loads of form. And then this form wanted the
action to be login and the method to be post.
So now there's a p tag that says username.
And then an input like wasted type of text
and the name of the user name. And then there's
another one just for the password
and then input type, password and then Give
it a name of password. And then the last one,
we're gonna have just have a break right here.
And then another input for the Submit. So
types of meat Are we safe. So now we have
this page, go to the login now, you see now
that we have this login page. So let's fix
this login, let's make a user really be able
to log in. So what we just need to do just
what we did in the views for the register,
we can just do for the login also offers and
get is a POST method to say if request dot
method is equals to post is a POST method
that was to get the user name which was sent
shouldn't be request dot posts. And then user
name and then the password which was sent
also. We shouldn't be request this boosts
password. So now that we have these two, information
saved in the variables, what we can just do
is to say user attribute equals to us that
authenticate user name shouldn't be equals
to user name. Password should be equals to
pass rush. So now wants to enter educate with
these details. Now we want to log the user
with these details. But before we go ahead
and do this, what if the user provides wrong
information, which is not on our database?
So we want to check for that want to check
if the user is really registered or not. So
we'll see if user is not known. So this is
how to check. So what do you see that is user
is not known. If user is known. That means
the user is fake. That means the user is not
on our platform, but it is not known. Now
as the user is really on our platform is registered.
So we can say dot login, so that we know the
user is real. And their request user after
login design, we can now redirect the user
to the home page. But what if the user is
not registered, so want to send the messages,
messages and the messages receive messages
the info quiz that will say credentials invalid.
And then what to redirect the user back to
this page. So return redirect back to the
login. Page, those who have else. Good. Now
we've done all these. And then what we just
want to do is to come into our login and also
our messages. So we use a for loop I say for
message in messages. There's an h3 saying
the message under less than the full loop.
So they just give you the simple style again.
They will say h3 should have a color of red.
Okay, red. So now, let's just test this out.
We can come here in our page, hit refresh,
and then let's login as the admin so we can
see admin, and then we log in. So it gives
us this arrow and as I said, just erased because
we didn't add our CSRF token. So let's go
ahead and add that right now. So right here,
just say, percentage sign CSRF underscore
token, in small letters. Now receiving does
we eat refresh? No, this mean. And then let's
say Submit. You see now that it redirects
me to this page to the home page, that means
we're logged in successfully. But now for
me to really know, what I'm gonna do is instead
of one page bootstrap, I'm gonna say welcome
whatever the user name is. So let's do that.
Right here in index. Default, where we see
one page bootstrap. So we have get started.
Ah, yeah, right here. Again, no, no, no, this
should be easier. So let's just add a P and
see if that is what we're looking for. Again,
know that this is it right here. So there's
no age, so isn't the one with space. So this
is just right here. So let's quit this. So
we can do now we guys an if statement and
say, user that is underscore often seek ated.
So this is checking if the user is logged
in. And then if the user is logged in, instead
of showing one page bootstrap, we just want
to show welcome. And then we'll say welcome
the user. username, associate user, dot username.
So this will get the current user that is
loading and get it user name, sorry to say,
welcome admin. But what if the user is not
logged in what the visuals are random guest
user visiting, then want to have another statement.
So then, we just ended up for end use statement.
And if now let's go check this. With refresh,
we should see welcome admin. So as you can
see, now it says, Welcome Academy. But now
let me just copy this URL, and then open like
an incognito tab, or private window where
no user is logged in, you will not see that
that will be different. So what's going to
be written here will be different. So that
is where we're not talking more about dynamic
values, the same page, the same code, the
same everything, but different output. So
now I see says one page bootstrap, where it
says welcome admin, if it seemed that is logging
into, say, welcome, Tim, it was john, it will
say welcome, john. So that's how you can do
simple stuffs like that. And then let's go
back to our code. So right here, we've seen
how to do this, we can also do the same thing
for you, we will see all services. If the
user is not logged in, like if the user is
just here, we can change all this to log in
sign up. And then once a user is logged in,
we continue to log out. So we've talked about
how he can register on our platform. We've
talked about how he can log in on our platform.
But we have not talked about this, our user
can log out. So we need to add a lot of functionality.
So you don't always talk in our platform,
or just be trying to clear cookies and time
the user wants to log out. So we just want
to have like button year where do you say
get started and actually log out once we click
on it. So this is the easiest thing to do
in this tutorial. Now we're just gonna search
for your CDs get started. Getting this is
it right here. So you know that's not just
search you Okay, so this is it right here.
Since we already know where it is, what we
want to do is use that if statement again,
and see that if the user is logged in, then
what want to show the is logos where the user
is not logged in, what want to show do is
login. So let's see. If If user that is underscore
authenticated, means users logged in, I want
to show feature for a user to log out. And
then this, I'm going to leave him blank for
now. I'm going to come back when I've done
the URL and the views for the logout. I'm
going to come back and change us. But what
do you do user is not logged in, so there
will be an else there, what I just want to
show is this same thing, but what I want to
show now is login or signup. So now let's
check this ad right here. I'm logged in. So
I hit refresh. It says our close tag, if so
the reason why this give us an error is because
as I said, we need to end the if statement
whenever we're finished. So and if they will
come in each refresh again. Since we're logged
in on this browser, we should see log outs.
Good. When we come to the incognito where
we are not logged in, we should see login
or signup. Good. So now the same button, but
different texts. This is what I've been talking
about when I say dynamic when I say something
is dynamic. So now let's take care of this
login of this log out. First of all, this
login should be easy, I can just redirect
the user to log in. So I mean, come on is
refresh. So if a user is not logged in, I
can click here and take us out to the login.
And at council are like a bottom below, I'll
say if you are not logged in this, if you
do have an account, then create one by signing
up. Now accounts will do that. So what wants
to do is log out. Now let's do that we can
just do is to come into VS code. And then
let our new URL path log out. Views does log
out. Me name equals to blog outs. And then
in the views right here, you can just have
to log out which take your request. Over there,
what I just want to do is to see what does
look out requests. So this single line of
code will log the user out of our platform.
And then once the user has been logged out
of the platform not to read put on and redirect
the user back to the home page. So now let's
check this out. Well before we can check it
out, we need to come to our index. And they
right here in the logout, we need to link
it to log out. Good. So we come here now on
it refresh. So once we log out, it will redirect
me back to this page. But now it doesn't show
welcome admin and he is login or signup. So
that's how to do the basic user authentication
in Django. I hope you got on and as to what
we did, up to this point. So now we're going
to be looking at dynamic URLs in Django, to
what I mean by dynamic URLs is to for example,
we have the same URL but with different ID
passed in it. So let me just quickly explain
this practically. Let's say we have this our
website slash Tommy taco. So our website slash
Tommy and then this is the File page one is
going to give us an error because we don't
have anything like that. But let's and this
is the profile page for this user named Tommy.
And then we also have user name team. And
then we also have for a user named john. So
let's say we have for every user on our website,
they have each profile page. So for us to
go, this is just going to be one page, we
are going to code. But because it is getting
different user name, it is going to be different
outputs. So that is dynamic URL routing, different
URL being passed, or different values being
passed in the URL. Now, let me explain this
more practically. So let's come right here.
And then, you know, URLs, you know, up, close
this up. All right here, we can do something
like pass, then we can see something like,
posts slash str, big K, and then we close
it. So what this means is that we're having
slash posts or website slash posts, then slash
strings. And we are naming the string DK.
So it's just like a variable. So the variable
is named BK and is a string, if we want it
to be an integer, we can just say, both, I
like sticking with string. So now we can just
add a comma and say, views, posts. And then
we can give it a name of posts. So now first,
to be able to collect this in our views, we
need to come here now. And then scroll all
the way to the bottom. Another new view, I
say, posts, service shaky vs post return s,
so posts, and you're gonna take a request.
And after this view, taking a request is also
going to take that particular variable which
has been passed, which is called PJ. And then
now what we just want to do is to say, so
we have this PK, and then Kathy return render
request, and the list goes does HTML. So there's
a script a new file, named pose dot html.
Now let's send whatever value is in that URL
to this post HTML. So we can see BK should
be close to p gay. Now let's save this. Right
here you see the value in the URL is BK. Now
let's save this to become your now I'll say
slash posts, slash 12. So now you see it says
the value in the URL is 12. Today just make
these h1. So now you see says value in the
URL is to have. So whatever is in this URL
is like Tim, the value in this URL is Tim.
So is dynamic, whatever we pass in the URL.
This is what is used in most sites, like when
you have a profile page, which is like john,
and then you see the name of the pressing
john, then like, says, we have the username
adipiscing, became the username to the top
into the database, I get the profile picture,
get the age, get all the posts, get everything
we need about a specific user. So is still
one same template file, one same code, but
different outputs relating to what has been
passed, or query to form in the URL. So that
is what we mean by dynamic URLs. Now, we can
also make this more add some more features
like right here, in the URLs. We can have
our integer here. So now this is an integer.
If we come here, and then we hit refresh,
you're gonna see dices page not found. Why
Why did this happen? This is simply because
we write in our code, we say we want only
an integer right here. So if anything, apart
from an integer is being Pass in the URL,
if you see it or not found, so it's not part
of our code is not part of our project, whereby
change is now 298. And it enter, you see now
it says the value here is 98. That is because
it sees what we told it to ask for, it sees
what we told you to look for. So that's the
same thing we can do with any type any, any
data type. But the good thing with string,
what I like using string is because I can
put in an integer in a string, and it goes,
it's gonna see it as a string, even if I mean
it as an integer. So most of the times you
want to use strange because it helps you avoid
playing the arrows. So you don't want to use
integer there. And then someone queries your
side and say same. And then let's go for changes
to an integer and say team, and the President
comes to your site and then sees these arrows.
Of course, this is not developed by just a
user that wants to use your site. Even if
you set debug to false, the best, he still
doesn't want to see an error. So most of the
times my personal devices, when you are using
your dynamic you are set, you are very, very,
very specific about it, I will advise you
to use the string in it. So we can also do
something like making this more usable. So
let's change this to string back. And then
right here. So you know, this in our counter,
just remove all this. So let's have a post,
which is equals to 12345. Then there's john,
yeah, that's fine. And then we're passing
this
to counter dot html. So we'll pass it right
here. So now in counter, where I can just
do is to have a for loop. So now I can look
through that post, I can see for post in posts
on there, let me end the follow. What I can
just do now is to have a link tag. So in this
h1, I can have a link tag I say. Let me give
him blank for now. And then what I can just
see his posts. So right here, for me to what
I want to do is, let me come to the counter.
So I'll go and go to slash counter. So you
can see that I have 12345678. So correlating
to the amount I add in this list around to
do is that once a user clicks on the first
one, it should go to slash post slash one.
And then if you click on like this team, you
should go to slash Brewster's team. So if
you know how to do this, then you know how
to query it from the database when you just
do object dojo, and then get everything you
need. Let's just do that quickly. So now,
what I just want to do is to say, the percentage
sign and close that, and then I'm just gonna
say URL. posts. And then was the ID buzz?
No, just first. Yes. So like this, on the
winner, eat refresh. They're gonna see that
the first one is eat one, eat. The last one
is john. Which right here is john. If I go
back, and I eat this, you see steam, if I
go back in our indies you see is four. So
that's how to get from like a list and then
turn it into a URL. So this simple trigger
this demo feature I taught you, it can be
used also when you are getting some values
from the database. And then you can just turn
those into the URL. So let's say for example,
you have a blog. And each of these stands
as blog posts from your database right here.
So the same blog one was either click on it,
you should be able to read all the posts of
the phrase blog, blog to read all the posts
also blog three, and so on. so far. So now
I hope you understood what we did in this
part. So what I want to do now is walk you
through the steps of how you can connect another
database provider into your Django project.
So throughout this project, we were using
SQL lite, which was provided by default for
us by Django. So I said there are other ones
like Postgres for our cu, MySQL, dm two on
so many that you can even think of. For this
video, I'm going to be showing you how to
connect Postgres database into your Django
project. So the first thing you want to do
is to go to search engine and just download
Postgres so what you want to type is download
Postgres. So this is going to take you to
decide whether you'd be able to download Postgres
obviously. So, yes, this one, Postgres does
Boggs slash download, and then it takes you
there. You see different versions, and then
different years for different OS. So just
click on yours. I'm on Windows, so I already
have Postgres installed. So I'm not going
to town to these. But if you're on Linux,
click on decks. If you're on a Mac, click
on this windows, Solaris, BSD. And then the
next thing want to download is PG admin. Actually,
recently, once you download Postgres PG admin
automatically comes with you. But if you download
Postgres and install it, and you don't see
PG admin, then just come here and download
PG admin, and just download the one for us.
So once you have all those downloaded and
installed, you can just open up your PG admin.
So once you open up your PG admin, this is
what you are going to see. So now, what you
want to do is to open up this server like
this, and then under Postgres SQL, open up
database. Now, if you want to create a new
database, just right click on this database
and eat, create, and then click on database.
So now this is going to bring a form for you
to create a new database. So we can add a
database, my project. And let's save it, that's
gonna create a new database for us. So that
should save all this are saved are created
our database, I'm going to show you how to
connect that database into your Django project
very easy enough. So this should create. Give
it a couple of seconds. Sure, let's see. This
shouldn't take this long. But most of the
times sometimes PG admin usually lags or comes
through did to your system. So see, okay,
good. So that has created we can close this
one up and open that. Now that we have these
opened, we know that the name is my projects,
where we can just do is open schemas. And
then open up tables. So as you can see the
tables is empty. What we can do now is to
come into VS code. And they want to go into
settings just pure to open up our project
folder, and then go into settings spy. So
rise, down below are
going to go to go We'll see database. So right
here where we see database, what we just want
to do doesn't default was a change from engine.
So we can see is Django DB dot backends dot
SQL lite three want to change that to PostgreSQL.
So plan this, and then the name should be
the name of the database. So we know that
the name of the database is my project. So
right here, I just want to have my project.
And then the next thing that should be clear
is the user And the user is Postgres, so just
use us us Postgres. And then after that is
the password. So the password which you set
when you first created when you first open
up the PG admin is what should be in here.
So I'm going to leave that blank for now.
And then the boost for now is the localhost.
So we have all these. And then once you have
all these in here, the next thing you need
to do is to open up your command prompt. And
then right in your command prompt, you need
to install two libraries, and the sidecar
to specifically be installed. Cycle two. And
then after installing cycle two, I already
have that installed, so I'm just going to
bring the out of it. So I'm breaking out of
it. And then I'll say FP install pillow. So
these two libraries are gonna allow you to
be able to connect Postgres to your Django
project. Without these libraries, you're going
to receive an error. So this pillow takes
care of everything. Let's say you have a database
that deals with images or files, this pillow
takes care of it asac have to connect them
together. So because this requirement already
satisfied, I already have that installed.
So once you have this setup, and you have
this installed, we'll just need to do is just
Python menage does poi make migrations. So
before I say make migrations, let me go into
my code and input my password. So they're
right here, there's gonna see make migrations.
And this see the migrations to make. So let's
give it a couple of seconds. Oh, that shouldn't
take time. So was this big migrations is just
gonna suppose just cannot change detected.
So by turn, manage. Those few are migrate
soon, is performing all migrations for this
time, taking into Postgres. So now we will
come back to Postgres on the on this table
is now right click on it refresh, you're gonna
see that we now have a bunch of tables, even
with that model, which we created my app underscore
fixture. So if I just drag this down, and
I say view, data, all rules. So I'm going
to view all the data I have in that mom fixtures
model under my app. So let's wait for that
to come off. And let's see. So this shouldn't
take a while. She just take a couple of seconds.
And it shows all the data base, which we've
saved from our admin panel earlier on. issue
was right here, because we migrated everything
here. It should be the database it should
start using from now on. So you can do the
same for MySQL or Roku, as I mentioned, they're
also similar processes. And I'm very sure
you might find it cool and more helpful to
use some external database provided and just
using the default SQL Lite. So right now,
this is it. And the data output we do not
have anything right here. But now if we use
like if we create a new one now it should
show right here. So this is how to connect
Postgres to your Django project. Now, I hope
you understood everything indeed in this video.
And yeah, so now I hope you know how to connect
the Postgres database to your Django project.
So guys, that's gonna be all for this video.
I hope you enjoyed this. Oh, course. If indeed,
please don't forget to smash the like button
and subscribe. Hey, what's up, guys, welcome
to this video. In this video, we're gonna
be building a simple blog using Django. So
this video is gonna be in two parts. The first
batch, we're gonna do everything we need to
configure the blog. And then we're gonna start
with the posting of a blog, and then showing
all the blog posts. And in the next part,
we're gonna have some more features, like
getting only some particular words of the
posts, right here, and then allowing the user
to click on the post and read your posts.
So I hope you're gonna enjoy building this
with me. And then let me show you a quick
demo of what we're gonna build. So right here,
I have this post, I can click on this post
to read everything right there. And then it's
gonna tell me the day and the time and the
title and the posts are very busy blog can
do the same for any other one. And then let's
quickly read the last one. So now all these
are being getting from the database. Now if
I come here and add a new post, let's just
add some rubbish there. And it's safe. Now
that is saved coming, I need to refresh. So
that is automatically updated here. Now, this
is what we're going to be building in this
video. And then this template we're using
is a very basic template. As you can see,
I'm also going to have the link to this template
and the whole source code of everything we're
going to be building in the description below.
So you can have that if you want to check
it or anything to do with it. I'm going to
leave it in the description below. And having
that said, I think we should just dive straight
into this video. So guys, the first thing
I want to do is to create a new Django project.
So right here in this folder, I have this
index dot HTML file. Now this is the file
to the template we're going to be using for
this blog. So I already have this template
done to, we're just going to be talking about
mostly the back end functionalities. So I'm
just going to import this template into my
projects. But first of all, I need to create
my project. So in this folder, I'm going to
create my project. So now I just copied this
directory and come into the terminal Mr. VS
code, right up inside that directory. And
then I can just Okay, so let's open up the
normal terminal, to go into the photo sources
CD. And then now we can see Django, I think
admin start project. And then we can say blog.
So now this is gonna create a new project
in this folder, named blog. So in a second,
it should do that. So that is done. If I come
here, now I can see plug. And then in there
also, I'm also going to create, I'm going
to go in the CD blog, I'm going to say python
manage.py. Start Up Alemany posts. So I'm
going to start a new app and image posts.
So done. Now if I come into the blog, I'm
gonna see a new photo. So named posts. So
I'm done with this Tommy now I don't need
anything yet again. So I'm going to close
that up. And then now what I just want to
do is to open up let me close this terminal.
I'm just CLS and then I can make this short.
And close it up. And now I just want to opened
up project I just created in my VS code. So
I'm going to open folder and then so it should
be in. Okay, right here. blog. Yeah. So blog
and post. So I'm gonna select folder. Just
gonna open that up. Yeah, and good. So now,
there's gonna quit this. And then I'm going
to come into the folder. And I'm gonna drag
this index at HTML, I want to drag it into
the folder. So now I have everything in you.
I don't need any other thing from the folder.
So right here, I'm gonna start all the things
I need. So first of all, let's run this our
projects are made sure that everything is
working fine. So right in here, I'm going
to save advice on one niche that's boi Ron's
server. Now this you run our project on the
localhost 8000. Okay, now let me come into
my browser. And then go on as you see the
default Django template. As you can see, it
says install work successfully. So let's head
back over closer. And now let's just start
with the URL mapping. So I'm gonna come into
posts, and then I'm going to create a new
file, name it urls.pi. Right in here, I'm
going to set up all my URLs. Now, if you don't
know what a Django URL is, is basically the
different path you have in your website. Let's
take example facebook.com. So facebook.com
is the main website. Then when you go to facebook.com,
slash notifications, there's another URL,
go to facebook.com, slash messages, there's
another URL. So think about that in this project.
So URLs is different spots in our website.
So now, let me show you how to configure a
URL. So I'll say from Django dot URLs, import
path. So this is just a default Django function
that allows us to, you know, configure URLs.
So I'm going to see URL patterns. Again, there'll
be a list, and I'm going to save path. And
when I leave him blank like this, it means
the home URL. Now if I put something like
notifications, what this mean is slash notification
or website slash notification. When I leave
him blank, it means the own URL. So now I
can say views dot index, and I can give it
a name of index. So this is saying that once
a user comes to the home, it should go to
the views dot index function. So that means
in this views.py file, it should look for
an index function and then do whatever was
being asked to do. As we can see, we don't
have any index function a view, we're gonna
have to create that. First of all, we don't
have views imported. So we have to say, from
views from this import views. So now we have
to use a button, we can say view dot index,
and then we just give it a name of index.
Now that's it. And then right here, let's
create a new function and name it index. That's
going to take your requests. Now we want this
to render that simple HTML page. But before
we do that, if we just type return, render
this out to render an HTML page, and we do
requests index dot HTML, if we do this, we
aren't going to see this is either going to
give us an error or is going to show us the
Django default template. Now for us to for
Django, to know where to get this interpretation,
we need to do it in a specific way. So in
the root directory, we're gonna have to create
a new folder and name it templates. And then
we push index dot HTML into template, so want
to move it. Now it is inside templates, this
is how it's supposed to be. But we're not
done, we need to come to blog and go to settings.py.
So right here in settings, or to pure Why
are gonna scroll down to dares are gonna see
this deer slash templates. Now, what this
is saying is that whenever a user requires
an index, an HTML page, it should go to the
base directory, which is the root directory,
then it should go into the folder named templates,
and look for that exact HTML page. So when
we're trying to render this HTML page index,
HTML, is going to request for this index dot
HTML in the root directory. And then it's
going to look for a template name, a folder
name templates, and then gets done index dot
HTML. So now we have this. But again, let
me scroll up to installed apps. And I have
to add this app I created which is posts,
you have to add it there. So now I can save
this. And now this can be rendered. So I can
save this also and save this. But if I come
here and eat, refresh, boom, nothing still
happens. And this is because we configured
all this in our app, we need to configure
it for our main project. So project we know
where to look for a URL. Now, for us to do
this, I'm gonna say from Django dot URLs import
path, you also have to import include And
then we can see the path when you use the
boom is gonna include was dot URL. Now what
this is saying is that once a user comes to
the home, which is just the main website,
it should include the own URL in posts that
you are opposed to Yara is our app dot URLs,
which is this. So it's going to look for something
similar to this, and this is it. So we can
close this up. Now we come here to refresh,
boom, you can see now that we have this HTML
page, we have a written set of whoever the
front end set up. Now, I guess it's time for
us to do the main stuffs. So now, what we
need to do is to create a database that is
going to store all our blog posts. So it's
going to store the title of the blog post,
when the blog post was created. And then the
main body the main text of the blog post.
So we're going to come into modules, which
are gonna create a new Django model, let's
say class. And then let's see posts. So I
will say models dot model. And now we can
see, the try to shouldn't be equals two models,
dot character feud. And then we have to set
a max length. Let's set the title should be
like 100 shouldn't be more than 100. And then
we have to do the same thing for the body,
which is the main posts. The body of the post
was also models towards character field. And
then the max length. Because says, like, let's
say, a million, because some blog posts might
be who. And now, the next thing we need to
set is the dates this post was created. So
we can name it created, underscore art. Unknown
as models, dot date, time field. And then
for us to pass in a parameter we need to import
date, time is a default fight on libraries,
you can see from date, time, import date,
time, basically, date time. So now we can
just pass this date time in years. So whenever
this is created, this is going to be saved
with it, we're going to get the current date
and save it with the source in defaults. defaults
should be equals to the date time.no. On the
nose leave blank to be true. So now this is
good, we can save this. Now we have our modules
done. And you know, in Django, one ever you
create a new module or you add any changes
to your Moodle, you need to make migrations
and migrate to the database. So let me create
a new seminar right here. And then all I'm
just gonna do is make migrations and migrate,
which is python managed.py. Make migrations.
Okay. Make migrations. Yeah, it's updated
data on then python manage.py. migrate. So
this should migrate everything to the database.
Good. So now, as you know, Django has on default
admin panel, which allows you to access all
your database and everything about your site.
To access that we can see our local slash
admin. But you see, it asks us for a login
username and password, but we don't have debt.
So what we need to do is to just come into
our terminal and say Python manage.py, create
super user. So this is going to create a super
user. So we can have our credentials to log
in here. So we can see i'd mean, no, this
is just the username. So say admin, let's
leave the email blank and then give it a password.
Then you So now we have this greatest sucessfully,
we can use credentials to log in. Yeah. So
now we have this, we have our database. This
is the users we have on our site, we didn't
add authentication or anything complex, we're
keeping this very simple. The only user we
are with us, which is the admin. So let me
just go back to the home, where we created
this database of posts, then why isn't it
here? Now, we migrated this model to our database,
but we didn't save it or showcase it in our
admin partner. To do these are going to have
to come to admin.py. First of all, import
or say, from dot models, import posts. So
we have this model imported. And then we're
gonna say admin, dot site, dot register. On
the watch, I was gonna register that posts.
When I come here, I need to refresh. Boom,
now we see posts, as easy as that. So now
we have this database, which is very good.
Let's just go ahead and create a new post.
And then let's say, tied to pleasure, say,
out to deploy
Django project to Iraq. So for the body, I
want to have this report. So I'm just gonna
go to my website collects the blog posts from
the otter deploy Django project. And then
there's gonna copy all of these, basically,
I'm just copied to this place again. And then
just going to paste it right there. And then
the date is automatically going to get the
latest date the correct time. So I'll save
this. Now we have the first one. Okay, we
don't need this. We do not need all these.
Yes. These posts. So let's just save this.
So we got that. Let's just create another
one. What do I have here. So best way to get
started with Django sculpted is based on then.
Oh, my gosh. Good. Copy. Paste unsafe. So
we have to let's add one more. So we can use
the database and showcase it right here. So
go back, get one more, let me say installation
of bytes. Okay, that piece paste. And then,
yeah, right here. And then we also paste this
and then good. Now we're good to go. So now
we have three posts, Raftery blog post on
this our blog. And now we just want to assess
everything right here, instead of just having
no dummy data. And what we want to do is I
want to use a CLI. So in this site to add
in is obviously going to be the title of the
post, like how to deploy a Django project.
And this is going to be the date. And this
is going to be just like maybe the first line
of the main blog posts. So once a user clicks
on these, they're gonna take the user to read
the whole post. Let's go ahead and do that.
So now we got this. We don't need this again.
No, we don't need this again. Yeah, so now
what we just need to do, right here, we can
open up our index of HTML, we're gonna need
that. So we're gonna make this dynamic or
dispose dynamic recognizes static posts there
is there which is just this, we're gonna get
all these from our database soon we're writing
these. So to dad's face after import that
our Moodle say from dot models import post.
So now we have posts imported we can assess
all the data or all the objects in that post.
So we can just say posts should be equals
to boasts objects dot all and then we can
just pass it right here on sipos. And then
save posts. Now they should be a variable
suppose. So in this particular line is we
have a variable and we are giving it posts,
which is this we imported dot objects dot
all that means we're getting all the objects
from this database right here you can see
this object one object to object three. So
I get in all the objects saving it here, and
then we're passing it into our template, which
is index dot HTML. So we can see this year.
And now when we come here, we can simply remove
this, we don't need this. So now we're gonna
use a for loop from year, so we're gonna use
a for loop to assess for those data. So we're
gonna see for posts in posts, so for post
in posts, this posts is this variable we passed
to our index. So now we can assess it as a
variable. So as in for post in posts. Instead
of writing the title ad, now we want to write
posts, dot title. In case you're wondering
where we get this title from this title is
the title of the page of the posts does what
we assigned it in the model. Suppose a title
and they should be post created ads. And then
some texts. So this shouldn't be boss dot
body. Right? Yeah, well, now instead of just
on body want to make it like maybe only the
first 10 words, they select the first 15.
So we should be able to do something. Let's
leave it for now, then we're gonna change
it when we see what our output is. So now
we can end this for loop. Now, when you're
using a for loop in Django, templating, you
have to enter a for loop, even though it's
just going to go through out the wall, code
beneath the for loop. So it's quite different
from normal for loop in Python. You know,
in Python, we use indentations to know when
to end a for loop, we use the end for to end
a for loop. So now let's save this icon here
and hit refresh. Good. So we have Tommy's
blood, we about to deploy Django projects,
we have the date and the exact time we created
this. And then as you can see, we have all
the posts. So this is working pretty fine
now. But what want to change is that once
again, two things. First of all, we don't
want all these posts right here, because if
a user can read all the posts from the main
page, then he doesn't need to click on that
post. So we don't want all the posts when
he wants me to like the first 20 words or
something like that, or the first 50 characters.
And then, as you can see, this is 11:30pm.
This is level 32, level 32. Now 1130 is earlier
than 1132. Now we want the latest posts to
be on top. So as you can see, this is the
oldest post. So if this is the way our blog
is Dominus, the first post we write is the
one that's always going to be on top, and
we don't want that. So now let's go back in
year, and then, to make the latest post be
on top are gonna say for post in posts, reverse.
This is very easy. They'll say reverse, I'm
just gonna reverse it for you. So we got this
reversed, D. So now as you can see, the latest
one is what is on top installation, Django
best way and now to deploy Django. So the
latest one we add is one that's gonna come
on top. So we have that. So guys, what we're
gonna do next now is to make sure that it
doesn't show all the characters of the posts
or the old body of the post. So I'm gonna
die in the next video. Welcome back to the
second video in this Django blog tutorial.
This is a second and last video. So in the
last video, we stopped at getting all the
list of blog posts, and then making them order
in, according to the latest posts. So at first,
when we put it, it was showing the oldest
posts at the beginning. But now the latest
poll shows at the beginning. And I said in
this video, we're going to continue why. As
you can see, all the blog posts is showing
on the front page, which we don't want only
ones like 10 words, or 20 words to show that
a user should be able to click, and it will
take them to another page to read the whole
text. So that's what we're gonna do in this
video. So first of all, let's remove all these
we don't like the way all the bullets is showing,
so let's change it to lock on it 20 or 30
words. So right here in VS code, we just need
to add impose the body will say, truncate,
truncate words. And then we'll put a colon
and say 20. So this is going to truncate it
to just 20 words. Now when I hit refresh,
you can see now I only have 20 words, I need
to automatically put this three dots, which
shows that you can continue reading when you
click on it or something. So as you can see,
only the first 20 words are showing, which
is looking good. So what I just need to do
now is to make sure that user should be able
to click as you can see, now just plain text
is I can't click. So let's make exactly and
then we're going to take a user to another
page. So right here, it shouldn't be in this
old class. So let's add. So right here at
age 80 going to know where For now, let's
base that back. So this can't calm you're
on this gun calm here. So let's save these.
So this should be going nowhere, but I just
checked. Okay, this is showing, but we don't
like our old DS, as you can see show in line
with purple. Now, we don't want that. So we
can just easily add a simple styling. So they
just we don't need to say style, we can just
add it in the queue this time. I said text
decoration should be none. So this is just
going to make sure that all the styling doesn't
show. Yeah. So as you can see the lines, the
underlines, doesn't show what we see of this
in purple. So very easy, I'm just change it
to color, black. So good. But when I click
on it, it still goes through that same age,
whatever. So now, once exactly gone, it should
take it to a dynamic and unique page. So everything
we're going to be doing is going to be dynamic,
you're going to understand that in a second.
So let's come up now. So what page is the
user going to go to once they click on a post,
let's go create that in the URLs. There's
great one, unlimited posts, save us those
posts, and then we'll give it a name of post
must add a comma right here because the lists,
save it. Right now we don't have any function
new views named posts. So let's go create
that. So say, def posts, requests. And then
let me just render a simple HTML page. Post
dot html. So now we save this, but we don't
have any page like this. Let's create that
quickly. Right here. New File, because the
HTML Okay, so we have with an S. So let's
come here and update that post return s. So
that's good. And now what we just wanted to
do is to make this kind of dynamic. So we
want to right now we can go to slash posts.
But nothing is showing just a blank HTML page,
which is this page. So we want to get all
the data so we once like once a user click
on this is gonna take us to that slash posts,
but it's gonna be like slash posts slash one
slash post slash two. Friends page with different
URLs. So these blog posts since is the first
post is gonna have an ID of one. So it can
be slash post slash one, this can be slash
post slash two, this can be slash post slash
three, if you understand that, and then we're
gonna get all this dynamically from the database.
So let's do that quickly. Right here, we can
just say, we can give it an integer or a string,
just like a string to avoid any errors. So
a string, which is p k, so this is st slash,
post slash a string, which is p k. So we can
see that coming to views. So right now we
are collecting pk. And then what we just need
to do is to say that posts is equals to those
dots objects, not written as the same just
object dot get the one which ID is equals
to Pinky. So once we have these, we just simply
pass it to the HTML, let's copy that here.
And paste. So what we're doing is, once a
user gets this URL, so let's say is going
to be post slash one. I know that slash one
is the ID of, let's say, one of these of these.
So obviously, this we have an ID of one because
it's the first or maybe an ID of zero, maybe.
But once we get the ID is gonna be passed
in this URL from the URL is going to be passed.
Yeah, you can see that this function is getting
that PK, which is the name we gave it right
here. And then from that became using you
to filter our database. So I've added a new
variable. And then once it's been assigned
to the variable is posts, which is our Moodle,
dot object dot get. So it's going to get to
that particular posts, which has the ID of
pk. So then once we have that, we're just
passing it to opposite HTML. Because we did
index dot HTML, we can go there now and access
that post. So right here, let's just copy
the index dot HTML code and use it. Let's
paste. But still, to me is blog. Birds go
to slash posts. Okay, so we need to add something
that is slash one. Okay, so it doesn't have
an ID of one, zero. So let's come into our
data base. Cookie, no, I D, for now. So we
need to create a particular ID. As you can
see, for now, it sees very various ad type
posts as no attribute objects, so it doesn't
see any posts with this particular object,
which is kind of weird. But so what we just
need to do is to make sure that we are doing
the correct thing. So we're basically going
to come back here. Now URLs. So we're passing
the string as be gay ID. And then right here,
we're collecting data and then filtering it,
which is good. So post data objects, okay.
So objects with an S, suppose dot objects
dot get. So now I come here, give it one.
Okay, so post object is not iterable. Yeah,
for sure. So what's the saying in post dot
html, every column here, as it gets here,
was in a for loop to get this now, but in
our index, because we said post dot objects
dot all, which means is getting it as a list
or as a dictionary, or just a list of something
so we can loop through it doesn't mean you
have iterable when it says something to do
his music and look through it. But when we
samples that object dot get only getting one
specific value. So we can look towards specific
values, just one thing. So that's why it gives
us this arrow dots post object is not iterable.
So in our posts, you must remove days and
remote produce. So now if we come here and
click enter, again, we don't have anything
here because wising posts instead of post
return is, but let's leave it at that. But
we have this now. And then right here on to
the post. So our simples are try to pose a
created on posts. That's bad. But now we're
not truncating. Any words, we want every single
thing. Now, let's see. So as you can see,
it says how to deploy a Django project to
Roku. And then it gives us all these. So this
is what we need. So right here, let's give
this on each one. Also, because it's in title.
And then putting the rest is good. So let's
save it refresh. So how to deploy a Django
project to Iraq. And then we have the date
that was created, and then we have to post
for these. So first of all, let's remove this
particular a tag, we don't need that again.
So that is gone. So right here, you can see
that this is perfectly working. But what we
want to do now is from the homepage, we want
the user to click on this, I need to go to
that particular posts. So we have to come
to index dot HTML. And we'll say, instead
of going to an ash tag, says oozes lash boosts
with an S, let's be sure. No one just boosts
this slash boss.id. Just like this, now, the
issue of everything working. Now let's click
on this, you see this installation of Python,
the date it was created with with the old
posts, and let me go back again, or click
on another one, you see this mentioned that
particular post. And if I click on another
one, it takes me to that particular post.
So this is how to beauty of simple, very,
very simple blog using Django. Now you got
some more advanced features, like very advanced
features like images, you can add comments,
like he's actually able to comment, you can
add to different types of text, so the user
can design his text like fonts and stuff like
that, you can add various other things. It's
just the basic, the basic fixture in our blog
is the crud functionality, which is create,
read, update, and delete. So a user should
be able to create a new post, which you can
do from our admin panel, and then should be
able to read the post. So as you can see,
anybody can call me I read this, you should
be able to update the posts. So if I come
here, installation of Python, and I say installation
of Django, and I say safe. And I come here
I need to refresh. As you can see, it changes
to Django, it should change to Django, because
that's what we designed it for. So I really
hope you guys enjoyed this video. And is actually
also be able to delete a post to Konya and
delete a post is going to delete higher. So
we think the leads Yes, I'm sure with no me
on each refresh, it's gone. That's gonna be
all for this video. Once again, I really hope
you guys enjoyed building this with me. Hey,
guys, welcome to this video. In this video,
we're gonna be using Django to build a weather
detector up, so is just gonna get the current
weather situation in a particular city, which
is a search for. So right here, if I just
search for London, and I click enter, it says
London, it gives me the country code, the
coordinates, the temperature, the pressure
and the humidity. So this is what we're going
to be building in this video. So the template
which has this HTML file, and the source code,
which is the final score to define our project,
everything is going to be linked in the description
below. So you can check the description to
get the source code for the front end and
the back end and everything you need. So having
all this said, Let's dive straight into the
tutorial. So guys, the first thing we need
to do is to first of all create a new Django
project. So we're going to create a new Django
project now and we're gonna name it weather
detector. So to do dads we have to say in
Django admin, start project and then we're
gonna say weather subject to something like
this. Then we just hit Enter. And now this
is gonna create a new folder named weather
detector in the directory under folder is
going to contain the Django default boilerplate.
So we can say, CD does go into that folder.
Now we are in this folder. If I press dir,
I'm going to see now that I have managed spy,
and whether the data. So after doing this,
we can just immediately create the Django
app we're going to be using for this project.
So I can say python manage.py. Start up. And
then we just want to name this weather like
this, then you'll see a new folder is going
to be added named weather to doodies. Noisy,
we have weather. Now we're going to import
this project into Visual Studio code. So I'm
just going to open up VS code. And then open
folder. So I'm going to open up that folder
in VS code. So I have it in weather up weather
detector. So this should just go ahead and
open my project right here. So let me just
close this up. So what we are just going to
do now is to just glide with configuring our
templates. So as I said, in the introduction
to this video, all the source code to everything
we're going to be doing on the template file,
I'm gonna link it up in the description below.
So you can get to the template file, which
is the HTML file, and the source code to your
finished project. So if you are stuck anywhere,
you can easily just check the source code.
So we're just going to create a new folder
in the root directory, and then we're going
to name it templates. So now let me pop up
my terminal, or let me just use my command
prompt. Python managers view I run Siva. So
what I'm doing now is that I'm running this
project we just created on our localhost,
so Django is going to run it on localhost
Port 8000. Just gonna copy these, come up
into my browser and paste it. Now you can
see it's showing us that yeah, this installation
works successfully, what we don't want to
see is what we want to see is our own HTML
file, our own template. So let's go back to
what we're doing right here. In templates,
we're just gonna get our HTML template, which
we want to use, and then we're going to fix
it into this template folder. So this template
folder is just basically going to contain
all the HTML files, which we need all our
template files. So I've got my template file
right here, which is indeed the HTML. I'll
say it once again, that this index HTML file
is going to be linked in the description below.
So I'm just going to drag it pastes in templates.
So now we have that. But you know, that's
not enough to tell Django that it should render
the page. So we need to come into weather
detector, which is our main project. And then
in settings.pi file, we're gonna scroll down
to where we see templates. Now see templates
here, that we're gonna look for. Here's where
we see dir is right here to save base dir
slash template. So what's templates? So what
this is doing is that it's telling Django
where to look for our HTML files. So anytime
we request a want to render an HTML file,
is going to come into base directory slash
templates, which is basically in this folder,
where we have our HTML file. So after doing
this, let's just add the app we created, which
is weather. Let's add it to our installed
apps. Nice. So now we can save this. But again,
this is not enough for Django to render that
HTML page. So now we need to go to URL routing.
So right here, you see that once we come to
the home page, we have this default Django
template. So to Django, where to look for
a template, but have not told Django though,
when a user comes to our home page, what HTML
template should you render. Now to do that,
we need to use URL mapping or URL routing.
So we're going to specify that once user come
to this URL, which is our home page. It should
render that index dot HTML folder, which is
right here. So right now, I'm just gonna come
into weather. So we need to create a new file
named urls.pi. Right here These URLs are p
wise where our URLs is going to be stored,
say from Django dot URLs, imports, but to
our importing path, which is going to allow
us to specify different URLs. And you'll see
from the views from your import views. So
also important views, I'm going to explain
why we need this in a second. Now what we
need to do is to have a new list named URL
patterns. Now it should be equals to path.
And then we'll say views dot index. And they
will say name should be equals to index. Now,
what we're doing right here is we're importing
path from Django URLs. So is a default Django
function, which allows us to specify a different
path right here, you can see where we use
it. So this from dirtybird views is basically
this file. So we're importing every function
which we have in this file, every class anything
we have in this file, why putting it into
these URLs with pure. So now, when we specify
a new this year, the URL pattern is a list
variable, which is going to take a list of
all your URLs we're going to have on this
our site. So the first URL, which I specified
is the homepage, that's why it's blank. If
I want to specify, let's say, slash signup,
it should be something like, let's say register,
this is how I'm gonna do it. I can just leave
it blank it just register or is login, I can
do exactly the same thing. Something like
this. Boss, this is the homepage, I can just
leave you blank. Now Django knows we're talking
about this page, the home page. Now when I
say views dot index, or I mean is from this
views.py file, which we imported, go to the
index function. Now the index function is
where we're going to tell Django what HTML
templates or whatever we want to do, which
we want to render. Now, this name is just
basically the name given to this particular
URL. So whenever we want to request for the
URL, or go to that URL, we use this name.
Now we can just save this. And now we know
that we don't have any function named index
in views.pi, we need to do that anyway, you
know, create a new function, I'm kinda silly,
name it index. So this index wants you to
take a request. So we're just going to say
return, render, and then request. And then
index dot HTML. So this is requesting for
index dot HTML in Templates folder. Nice.
Now we can save this. Well, we could call
right here on each refresh, it still doesn't
work. Now, the reason why this doesn't work
is because we configured all these URLs only
in our app, we also still need to configure
it in our main project for Django to know
what we're doing. So we come to weather detector,
which is the main project folder. in there,
we go to urls.pi. And then we scroll down,
where we import path, we also want to import
include, after importing include in the URL
buttons, which is here already, we didn't
write this is there already, we can just say
path. And then we'll say include with the
two arrows. Now what this is doing is that
we're creating another home URL, we're now
in the URLs. py file of the main project.
And then once it comes to this room, it should
include whether or not URLs that means whether
is this app, which we created right here.
And then we go to the URL spy file of it.
And then anything we do to the same path is
what should be done. Yeah, it's just including
the URLs. So if I come here, you see we have
the same blog path. So anything we do here,
I was wondering is taking views dot index,
our are we doing a view dot index, rendering
this index of HTML. So now when we come back
here, and just hit refresh, now you see that
we have this HTML page. So for now, you can
see all these are just dummy data, country
code, country code coordinates coordinates.
So what we want to do now is that we want
the user to be able to search for something
like London. When is it enter, we want to
show the current weather details or weather
status in that particular city? So I just
gonna come back to VS code. So right, yeah,
the index. Now I went to the column into templates,
and in index. So right here, we're going to
scroll down. So what we want to do now, if
we scroll up, you're gonna see that in this
index, we have a form already. Now this form
is using a POST method. The first thing we
need to do in this form is basically in this
input, this search bar, which we have here.
So this form is a post form, as you can see,
using the POST method, in Django, anytime
we're using the POST method, we always want
to make sure to add CSRF token, something
like this. On the squat, okay. Now, once I
save these, and I call massage London, it
gives us this error. Now, because I've not
refresh the page you see of the error, but
take a look at the error, we see it says forbidden.
If I go back, I need to refresh. Now I've
loaded the new one. And I searched London
again. You see now that I don't have any arrow,
nothing is working yet. But we've bypassed
that arrow, which is good. So what I want
to do now is basically just st this detail,
this input right here is this input, which
we see input type text name, city. And then
once you click on submit it, you send this
detail to this view, back to this index dot
HTML view, is still what I'm sending you back
to this page. But this time around, we want
to be able to get some details on things.
So this is easy for us to do, what we just
need to do is just specify the data which
was sending back. So right now, right here,
what we're just going to simply do is come
here, when make sure that you set an action.
And the action should be blank. Now the reason
why these action is blank is because when
we eat so search is sending all the data,
which is only one actually sending this London
data back to this home page. Well, this time
around want to have something yes of country
code coordinate, want to have the real country
code, which should be London, UK or something
like that. And then later, we're also going
to remove these. So that's when he is after
his country decides, by me, when his office
comes to decide this shouldn't be the only
search, we're gonna do all this also. So after
adding the option, and then we're able to
send now what we just need to do is to come
into our views.py file, and then collect that.
So first of all, collect the data which was
sent, we'll say if requests dot method is
equals to posts. They want to say, city shouldn't
be equals to request dot posts. City. Now
what are we doing right here, when I come
to this page, from the normal URL bar, I'm
using a get method to access this page. When
I when I send a form using a POST method,
I'm not sending a form to this page, the method
is different, as you can see now is a POST
method. That's why we're going to say if request
or metal is posts. Now the only time we're
gonna use post is when we're sending a form.
So we're gonna get if the metal is post, that
means obviously, the program's you know, the
form is coming. Then once we know a form is
coming, we just need to collect the form,
say request dot post CT. Now, this city is
this index, this input right here you can
see there's a name of city, if I change this
to place, then also needs to come here and
changes to place. But for now, let's go with
city to make this big again. Just go with
city, or then city top, you understood what
we did, right? So we're just gonna save these.
And then let me just first of all, after sending
the city to this place, let me just pass it
back to the HTML just to make sure we know
what we're doing. So we can do something like
this city. So we're just going to save and
then if I come here So it says local variable
city referred before assignment. Now this
unbundle Kira always happens, anytime you
are using an if statement, and there is a
variable been assigned without adding an else
statement. Now we just need to do else. Sit
CT should be close to blank. Once I save this
and come back and eat refresh, we do have
the arrow again. So anytime we come across
the arrow in Django is always very, very,
very common. You just can just simply use
that to take you over that. So right here,
we have country code. Just see h1, and then
there's a city. So right now, if I refresh
this page, and I hit London, now you see excuse
me back in London. So that's just first verified.
Okay, yeah, we're already passing a data value
from our page back to our page, as I explained
earlier, using different methods in a POST
method is tomorrow. But now, obviously, we
don't just want to see London, I want to see
is the country code, which is not really relevant,
but I think is still key, we can get that
the coordinates, the temperature, pressure,
and humidity, so weather status, and details
of the current city, which you search for.
So for these, we're gonna be using an API,
which is called Open weather map. So it's
a website, which has an API for you to use.
So you can get those details from their website.
But before you can use their API, you have
to sign up to their sites and then get an
A, it's totally free. To sign up, you get
you can get an API, and I'm going to show
you how to use their API. So first of all,
you need to come to your site, which is open
weather maps.org. And then once you log in,
you can just go to API keys right here, and
they are going to see your own key. Now you
can this is free to adjust in for testing
purposes, this is totally free, you don't
need to buy a subscription or anything like
that. Nope. So we're going to be using this
API key to do what we want to do. So I'm going
to show you how to use the API gets the details
of any city, we search research London, it
was such a cry, it was such a cape town with
such Delhi, Mumbai, anyway, who can get the
current windows situation right there, right
here from our Python program, or Django site.
So that's gonna be all for this video. And
then we're gonna finish up these projects
in the next video. So guys, is the second
part in this weather websites tutorial. So
in the last part, I stopped at telling you
guys to get the API key from open weather
maps. So once you have your API key, you can
continue to follow along. So this is the second
and the last part of this tutorial is just
a two parts tutorial video. Now, this API
key is very important for you to be able to
access the API. After getting this API key,
you can continue. Now this is where we stopped
ads, which was where we just pass London back
to this page. But now, whatever city is our
search, want to get the details, what we're
gonna do is go back into VS code. Now that
we're able to send in data from this form
to our views to our templates, we can easily
just get that data and then get the weather
situation in that city. First of all, let's
remove these towers for testing purposes now.
And this also. So now that we have done all
this, what we just want to do, we have the
city. So right here. So now that we have city
want to assess this open meta Maps API from
this code, so we need some libraries, we need
to import JSON. Now JSON is where as the JSON
is, when we send a request to the API is going
to give us a response in a JSON format. So
we need to import JSON to be able to actually
get and then you know, pass or filter this
data. And then we need to import URL lib those
requests. So now that we have this done, we
are very good to go. So right here, I'm just
gonna say something like risks. Now this race
is the request was sending to open weather
maps. Now what I'm just going to do is to
say, URL, leave those requests that URL open.
So I'm going to open a particular URL, and
the URL is going to be HTTP API dot open,
open with a mob.org. Slash data, slash 2.5.
Slash with question mark, then I want to pass
in some parameters, say Q. Now Q is going
to be close to the city. Now this city is
Q is actually a totally means query. So it's
going to be close to the city that the city
will want to get the details of. And we use
concatenation at the city. After adding the
city, what we just need to add right now is
our API key. So we're just gonna say an ID
should be equals to now those only inputs,
the API key which we collected from you. Paste
it right there. So now we have inputted, we
have input our API key. So I'm just gonna
say dot read. Which two parenthesis. So now
that we have this done, we're just gonna go
on a new line. And then what I just want to
do is to say lists. Let me just say JSON data.
Now this is the data I get after sending a
request to this URL. So I'm going to say JSON
data should be JSON dot loot with an S in
order to load risk. Nice. So now I have the
current weather details of this city stored
in this JSON data variable. But now I want
to make this JSON data, I want to change it
to like a dictionary, a Python dictionary.
So it's easier to access, I can just simply
say data equals two. So what I just want to
do is to say country
shouldn't be streamed. And then from JSON
data, see s Y is and then we'll say country.
So now after having these, we just use a comma
to get some other details which we need. Now
let's see what we need right here. That was
amazing. Why puts this down. So we know what's
funny, we need the coordinates, the coordinates.
So another one is the coordinates. Now, they
actually have their documentation where you
can get out to use all these, but I already
know how to use it. So you can just follow
up with this tutorial. So you can also get
some more things about that specific location,
even more than with our situation, the guys
who are getting the coordinates are getting
the country code. Now these are more about
geolocation. So you can use the API for some
more themes can just go check the documentation.
But for now, let's stick with this. So coordinates,
and then also a strange making sure is a strange.
And then from JSON data, what we just want
to do is C o r d, and then another one after
it, I want to get the longitude, which is
short enough to learn. And then to concatenate
if it doesn't look like it space or something.
Now want to concatenate it with the latitude
also send JSON. And then what we don't need
to do is also say, C or D. And then right
here, we're just gonna say lat, which is the
short form of latitude. Now comm put a comma
to get to the next one. So we have the country
code, we have the coordinates. Now let's get
the temperature which is basically what we
need. Let's change it to temp strange. And
then JSON data, then what we just need to
do now is to just the main main exam, which
is the temperature plus gay. So this key is
basically in Kelvin, so it's not in degrees
Celsius degree far away, it is in Kelvin.
So you can also you know, use your Python
code to convert it very easily. But for now,
let's just stick with Kelvin. And then let's
see, we need to pressure and humidity nice.
So just a pressure. We forget our pressure
string. JSON data mean other than preasure.
Nice. So now you can just add our comma. Then
the last thing we need is humidity. Humidity,
then we say the same thing string. Then we
just say JSON data. There we just say mean
and then we just say humidity. Basically.
You meet the tea. Nice. So calsonic Homer
just to avoid any heroes, go right here. And
then we can just come down. Okay. So we're,
I think we're done with this data since we
have it closed here already. So now we already
have everything we need inside this data socios
data shouldn't be empty. So now what we just
want to do is after rendering this, we just
want to pass data. Now we can access this
from our HTML, which is quite cool. So now
let's come in to our HTML. So right now, instead
of all these country code, coordinates, we
can just use these same thing for for the
temperature also, for the prayer, humidity.
And I think that's what we need. So now let's
save this. Let's just save these. And we come
back here. Now this is the key now you see
that there is nothing in the outputs. So now
there's eight slon. Done. Now press Enter.
So it says budget quiz HTTP, we come down
here. Unable to receive, so we are having
some errors. Let's go and check was Yeah,
from this line, the error is coming from this
line. So let's go see. Views dot p y. So let's
see, most of the time, this happens because
of HTTPS. Now, let's go back to our page,
London, we eat enter. So we see the error,
basically. So let's copy this URL in which
we're trying to assess. And then let's open
it in a new page, just to make sure that Yeah,
everything is working. Okay, now, the reason
why we're getting this is because right here,
there is no equals to. So let's go back and
change that. So you can see that whenever
we are passing a value can see there's supposed
to be q, which is a query equals to CT, then
app ID equals this. So let's just say query
equals two then CT. So I think that should
fix our problem. Let's save again. And we
come back here and search for London. Now
you can see very, very good. We have country
code. Great Britain, which is where I live,
I'm just saying coordinates. We have the longitude
and the latitude, then temperature is sodre.
74. points. 34k. Yeah, I think that's correct.
Then pressure, which is DS unlimited D so
ever these which we need. And I think basically,
that's all we need for this project to be
working. We can do some little tweaks like
going back here. Right here in the index.
We just want to have right here is like an
h1 and then let's pass in. Gum, yeah. Yeah,
this CT. So let's make sure the CT it goes
to blank. Then, let's see CT is CT. No safeties,
we come back here. In year we can put CT.
Let's save this and check. As you can see,
we have our page coming in as HTML. So I'm
very sure the reason is because there was
a syntax error right here. So go the dictionary,
we just have to cut that. Do the candles do
something like this. So let's save it and
go check it out again. So we eat enter with
four codes to run. Let's open that up. So
we have an invalid syntax actually. So the
reason is because let me come back here is
because we are not Supposed to pass a dictionary
on, you know this like this. So we just need
to do
is this. So said data should be equals to
data. Now let's save these. And then this
should work back. Let's wait for it like two
seconds or so. Okay, he's reloading. Yeah.
So now let's see, unless it's London. So now
we have London. But you can see that we have
all these not showing. Now the reason why
we do have it shown because it doesn't see
it. Now, as a dictionary, again, it sees it
as a normal variable. So we're gonna have
to come here, index, and we'll see data. Data
that data. So you need to add them. It Oh,
and therefore humidity also. Now when we save
these, come here, but yeah, each refresh and
submit again, you can see now we have London.
And we also have all these details. So that's
basically how to just fix that. So first start.
So let's search for another city, actually,
let's see legace. Now Lagos country good Nigeria,
which is Angie, now we have all these well,
cool temperature, then, let's see another
setting and then we move on. So that takes
us now to exhaust contract with us. And it
gives us the details. Now this is what we
want in this video. One more thing that we
want to pass is when a user comes to this
site, we don't want this to show one displays
to be blank. First of all, there was a search
history show. So we can also do that by first
using an if statement. So after rule, right
here, by going to say e if data dot country
code. Then if we have these they should be
out the country code should be we have these
initial these else, which is our else statement
alleges entity if we don't need else. Now
let's save this and see each refresh boom
is gone. So what we're doing is we're saying
if data does contract code, that means if
we have anything like this, then you show
all of these words, even though it's obviously
this will not be there. So now let's go and
check it again. London, we'd enter now we
have this border, we just come to this site.
Normally we do have these are this is very
good. This is what we want. So I hope you
guys enjoyed this tutorial, which was really
fun for me beauty. And also, if it did, please
don't forget to smash that like button and
subscribe. In this video, we're gonna be building
a simple chat application using Django. So
this is going to be built with Django and
a little bit of Ajax, so a little bit of JavaScript
in it. So we're not going to be using doing
anything so complex, we're not going to be
using them WebSockets channels or anything
like that, just Django on Ajax. And the link
to the source code of everything we're going
to build in this video is going to be in the
description below. So the template file and
everything we're going to build, you can access
it. And this video is going to be in two parts.
So this is the first part and you're going
to have a second part to conclude it. And
yeah, so let's go ahead and test this out.
So this is the room name or user can create
a new room or they just say let's give it
like a room of code Dean. I don't know I'm
just giving it any room and then less and
US team to now enter the room because he is
blank for now. Let's enter that same right
here. We are let's enter as john. Now we enter.
So now I can see I guys almost like it sent.
You see it shows 42 this is a real time and
I got a What's it send you see it shows 42
so this is the simple application we are going
to be building in this video. Now all these
data you're seeing here with the date and
time with the message and the name are going
to be saved in our database. So as you can
see, we're getting back all these messages
in real time. It's actually a fun project
to build, and you're going to improve your
skills in Django. And mixing is really a bit
of JavaScript to even notice it. Let's dive
straight into the video. So guys, the first
thing we need to do to get started with this
project is to obviously install Django. So
as I said, in the intro, we're gonna be using
Django to do this chat app. So let's make
sure we have Django installed. So I'm just
gonna say Pip, install Django. Now this command
line is going to install the latest version
of Django on my computer. But I have Django
installed already. So it should tell me requirement
already satisfied. And note that if you're
new mark, you should type PIP three, install
Django. There's just a small difference between
Windows and Mac, what, there is nothing more
than that. So as you can see, it says requirement
already satisfied. So let's just wait for
that to opt out. Oh, yeah, I cancelled it.
So let me close this up. And now we can just
create our project. So I'm in the directory
where I want to create my project. So I'm
just gonna say Django tyffyn admin, start
project. Let's name it Django chat. This is
it's Jango chat. And in this video, we're
not going to be using channels and readies
and the popular way of using a chat app, what
we're just going to be using is a little bit
of JavaScript, which is Ajax. So we're going
to be using Django and implementing Ajax to
make our chat functions real time. So you're
gonna see what we're gonna do in this video.
So right now, we can just go into that and
say, Django charts. So we are in this. And
then if we press dir, we can see right here
that there's money.py file, and we have this
folder. So let's just what I like to do is
to create my Django app immediately. So now
I can do Python manage dot view, our start
up our name, just name the app chart. So now,
this should create a new app named charts.
And we should have another folder right here,
named chart. So right here, you can see we
have a new folder. So we don't need this command
prompt again, let's come into VS code. And
then let's just open that up. So I'm gonna
open a folder. So the projects we just created,
I'm gonna bring it into VS code. So project
Shut up. I have it in here. And it is yeah,
this is it. So I'm going to say Select Folder,
so it should pop that up. And give me some
seconds. Okay, so that's done. Let me close
these anomalies. So now we have all these
right here. So the next thing that I want
to do, the first thing I like to do is to
just add my template file. So the template
file, when I say template file, I mean the
HTML files in which we're going to be using
in this project. So first of all, let me say
templates. So I need to create a new folder
in my root directory named template. And in
here, I'm going to bring in my template files.
So I have this template file designed already
in this video, we're not going to be doing
that from scratch. So if you want to get it,
as I said in the intro, I'm going to have
a link to the source code of this project
in the description below. So you can go there
and get the template file. So right here,
if I open this up, this is where I started
the template file. So I'm just gonna drag
and drop into VS code. So we have it right
there. Now the next thing we need to do is
to go to our settings, and just configure
the template and this add this chart to the
installed apps. So first of all, let's come
here. And then there's our charts. So that
is added to the installed apps schoolzilla
up and then we come down yet writing this,
I can just say pays the day when I see these
slush templates. So what this command line
is doing is that it is telling Django where
to look at our template file. So when we are
doing the URL mapping, which means when we
looked telling Django where all our URLs are
all the URLs of our project, and we want to
render an HTML page to show for a specific
URL, we need Django to know where to locate
that HTML file. So this line of code says
directory so I don't need to go to the base
directory. So the base directory shows the
root project right here. This is the base
directory. And in the base directory, Django
is going to enter into a folder named template.
As you can see, this is a template. So Django
cannot assess all this files inside this template
folder. So let's say we instead of naming
this template, let's say we name it something
like files, Oh, we don't need to do is to
come here and change it to files. But yeah,
we are using templates. So there is no specific
name you have to give this is just make sure
that this and this correlates. So yes, we
have that done. And then we can save. Now
I don't think we have any to do with settings
file, again, now we just need to do is to
set up our URLs. So we've come here, and then
we need to create a new file called urls.pi.
To now setup URL, we're just going to say
from Django dot URLs, impulse pass. So this
is gonna allow us to be able to configure
the paths. So now let me just say from the
input view, so we're gonna use this and I'm
going to explain why we're important this
second line in a minute. So now let's say
you are buttons equals two lists, the first
one, which is empty the root directory, we
used or let's say home, and then let's give
it a name. So now we have this. So we're important
these views, because we're saying that when
a user wants to go to the home directory,
it should go to the views dot home. So it's
going to go to views.py file, which is this
file right here. And again, to look for a
function name. So whatever we're doing it
functions, we're going to be happening to
this URL. So I just did a second like to import
views. So we can says any function we have
enough, which is right here. So right here,
we have to have a function named home. I'll
let you just take a simple requests. And then
there's return say return render. And then
requests for now want to request for home
dot html. So that's it, I'm gonna call me
on it. So the last thing we need to do for
this particular URL is comes in Django chat,
which is the main project folder, and inside
the URLs have to follow these ledges closes
up. So right here in path after importing
path, want to import include, and then I'm
gonna say was include charts dot URLs, and
we're gonna save. So now I'm going to pop
up a new terminal. And then I want to run
my Django projects just to make sure that
this URL configuration works successfully.
So let's give that a minute to set up. So
it's very easy to run a Django project to
actually try to follow up with this video.
I expect you to know at least some basics
of Django so you know what's going on around
here. But when in time I'm doing my tutorials
are like explaining everything I'm doing even
if you're not, you don't know anything about
Django so you know what's going on. But having
no basic knowledge of Django before watching
this will be helpful. So to run our Django
project, we're just gonna say Python managed.py
run server. So that's how easy it is to run
a Django project. So I'm just going to wait
for that to run on the local host which is
localhost Port 8000. So okay, right. Yeah,
it gives us an heiresses shrink add new objects.
Oh, so we're gonna come here so it's safe
on Nana it also cuz I guess it hasn't updated.
We think gives us that same error. Okay. Let's
see. views. That's boom. Here. It is not supposed
to be full stop supposed to be a coma. So
let's save that again on should be running.
Yeah, yeah, so dad's running on this. So if
I just Ctrl Click is gonna open these particular
URL on my default browser. So okay, they just
come here and open it up ourselves. So you're
just going to type in the localhost, which
is 12700 on port 8000. So that was open and
ready. And then we should see our HTML file.
Good. So as you can see, now we have Django
charts. And then we have the basic form, which
we're going to use in this project. So this
is the basic HTML file we're using. So a user
just gonna add to the room name, and then
his user name, and we'll be able to enter
a room. So let's head back to VS code and
continue with the coding. So now we can just
close this up. So let me just open a new terminal
down because we're gonna need it later. So
now that we have these, what I want to do
is to set up the model that we're going to
be using in this project. So I'm going to
set up two models, one is going to be for
the chatroom, and the second one is going
to be for the messages. So I'm going to come
into models.py file. So right you, all I just
need to do is to create a class, I'm going
to name it room and gather models dot model.
And the only thing I want this to average
is the room name. That's all Mojo's towards
Jakarta field, and unleaded max lens of 1000.
So that's what the room name. So I would have
given it another attribute of ID. But in Django,
each model objects as an ID generated one
if a new object is created. So like these
days, another attribute named ID Oh, don't
need to write that ourselves. So this is good
to go. And the second one want to create is
the message. So this is the module or the
database that is going to be storing all the
messages. So say models dot model. Right now,
I just gonna say value. Yeah, I think value
is a good name. So value is like the message
the user wants to send like a Oh, you're doing
what's up. So that value want to give it so
models dot character field, also, Max land,
so a message can have up to like a million
characters. And then let's give it a date.
So which date wasn't this. So before we can
use date, we need to import something named
date time. So from date, time, import date,
time. So we're gonna say models, dot date,
time field, not only date, view, date, time
field, and then what want to pass in year,
this is not going to have a maxlend. What
this is going to have is a default. So defaults
will be equals to date, time, dot now. And
then let's just set blank to be true. Just
copy this, paste. So the next thing we want
to have is the user. So which user is sending
this particular message that we want to use
a ledger give it a million user name shouldn't
be able to double it's just to avoid any errors
in this project. And then the last term I
want to add is the room. So want to know which
room is this projects been is this message
been sent to. So this room is going to be
like, we can use another Django model, like
a relationship model, like the many to many
of you the foreign key to link this with this
room. But we're not gonna be doing that in
this video. So this is also another way to
do this. So one was submitting a new message
is going to have the ID of the room, which
is going to add a link to this. So you're
gonna understand all these in a moment. So
let's just save this. And what we just need
to do is to migrate this to our database,
so say python manage.py. Make migrations.
And then after making the migrations, whether
it's gonna have to migrate, so that's done
by dawn manage.py. migrate. So, yes, we have
the migration done. Good. So it has been migrated
to our database. So now we can go into our
Django project and go to slash admin. But
before we can answer the admin panel, we need
to create a super user. So Python money creates
super user. So let's just avatars admin, leave
this blank. Give it a password. Let's bypass
good So now we have a supervisor created.
Let's close this up. So we need to register
these models in our admin file. So first of
all, we have to import the modules from those
models, imports grew an important message,
admin, dot site, dot register, register, boom.
And then there's also register message. Now
we'll save this. Now that come you go to slash
admin. Now he's gonna ask me to log in, let's
give it a second to load. Nice, he says I
should log in, let's gonna log in with the
details that I just created. And then, as
you can see, now it does take me to this admin
panel, and I have the messages and the rooms.
model, the Django model right here installed.
So coming to messages. For now, obviously,
we shouldn't have any object here. So what
if I want to add a new message, you're gonna
see that it has all the fields we need. So
let's just go back to the own. And then let's
open a new tab, go back to the home page and
leave this like this. So now we have all this.
Next, next thing that I think we need to do
now is to make sure that once a user put in
a particular room name, let's say the room
name is Django, just Django room and the user
is like, Tom. So what is the entire room,
it should take a user to another unique URL
for that particular Django for that particular
chatroom. So what we need to do is to first
of all, check if this room exists in our database.
So if, let's say Django, for example, is the
name of the room, I want to enter the room.
If it's a new room, that means if someone
has not created it before, we first of all
want to create this room, and then enter,
but there is a room that already exists, we
just want to enter the room and see all the
messages. So let's just take this off, and
let's go through that. So first of all, we
need to let me remove this, we don't need
this again. So right in our URLs, we need
to have a new path. So this path is gonna
be the path for the room, it's gonna be the
URLs for the room. So I'm just gonna say so
it's gonna be a dynamic one. So we'll say
strange, dudes name of Rome. And then we'll
say slash. So this is the Rwandan slash anything
want to add to it. So say views. dots room,
I'm gonna give it a name overall. So this
is good. And then let's come into views and
create a new one. I'll name it room associate
room request also, under just copy this, it
should also render the room dot html file.
So this is where the room dot html file is.
So it's rendering the room dot html file.
Very simple. And now, what we just want to
do, so this is not just taking a request.
First of all, as you can see, right here,
we're passing a variable into this particular
URL name room. So we need to come into views
and also collect. So now we have all this
collected. But if we come into home dot html,
so right here, scroll down, go down, down.
Right here, we have this form. So want to
send this form to an action that was a user
click on Submit. It's your first sent those
data to a view that we check if this particular
room as I said or not. So let's let's create
that view. So we need to create another URL,
actually. So let's name this check view. So
this is a view that is going to check for
what's going on. So Oh my God, why is that?
So let's just copy these views. The check
room is the name of check row, as Michelle
design, comma, and they're right here in our
views. Let's check room. Just think request.
For now, let's pass. Let's save these knowing
komiya and save these. So now we have this
URL. So if I go to slash anything is automatically
going to see that as a room. But what I want
to do now is to come into my own dot html.
So right here in my home that HTML, I want
to add some things to my form. So this is
going to be easy just to add where this data
is going and stuff like that. So first of
all, let's say the method it's using to send
this data is a POST method. And then the action,
where is it going, it's going to check for
you. So now we have the room name, the user
name. So in Django, we are using a POST method,
we must make sure that we have the CSRF token
CSRF underscore token. So you must make sure
that we have this obviously, now we have the
room name, and then the user name. So this
is good to go. So now we are sending these
with the room name and the user name to this
check for you. Now, right here in the check
view, before we do anything, we want to check
if that room name exists in our database.
So before we can do that, first of all need
to import that particular model so safe from,
we can see those models, or we can see from
chat those models anywhere you want to do
it is fine. From standard models import, we
want to import room, I want to import message.
So for now, we don't need message berlage
as important down because we're later going
to use it. So right here in the jag view,
what we just want to do is to say room, because
the requests dot posts. And then bescom yummy
shower. So does a name of room name. So we're
getting this name, room name. And then the
second one is the username, obviously. So
let's make sure user name correct. So a person
DS, and then what we just want to Jake was
gonna say if room dot objects dot future,
so our future needs file t name equals room.
Now want to check even this exists, then let's
do something. So what we're saying right here
is that if a room got object of future damage,
it's gonna check even if there is an object
in this room model, which has the name of
room, so the name of this room that the user
sent. And then if that exists, wants to do
something, what we just want to do is to redirect
the user to this to the room, which is a trim
function. Before guys redirect, we need to
import it. So import redirects. Good. So we
just say, return redirect, and we're redirecting
the user to slash room slash room dot name.
And we don't need to say that name, because
you already have that name. And we know it
exists. So we're redirecting the user to the
room. And then what want to pass also want
to pass the user name of the person that wants
to enter this room. So we know we send in
a message with entering and doing stuff like
that. So now, we can just say slash user name.
So right here, first of all, we should have
like, these user name should be equals to
unreligious. Add the user name. So that's
why we took tissues and so returning the user
now, to slash room slash user name, then equals
to user name. So this is good to do working
on then even doesn't exist. So if this is
a new room that the user is just creating,
but want to do is rather new. To have a new
variable, say new underscore room should now
be equals to room does object dot create.
So want to create a new one with the name
of room. So we're gonna get that room and
then create a new room with that particular
name. So now we just say new room built safe.
So now once we have this saved, we can redirect
the user to that page. Exactly the same thing
we did here. So I hope this you understood
what we did in this check view is pretty basic,
pretty simple stuff. Religious safety safeties,
and good test it out. So right here, does
it refresh. Let's go to our rooms, he will
see that we have no room to let our new room
unless you say something like, let's give
it programming. They just say programming.
coders. Okay, good. And then they say, Tom.
So now let's create a room. Now you can see
everything is working perfectly. It takes
us to this particular URL named coders. So
this is our app slash go does then user name
equals to. So we are the name of the room,
and then the user name, so the user that entered
the show, and then when we come here and eat
refresh, we can see that our room has been
created successfully room coders. So that
is good. And then don't mind this message
or see now that's just the basic template
that we brought in earlier. So this is what
we're going to change this to be real time
message, and oh, or deciduous, or demo. And
they are going to change this to the room
name, obviously. So I think we have these,
and then let's check. So let's go back, and
then try to enter this cooler room again.
So now let's make sure that he doesn't create
another room with that same name of CUDA.
But he just takes us into that room. So let's
enter with another user, this time I could
change. So he brings us to that same room,
but with a different user this time around.
So once we hit refresh, we see that we don't
have a new object created, it just takes us
into this existing one. So that's what we
did in our check view. So that is pretty good
right now. And then, since we have these,
or we can just do is to come into room dot
html. So right here, this is where we need
to do some work. Next, I can just close that
up. So instead of having name, okay, let's
see, right here. Okay, good. So now we have
all this grated, the next thing we just want
to do, first of all, we're going to remove
this. And then once a user input a message,
and it's sent, we want the message to be stored
in the database with the details of this room
and the user. So you're going to see what
we're gonna do. So right here, now, what we
just need to do is to first of all, come into
room dot html. So right here in this form,
we need to create some things which are going
to allow us to submit that obviously, so in
the form, we're going to listen, the form,
right should be down below, discloses. disclose
DSL. So this is the form here. So now in this
form, let's just have some things like CSRF
token, as I always have CSRF underscore token
to this, just to make sure that whenever we
use a POST method, everything works. So you
can see now that I put a CSRF token by I didn't
do something like method posts. So that's
because we're going to be using Ajax to submit
this form. So if I come here, normally, and
then I type in a message and it's sent, that
page is gonna reload. And that's, that's what
we don't want in our chat. So we want you
to be real time, want everything to happen.
Without this page, even thinking of refreshing.
So once we hit something is gonna send I was
it sent without page refreshing is gonna be
created in our message database. And then
later on, we're also going to make it show
you automatically in real time, without any
page refreshing. So this is where Ajax comes
in. So Ajax is a very cool feature. I have
a ton of tutorial on Ajax on my channel. So
it allows you to do things like get database
in real time, asynchronously, some cool stuffs
that you can play around with Django. So this
Ajax is not with Python is actually with JavaScript.
So we're gonna be using some basic JavaScript.
Now, to use Ajax. We just need to make sure
is that You have this script loaded in your
template file. So this particular line, let
me just scroll across so you guys can see
the lines. That's it. So once you have that
imported, you are good to go. So first of
all, right here, you can see that we have
this form. So we want to click Send. So you
right here, you see we have 1234 inputs. But
yeah, we only have two inputs shown. So if
you see the type of this is eating, and the
type of this is also eating, so we don't want
the user to write anything new, we're gonna
automatically give it a value ourselves. So
the user name is the current user that logged
in. And then the room ID is the ID of this
room the user is in. So before we can continue,
we need to come into our views, get these
two details, after getting details, we pass
it back here, and then implement it in our
form. So let's do that quickly. So now right
in our room, we just need to say user name,
first of all, so how are we going to get this
username, you can see no bad, bad, bad, bad,
bad, bad. So user name should be because now
let's just go back and listen to a storm.
Okay, good. So make sure our URLs is working.
So you can see now our URLs, we have the name
of the room, and we have the name of the user.
So since we have it in this URL of this view,
we can just get back this details. So let's
say user name should be equals to. So I'm
going to request for its request that gets
that gets, Shall we do it. And then we'll
say username. So it's stored in a variable
of username, as you can see. So now, in this
scenario, we're going to get the value of
Tom, if this is theme are going to get a team
with this area we're going to get. And the
next thing we want to get is the room details.
So you can see that we have this room. So
this code does is what is being passed here
in this room, we have that read. So I was
gonna say since we have the name of that room,
we're gonna use this name to assess the database.
So we're gonna see room on discord details.
And then we'll say it goes to room objects
dot get name equals from. So what this is
doing is that we have a new variable, obviously.
And then from this room model right here,
dot object dot get is getting the particular
model which has the name of this room. So
we have the name of coders in this case. Now
that we have all those details that we need,
all I just want to do now is to pass it into
our HTML. So right here, let's make sure we
get that. First of all, we put a comma. And
we have these. And then let's pass the user
name. Copy this past a user name. And then
one of us the room details also. So first
of all, what a buzzer room. Actually, if we
have the room details, we need to pass the
room. But let's just do that. Let's copy and
paste. So now we have all this sent to our
HTML. Now in our HTML, we should be able to
access all this easily. So let's save this
file. And right here in rooms. First of all,
let me scroll all the way up. So instead of
room name, now that I have the name of the
room, I can just do room. So this room is
actually DCE. Okay, this shouldn't be days.
Good. Save that again. So we have this room.
So let's first see that change and make sure
everything is working. So instead of one name,
we should have queued us. So right here now
you can see we have queued us. Good. Now we're
going to scroll down back to the form right
here. So the value of the user name is the
current user, we should just have these. And
then the room ID should have real details
that Id like this. So I get in this room details
that was sent here. So as you can see, remember
that the different details of the particular
room from the model. So what we're just doing
here is getting that particular model and
getting this ID remind the beginning I said
once you have a new object, the object automatically
On ad, so I get in that ID. So now that we
have all of these issued, why we should be
good to go with using our Ajax. So just use
Ajax, I'm actually gonna just open a new script,
right here down below the body, as given here.
So to save time, I'm just gonna paste in this
code. So what this code does, you can see
just a piece of JavaScript. So let me explain
each line by line. So this is document. So
what this is doing is that once we load this
document form, we're saying that that also
meets of this post form. So what we're saying
is immediately a user clicks on the submit
button of this post form. So this is this
Submit button of the post form. So what do
we want to do, we want to have a function.
And we give this a value. So we'll say e dot
prevent default. So what this prevent default
does is that normally in a form, once we'd
submit the page is going to refresh or go
to another page. So this prevent default is
going to prevent that from reloading or going
to another page. So now we know that the page
isn't going to reload. Now we're going to
use our Ajax to send that details to our database.
So what we're doing now is that we're saying
Ajax, and then we're saying the type is posts
normally weren't using Ajax, we know, well,
we're gonna use something like method. But
since we're using Ajax, we don't need that.
So already assessing the type post, and the
URL is sending it to send, I'm going to explain
this URL in a bit. And then the data is just
basically what the data user name with the
image tag of username, room ID, and then the
message. So as you can see, everything is
user name, mighty message. That's just what
we are sending. And then the CSRF token, this
is how we implement the CSRF token right here.
So the success function, we can just say something
like message sent. So I just commented this
out was let me leave that like that. And then,
yeah, let's just leave this like this. So
what this is, what this is doing is that the
sources function damage if the message or
some debt to database, we're going to create
a particular message. So this is going to
be accessed from the views.pi function. Going
to go back to that. And then this so what
this is doing is that once a user it on sent
and it has been saved in the database, we
want to delete these once we delete that particular
line from the input. So what I mean is that,
let's say user type something right here.
And then these are it's sent. So once that
has been saved, we want to clear this particular
input to now be blank, just like the way you
see normal chat services. So right here, it
gets this, this shouldn't be good. What we
just want to do is to have a new URL, and
we're gonna name this URL sent. So as you
can see, it's sending all this data to a URL
name sent. So first of all, let's save this
up, and come up with a new one, say sent.
And then we based and then we based so we
have a new URL name sent, then wants to create
a new function for it. So just the way we
did something like this check view, remember,
so this check view first checked, if that
room is available, or not available, then
before it did whatever it wants to do. So
we're gonna do something similar in the st.
So we're just going to do, we're going to
assess the st. So let's scroll down a new
function sent requests. So these are just
basic functions. And then, right here, you
can see we're sending all this data to this
st. URL, so let's just access them. So we're
just gonna say the message should be equals
to. So why isn't a Post's method from the
front end associated with quest those posts
and then it's same message. So I like cross
checking to avoid any arrows. So here is an
a variable message their room ID, then use
a name. So those are the three we need. So
Nope. gamier based based, and then this should
be the user name. And then this should be
the room underscore ID. So now copy that.
just pasted the essence of the same thing.
So we have all these done. So now that this
view as all this data, which to us are kind
of inputted, or we just want to do is to store
that data in this message database, we'll
let that quickly load. Okay, I know why this
error is coming up, just because we didn't
save some changes yet. But let's keep going.
So you know, we have this modules, which is
message, so want to save all those into this
module. So now, since we imported the message
module up here, remember I said we're going
to later use it, so we have that imported,
we don't need to import it again. So we can
just say, new message. No new message, we're
gonna say message is no just message actually,
message does objects. Not slash Wait a dots,
objects dot create. So I created a new object
right? Now the value, remember we used value
shouldn't be the message which we collected.
And then the user, remember which user should
be the user name, which was collected, and
then the room. So what we want to store is
the room ID. So room should be equals to the
room ID. So now that we have this, all we
can just do just say new message that safe,
so we just do new message that safe. So we
have that saved visuals, return. Now, we are
not rendering any HTML page, we just want
to return back to the front end or to the
JavaScript the message. So we're gonna give
it an HTTP response. But before we can do
that, first of all have to import each year.
So we'll say from Django dot HTTP, import,
HTTP response. Good. So now we can see return
an HTTP response. We can say message sent
successfully. Good. So now we have this. So
this HTTP response, this is how I just saved
the file. And this is our gonna, so this data,
remember I said on success dummies, if everything
works perfectly, we're going to function with
this value of data, and then want to alert
data. So this data is this HTTP response.
So when we alert, it's just gonna say message
sent successfully. Now, we did pretty good.
So let's go check out what we do. Now, this
should be working. Good. And then in messages,
you can see we have zero message. So now let
me just type Okay, first of all, I got to
refresh this page. refresh, refresh. Good.
So now, let me just type a message like, Hey,
guys, and I sent you can see it says message
sent successfully. Obviously, later in the
tutorial, we're gonna remove this or just
using this for confirmation. And then once
I hit send, you see that the message doesn't
show year again, which should be not as come
on it's refresh. I think now that we have
a new message, so it says a guy's value. And
it comes from the user term, which we see
here. And then the room with the ID of one.
So the room with the ID of one is obviously
this restroom. So if it's another room is
going to tell us the room with the ID of two.
Let's cross check. No, that was awesome. So
I say okay, let's go to the home page. Now
I want to create another room and say, back
end developers. And now told me is going to
be here. Now let's create the room. Now let
me see a developer's an IDE sent the message
and successfully the message displays is cleared.
Now we come here to messages, we have two
messages now, a developer's we got the date
and the time, and it's coming from the user
to me and the room ID is true. So if you've
gone to rooms, you see we have a new room
greeted with the idea of a back end developer.
So we can use this to assess the messages
for each room later. So this is working pretty
fine. We what we've done to this point is
that a user can create a new room, enter that
room, so it's gonna be on a dynamic URL, and
then the user can send a message and that
message will be saved in the database. So
in the next This video, what we just need
to do is to make sure that all once the user
enters a room, all the messages of that room,
first of all show will load like normal charts.
And then once a user submits a message I need
to send is automatically going to show right
here. And then not just only for the user
for also another user anywhere, the person
is also going to test that with an incognito
mode. So I hope you guys enjoyed this tutorial
to this point, I really had fun building this.
If you do not forget to smash the like button
and subscribe. Hey, guys, welcome to the second
part of this Django tutorial. So this is the
second and final parts in this chat app with
Django. So in the last video, we stopped at
saving all the values into database. So we
add two models, which were let me quickly
come your messages and room. So this room
is gonna create a new room, whenever a user
wants to create a new room, and then this
message is gonna store the messages. So this
message is like the database for storing all
the message. So as you can see, we have the
value of the message a developers, we have
the date and the time, we have the user which
submitted our message, and we have the room.
So as saying the room with the ID of two.
So we didn't watch the last video, you should
definitely watch that before these. So what
we just need to do now since we have all the
data is stored, I think we don't have too
much of work to do, we just need to get all
the data and showcase it to you. But we are
we need to do a little bit of extra work is
to make sure that this data showcase in real
time. So if a user from another mobile phone
or from another place in the world, texts
have also sent a message, we want to see it
right here in real time without even refreshing
this page. So we're using Ajax for this last
video, we use Ajax so that when a user submits,
so if I come here and say I testing. And then
I see that I click sent, it says message sent
successfully, this page didn't refresh, and
then it was cleared from you. Welcome to messages,
you're going to see that I have a new message,
I tested the date and time user and the room
ID. So now we use Ajax to do that. Now we
want to use Ajax also, again, to load these
messages data in real time. Let's get right
with that. So right here, we just need to
add a new URL. So if we are just using normal
Django to just load the messages, you know,
we're just gonna come into the views, we have
a new function, or we don't even need a new
function, which is going to come to the room,
and then we'll just specify the message and
send it to the HTML file, and then just showcase
it. But if we do that, once the user updates
or create a new message is not going to be
updated in real time. So we need to make that
real time. Let's go into URLs, we need to
have a new view for getting all the messages.
And this URL is going to be dynamic. So since
y is in a dynamic URL list, copyright is past
this. So this is slush gets messages. So if
you can read these, this is saying that gets
messages slash a particular room that you
want to get the message. So we're gonna have
the room name. So if the room name is called
us, like right in your digital name of Jesus,
but develop back end developers. So we're
going to be like get messages slash back end
developers, they will say views that get messages
and the room gets messages. So this is good.
And then it is going to come into our views.py
file, create a new function, gets messages
should take a request. And it should also
take for now, let's pass. So now let's save
this. So now this is working fine. Now, what
we just want you to do is to come here, and
then want to get all the messages of that
particular room the user is in. So now that
we know we have the room name, so we can use
this room name to get all the messages of
that room. Now, when we get this message of
this room, then we're gonna return a JSON
response of all the messages. Then from our
front end, we're gonna use Ajax JavaScript
to assess that JSON response and showcase
it to our user. Now, first of all, we need
to make sure that we are importing JSON response
so that we can use that so right here in HTTP,
we can say JSON response. So right here, now
we're no longer gonna pass. We're just gonna
do that to save room details. So this is a
new variable. So was this in the room model
objects that get on then what gets in the
room, which has a name of this room right
here. So now that we know we have that room
that we're looking for, let's get to the messages
associated with our room. So let's say messages.
Good, should we get calls to message so this
message, Moodle does object dot future. And
they want to filter with the room, underscore
underscore eight continues, don't worry, I'm
going to explain this. If you don't understand
it here. It's room details.id. So what this
line of code is doing, now, let me go back
to what we did in the first tutorial. So right
here, a module created a new model name message.
Now this message, what is is just the model
that's going to be storing all the messages
on this platform or the messages. And then
we add four attributes, the value of that
message data, that message was sent to the
user. And now what we are specific about is
the room. So this is what I want to talk about
this room, is which room was this message
being sent from? Like, which room does this
message belong to? Exactly, that's the word.
So this room is just specifying the room ID
of the message that this that this message
belongs to. So now that we know that room
ID, we cannot get all the messages. Now ever
come back here into views. We're saying message
those objects, the filter. So now we want
to filter with all the list of the data we
have here. With the room ID that's a contains
the room details.id. Now, I don't think we
should even say contains I think we're supposed
to say with a room that equals to room details
or ID. Now this is that more futuring without
the messages with the one in which the room
is this room details.id. Now, let's just return
in JSON response, return JSON response. And
then let's return it's the middle variable
of message messages, actually, let's say you
should be fine, then, at least obviously,
we need to say that at least I will say messages,
values like this. So this is returning a JSON
response. And is returning it as a variable
of messages. So this is what we're going to
be using to assess it. And then we're done
does a list of messages, which is this messages
of value. So we're getting all the values
from you. That's very good. Now we have this
done. Now what we just need to do is to come
into our room, dot html. So right here, this
was the AJAX function we used in the beginning
for submitting the message. So for now, let's
just comment that out. And I think we can
close this up. So right here, should be good
to have another script. So right here, we're
gonna have another scripts. Let's just have
it right here. Good. So let's create a new
script. So in your I'm going to paste a particular
JavaScript code. So what this code is doing,
I'm going to explain how this code line by
line. So this is saying that once we load
this document, which is this page, then want
to want to do everything in this function.
So this is set a set interval, what does that
data What does is that anything inside these
brackets are the function is going to be done
again, and again, and again, with this particular
amount of time, which is one seconds. So this
means that all these Ajax function and getting
all the requests, everything is going to be
done every second. That's why we can assess
the data in real time. So once an update is
made the next second, we have that data updated
already. So now we are now using the AJAX
we're saying get So this time I like getting
a particular data from the URL gets messages
slash room. So you remember when we did it
right Where's that right here gets messy slash.
So now we are giving you the room. Where is
the room? In our views, remember that in the
room view right here, we sent in room. So
this room is the name of this particular room.
So I think, yes, maybe this last particular
name of the room. And then if we've got everything
successful, and then so what we have right
here, when we are getting, we're getting this
JSON response, right here. So this is what
we're getting you, then if it was successful,
you can do console dot log response, we're
going to show the response in girls, which
is that particular data. So I commented that
out, because we don't need it, but we just
want to do is to show it in our UI. And then
I said, display dot empty. So what this is,
is, so if I come here, you'll see that I have
a new div tag with an ID of display. So first
of all, I made sure that this is empty, I
removed everything there. Metallic gonna remove
all things I just commented out. So I removed
everything in there. And then I looped through,
so I say for varkey, in response those messages,
so for each value in this response, and this
response, which includes was JSON, it was
saying dot messages, as you can see is this
messages of everything we get here. So as
seen for very key in response messages. Now,
what are the new variable over just named
it temp? Just put that, and then now you can
see that we have this particular is it div
tag in here. So this is the div tag we use
in here. So we just specified a new JavaScript
variable with the HTML tag. So is that the
same thing? So it's div class, container Doc,
everything. But now in you can see that we
just added dummy messages. Hello, everyone.
How are you guys doing? But right here does
know what's out there. Again, right here.
What is the IDS response? messages key dot
user. So this first of all, is the user name
of the person that sent the message. And this
is the value of the message, which is like
a whatsoever, guys, and this is the date.
So now we have this in an HTML tag, while
I was gonna append it to the div tag that
has this hashtag display ID. So now this is
empty, then we're gonna append whatever we
get into this div tag. So after having that
done, I would just add an arrow. So if anything
happened, if we add an arrow, we just say
an error occurred. So this should totally
work. Now let's save this up. So if I come
here, so back end developers? Yeah, let me
refresh. Okay, so as you can see, now I have
two messages. So if I go into my Chrome, there's
no Chrome, this is Microsoft Edge Internet
Explorer or something like that. So if I come
into my dev tools, and I come into console,
now let me is refresh again. Okay, normally,
I'm supposed to see all the data I'm getting
in real time right here, where I guess, not
Chrome. But you can see in this HTML is occasionally
changing every one second. So let me show
you what is going to happen right now. So
if I send something like WhatsApp people,
and I say sent. So automatically, you see
that that we have that message here in the
HTML, you see that is North Korea detailed
in our code, but that's what that JavaScript
code is doing. So this is supposed to show
everything, I guess, because I'm not using
Chrome. I don't know why. But yeah, we can
skip that, obviously. And then, let's see.
Let's see. Let's see. Okay, good. So these
were we're looking for network, not console.
Sorry for that. So you can see that this is
getting some data every one second. So it's
updating. Updating, actually, this is not
even what I'm looking forward to. Okay, I
guess. So in caso were supposed to have, oh,
yeah, I know why the problem is, so right
here in our sources function. We didn't we
I remember, I commented it out. So let's save
this again. Is it refresh? So now you can
see, I have this message without reloading.
So three messages for this particular room,
a developer, I was a pastor. So you can see
now that we have three Good, let me have a
new one like a, and then just hit enter. Now
you can see we have four in real time is updating.
So let me show you what is cool about this.
I'm going to open a new incognito mode. So
in private window, I don't even think I've
opened this in his browser before. So I'm
just gonna add that there. Is these? Yeah.
Okay, good. So where is that? We have you?
Yeah. Good. So now, let me just assess. Well,
in back end developers, so let's enter this
same room, or space states for now? We are
I think we are Yeah. As to me. Now. Let's
enter as john. And ls it enter room? Now you
see that it loads all the messages of this
room? Now, let me say he told me are you doing?
automatically, you see, it shows you and it
shows in my own side also. So it's real time.
So if someone is in another part of the world,
it's gonna work. So let's say we post this
online. And then we have two people connected
in different places, once a user sends a message
here is going to show right here in my own
platform a real time, as long as I'm connected
to the internet. So it's a pretty good feature,
actually. So let's make sure we got no errors.
And in this test is a game. So let's just
go to the home page. And then on the beach.
So now let me create a new room. So let me
say, let me just say, code, let me just name
it code. And now let me enter as broad, something
like this. Now, interdivisional, you can see
now that there are no messages, actually,
I can put something like, if there are no
messages, I should say, no messages in the
room or be the first sentiments of the like
that. We don't need that for now. So code.
And then let's say that she's another name,
Jessie. And now we need to enter. So now we
have these two blank rooms, to now say, a
who's online. I'm 18. And you see, it's automatically
shows here without any delay. And I can see
I am. And it shows here. So this is very,
very good. So I might post this online, maybe
when I'm done with recording this tutorial.
And if I do, I'm going to leave a link to
the description, the description. So if you
want to chat with me there you can. And I
guess we're pretty much done with this video
is something's right here. Okay. How's Gooding
going? Yeah, good. Good. Yes, of testing this.
So yeah, this is very good. I love what we
built in this video. With you guys love what
we build. And you lie you like watching this
video. And if you watch this video to this
particular point, I appreciate you because
not everyone watches to the end. In this tutorial,
we're gonna be talking about the Django rest
framework. So the Django rest framework is
a library, which allows you to Butte API's
in your Django project. So let's say you have
a Django project, or you want to build an
API so that others can access your data, or
you're just trying it for fun, or just want
to build your skills, that Django rest framework
is the best way to go. It allows you to easily
build API's with a lot less code. So this
is this, the rest framework is very, very
easy to set up. And I'm going to walk you
through everything in this tutorial. So we're
gonna start from the scratch, we're gonna,
first of all, install Django, and then we're
gonna start a new Django project, then we're
gonna install the rest framework, and then
I'll show you how to integrate the rest framework
into that Django project. So without wasting
any time, let's get straight into it. So right
here, I have my command prompt, and I already
have it in this directory where I want to
create my Django project. I want to first
make sure that I have Django installed. So
just pip install Django. This command line
is for installing Django using Python package
manager code Pip. Like also install Django
in some other ways, like easy install or just
with GitHub code directly, but this is the
best way to go. So I already have Django installed.
So it should be telling me requirement already
satisfied. So we should give that a minute,
it should bring that up. Now we already have
Django installed right here. So it's taking
longer than usual. And then I can just get
out of that. Let me just close by I have Django
installed before, you should go ahead and
install it. So now let's start the new Django
project using the Django admin start project.
And the let's say, the RF, which stands for
Django rest framework approach. So Django
rest framework project, to that command line
is gonna start a new application or a new
Django project in this directory. So this
is a directory right here. So you can see
now that it is empty for now. And boom, you
see that we have a new project that has been
started. So let's come back. Yes. So now that
we know we have a new project started, let's
just CD into that project. First of all, so
we see we have a Django project and CD into
it. So as close that up by press di R, now
I can see that I have money, just Pew II and
di F. So this is my standard Django project.
Now the next thing I want to do is to install
the Django rest framework. Before I install
Django rest framework, let me bring this Django
project into VS code. So let's open up VS
code, close this up. And then in fall, that's
going to come to open folder. And then it
should take me to the folder which should
take me to the file manager. So I can go into
that folder I think is to F toots, then Chang,
ti F. So this is the folder. And then once
I select that folder, obviously VS code is
going to open that up. So as VS code is doing
its magic, let's go back to the command prompt.
And then what we just want to do now is to
install the Django rest framework. So let's
say Pip, install Django rest framework. So
this is how easy it is to install the Django
rest framework, just a simple PIP command.
So this command line is going to install the
Django rest framework on our computer. So
again, I already have the Django rest framework
installed, so it should tell me requirement
already satisfied. But for you, it should
go I understood that if you don't have that
installed, so let's come back into VS code
as that is installing. And then let's just
make everything clean here. So we can quit
this. So we can see that this is a Django
project. So for this project, we are not going
to create a Django app, at least for now.
So later, we're gonna create an app where
we're gonna use serializers and stuff like
that. But for now, we're just gonna stick
with just the Django project and the URLs
of UI file in it. So that's where we're gonna
put our views.pi. And everything we're going
to be using. So let's come back to the command
prompt. As you can see, it says requirement
already satisfied. This means that I already
have the rest framework installed. So now
that I know I have the rest framework installed,
I can use the library in other module in our
project. So now, what I just want to do is
to create a new file First of all, and then
they rename it views.py. So in this views.py
file does where I'm going to code just like
a normal Django project. First of all, let
me import render, say from Django dot shortcuts.
So from Django shortcuts is the command line.
Not command nine actually is the module. So
the shortcode is like a class, I think like
a function in the Django library, in which
you can input some things. So we import render.
And now, that's just for rendering a Normal
template for, but I want to use the API view
from the rest framework. So the rest framework
provides us with an API view class or function,
or whatever it is. So with that API view,
we're going to be able to access a lot of
type of API's that is available in the Django
rest framework. So when we use the API view
we can do we can use something like a get
request or port request. And some other things
that are being rendered or are being given
to us by the rest framework. So first of all,
say from rest underscore framework. And they
want to know the views, then we'll import
API view. So I put in the API view from the
rest of the among those views. And then, as
I said, this API view is gonna allow us to
create a function or a class on it, so that
we can be able to use all the everything available
in his API view. But we'll also is an API
view, we want to obviously send a response.
Now, for example, let's say someone, another
developer tries to access our API, once it
sends a request to our API, we'll want to
give the developer a response want to give
him some sort of results. So let's say user
send a get request just to get a list of a
query set or something, or at least over data,
want to give the user back a response or data
data? So first, give a response, we're gonna
have two inputs, response from the rest framework
associate from rest framework, import dot
response, first of all, import response. So
what this is doing is just same from rest
framework that, Oh, nope, this is wrong. from
rest framework dot response, you just want
to import response. So that's it. Now that
we have these everything imported, we can
now create a class to inherit from this API
view, so that we can get a lot of methods
that we can work with. So let's just have
a new class. And let's name it something like
let's say, test view. And then API view. So
this was naming this, this view. And then
this, this view is inheriting from the API
view, which is right here. So what we can
do know in that order this class, we want
to have a get function, which is just gonna
be like a get request to this API. So said,
Jeff gets, and then roughly says, self request.
Alright, last arguments, and then keyword
access keyword arguments, keyword x, just
like this. So now that we have these functions,
what we just want to specify is a data. So
this is a test view. And then in this test,
we have a get request. So we want to like
average data in which we're going to send
back to the user or just give us a result.
So same data. For now, let's just hard code
our data ourself. Later, I'm going to show
you how to use the jungle model so that this
data will be like from the database you have
or something. But for now, let's just have
a simple dictionary that we're going to send
back. So let's just have a dictionary saying
something like user name. Let me just see
admin. And then number of years, I select
number of years, lots of the user has been
active. And then we can give it something
like 10 years. So that's actually a good user.
So this is just the data, the user name is
admin, and he has been active for 10 years,
let's just make demo specific number of years
active. Remote these, we don't need that.
So we'll just use active to last 10 years.
So now we have this data that is in a dictionary
format. So this is a data I want to send back
as a response. So by just going to do is to
say return response of data. So what we just
did was that we use this response in which
we imported from restaurant the response.
And then we're returning a response of this
particular data. So now we have this done.
What we want to do now is I want to go set
a URL for this so that we can actually test
this when we run it on our localhost. So now
let's come into URLs spy, right here. I just
wanna Remove all this needed. And then in
year, first of all, let me have a new path,
which is going to be empty. Now this empty
path shows the own URL. So like when you just
go to your website, let's say like google.com,
boom URL is that empty path. So that's that.
Now, what we can just do is to first of all,
import that test view from the views. Let's
import this video. So now that we have this
view imported, we can easily use it in here.
So this is the UI. And then we can just say
test view. Since it's a class based view,
we have to add.as view. Now the reason why
we're adding this.ru is because the view in
which we're using is a class based view. If
you're using a function based view, you don't
need to do that you can just say, test view
year as the view. But since y is in a class
based view, we must do this even though it's
going to give us an error, and Django is not
going to recognize that other valid few. So
test view.as view. And the ledger gives you
like a name of something like test. So now
we have all this set up, we have it linking
to the own URL using the test view.as view.
And we'll give it a name of test. Now, I want
us to just run our server and test it immediately.
But if we do that, while I'm gonna see nothing,
we might even get an error. And it is why
am I getting an error is because right here,
what we did was we installed the Django rest
framework. Immediately, we just came to start
importing everything in our project. But you
know, if you work with Django for a while,
you know, you actually need to do some second
configurations, to be able to use some particular
type of libraries, not all. So for this Django
rest framework, we need to add some things
to our settings. Now let's come into settings.py
file. First of all, the first thing we need
to add is in our installed apps, we need to
add where we rest framework, surprisingly,
so right here, we need to add rest framework
in our installed app. So Django is going to
recognize it. Now after adding that as well
to do with the settings, what we just want
to do is under the URLs, we need to add one
URL in which the restroom Oh, my goodness.
So first of all, we need to import include.
After that, we can just pass API. I think
for both of them, we're just gonna do like
a comma, and give you this a slash. And then
we're just gonna include from the rest framework,
dot URLs. So that is duffel, dat, and we'll
give it a comma. And then we can see. So now,
we can easily come to a command prompt, and
just the Python managers Pew II run server.
So now when we run this server, we can come
right here. And then if we go to the Oh, actually
what I'm going to use this for now, we just
have to set that Oh, because the Django rest
framework requires that. So when we go to
the UI, it should give us this test view.
And this test, you should just be docking
get to just like either sending a get request.
And then we're just gonna give it a response
or this particular data. So let's save this
also. And let's come back and see what's going
on. So this should start running in a second.
Because we felt that normally, Django doesn't
take time to run by guest causes a new project,
and we're running for the first time. So let's
just give me a minute. Okay, so we have that
done. And then let's come back to a browser.
Let's open a new tab. In the new tab. Let's
go into our local hosts with the port of 1000.
Because that's Django default URL, something
like that. So give me the time to load. Okay,
I can see the title loading already. Let's
give it a few seconds and Yeah, good. So this
is what we see. Now, you know, We didn't design
or this page or this fancy UI that we're seeing,
we didn't design. That's what comes with the
Django rest framework, it actually gives you
this nice looking template to showcase your
API and basically test all your API's. Now,
as you can see, is giving us in a dictionary
right here is giving us user name, admin ESR,
tF 10. And that is exactly the same thing
we are writing in data. So normally, the API
uses it gives us a response in JSON format,
that was given us a response in dictionary
format, because those words, we actually set
up right here. Normally, it shouldn't be a
JSON format. So we're dealing with real data,
real models, you're gonna see what I'm talking
about. So as you can see, choosing the GET
requests, and then the HTTP two addresses,
okay, so because it's allowing and get requests,
because we specified the get function, right
here. Let me remove this safe. Because we
specify the get function right here. If we
specify the post function, we're also going
to talk about that soon. It's gonna show right
here that we allow in a POST request. So that
is basically the basics about this Django
rest framework. So if I come here, and then
I, it's Jason, you're gonna see now like,
gives me this in JSON format. So right here,
he just gives me a blank JSON format, no template,
nothing, just a blank JSON formatted as if
I go to this URL. But normally, we just get
the homepage, this is what it shows us. So
this is good. And I hope you're starting to
have a grasp of where the Django rest framework
is above. Now, to be honest, it gets more
complex than this layer, I'm going to walk
you through every single thing you need to
know to get started, and I'm going to simplify
every single thing. So let's just come back
to the rest framework page. And if we scroll
down, right here, in installation, you see
the exactly what is doing here is what we
have done in our project. So you can see it
says install using Pip, including any optional
packages you want. So this is where we install
the Django rest framework. We can also install
markdown on the Django filter, but we don't
need that for now. Because they are optional
packages. So you just saw the Django rest
framework, what is mandatory, or you could
just clone the project from GitHub. Oh, I
see that as stressful, you know. So I just
prefer using Pip. So what we just did was
to address remote, so I installed apps right
when we did it in the settings. And then we
added this URL pattern that I said, the rest
framework requires. So we've done all that
we've gone gone through the installation,
we've come Yeah, we've seen the results of
the API's. And then let's move straight into
Django rest framework serializers. Now let's
talk about serializers in the Django rest
framework. So serializers is a structure of
representation that represents a data, we
want to return in a JSON format, or are saved
in a JSON format. So we can use this realize
that to like transform our Django models into
JSON, let's first create a new app, and our
Django project, and then we're going to do
deeper into serializers. So right here, in
where we start, in my command prompt, I'm
just going to opt out of this server that
is already running. And then I'm gonna create
a new Python, a new Django app for the smart
project. And we're gonna name it, whatever
I want to name it, maybe my app or DRF app
or something. So first of all, is of total
t so t should pick gun within a second. And
then yeah, okay. So, okay, well, that was
a lot of press. So now we can just do Python
manager spqr start verse a DRF. So this is
gonna start a new jungle up in our project.
So when this is started, was gonna go ahead
and continue with it. So, first of all, after
this is started, we're gonna go into our modules
and create a module that we're actually gonna
play around with. So let's just switch we'll
just do that. And that should be done. Within
a second, give you a moment to do and see.
Doesn't take time. So as that is doing, let
me talk more about serializers. Actually,
I wanted to explain more about serializers.
Because we are getting started with the restaurant
mock jelly takes a bit of a while to understand
what these things actually do. So the serializer
is a big about the lack of form, like a modal
form. Once you have modal, the way you create
a form for modal, so you can submit in Django,
so you can submit a form, or update or whatever
you want to do. Think of that as a serializer.
So serialize, I just basically the same thing,
you have a model, then you have a serializer
that you link that model to and then you specify
the fields you want to be you want to be in
that particular serializer and enjoy GTO views.
So that was the theoretical part. Now let's
dive into protocols. So right here, we can
see that DRF has been created successfully.
Good. Let's remove that. So let's come back
in now, we have to create a new file and name
it serializers dot p y. Now this serializers
dot p y is the file where we're gonna configure
our serialization. For now we're gonna leave
this blank. Now, as I said, we're gonna create
a new module that we're going to use. So let's
come into module.pi. So writing a module does
pure let's just create a new module. I want
to name this module like country. I change
my mind on me students are learning from the
models. That's Moodle. So let's give it some
fears. And Alyssa, the name of the student,
that would be muddles towards Sheffield, under
character feud should ever maxlend. Let's
just say 100. Let's give it another one like
age. That's moodle.in teacher fuge. I don't
think that takes any attribute. Let's give
like a description of the student who deals
does, it should be a text field. And that
doesn't have any attributes, or let's say
date a route. And that should be a date time
field. So they'll be models dot date, time
field, let's say auto now should just be equals
to true. So I think we have these. Yeah, I'm
happy with these. And so let's just give it
a string. Yep. And then as do the self on
alleges average return, self name. So
now we have this particular module. Now, you
know, normally in Django, when you create
a new module, or you make any changes to the
modules file, we need to migrate it into our
database. So we're gonna do that right now.
But before we do that, I want us to, first
of all register this up in our installed apps.
So coming to sentence under right here, what
we're just going to do is to say if that's
the name of the app we created, so let's save
that. So now that we have that saved, what
we can just do is to come into our command
prompt. And then let's just migrate associate
Python managed. py make migrations. So we'll
give that a second to make the migrations
it might see no changes detectors. So I just
like making sure I make migrations and migrate.
So I don't get any errors because sometimes,
Django might be funny. So that should be doing
okay. Yes. So, as you can see, it says creates
models to dent biologists guide and migrate.
So as you can see right here, when we said
money, those people I make migrations But
what he did was just to make some migration
done Moodle student, right here is just migrating
every single thing into a database of admin
of DRF. That is, that is what we want to see.
So now that we have done migrated, let's go
back into the serializers, that fewer. So
now we need to import the serializers from
the rest framework. And we also need to import
the post model from the models.py file. And
after that, we can create a serializer for
our post model by specifying only some fields.
So first of all, let's do from rest framework.
Import serializers. So now this is how we
import the serializer. So we can use it, just
like the way you use forms in Django. From
Django dot forms, import forms or something
like that. That's just where we import the
serializers. So let's also import that module
in which you want to use so from dots models,
imports, students. No, we have these two things
imported, we're just going to first of all,
create a serializer class for that student.
So say the class will be student serializer.
And then we're gonna do from the serializers
dot model serializers. So as you can see,
it's quite similar to the form where we just
have like, if it was a fun one to use, we
can say student form, and it will say forms
on Moodle, very similar, if you're used to
using the Django forms, you definitely definitely
understand this. So knowledge is our class
meta, under specify, specify the model loaded
with the student, and then the fields. So
the fields, let's make it a total. Let's see,
let's just take two, so we just want the name
and then the age. So these are just the two
fields want to use in this serializer. Now
it is that easy to specify a serializer to
configure by any word you want to use. So
now let's head back to the views.py file.
So right here, right here, we're gonna import
our post serializer and our post model. So
to do that, let's just say from that serializers.
Reports, student. So I've already made a mistake,
I said from the serializers. I said, we are
going to put post serializer. But we are going
to put in post serializers why budget students
realize that we actually do have post, but
I'm just going to use the same post as like
a model, because that's what I use for examples
most of the time. So why wasn't a student
serializer right here, class students serializer.
So from serializers, which is DS, please make
sure we have that. From just serializers we're
importing the students serializer. Calm you're
good. So now that we have the students here,
imported, let's just import the students model.
So from the models, import students. So now
we also have that imported. Let's go me and
make sure that's correct. Student Yup, that
student. So now that we have those two things
important, let's create a POST method in our
test view class. So in this video class, we're
gonna create a POST method. So we can receive
data, just like in a form. So to do this,
we'll just add a function below in artists
with class right here. We'll say def posts.
Now this is going to be a post not to get
and then you just gonna take exactly the same
thing that should be self. Exactly the same
thing. And there's going to be self requests.
And then keyword. So now that we have that
was gonna spit for our serializer in a variable.
So this URI lives equals to sudents serializer
unreligious give it a data. So when we do
something like data equals to request. So
this is a request towards data. So when we
do something like this, or it means is the,
we actually want to use a form or want to
submit a detail something like this, we'll
say data equals request or data. So beneath,
we're going to see if serializer is valid.
So first of all, check if it's valid. What
we just want to do now is to say serialize,
a dot save just exactly the way we do in a
Django form, I'm always referencing to that
Django form, because it is very similar to
this. I said earlier, if you've worked with
Django form, before, you understand what's
going on right here. So serializer data. So
what I just did was, first of all, we specify
the serializer. But our serializer is this
student serializer. So normally, if one was
in a post, like, if you don't want to submit
a form, you can just remove this as a serialized
because students realize what I said, because
once you submit something like a form who
has to say data equals to request or data
it needs to get the data which is being posted
into this particular API view. So let me get
that we'll say he does realize that that is
valid. That means if all the values value
in blue are correct, just like we want to
collect an integer field, of course, we want
to have an integer field, if we're supposed
to call it an integer field, we have all character
food or Tex food, then that serializer is
not valid. So this is just checking you is
valid if everything we want, even if values
are correct. And if it's valid, we'll just
save it to serializer dot save. And then we'll
just return the response of that particular
data, which is awesome. So you know, just
like when you save a data, we just want to
show it back to us. So So data has been saved,
this particular data has been saved. But if
these don't happen, we'll just return a response
of an error. Sources serializer dot errors.
So that is it. So now, let's save this. And
then let's call and just roll our server once
again. So what I want to do now the server
is running. We want to test this particular
API in postman. So let me first of all, wait
for that to load up. So okay, that shouldn't
be done. Okay. So it says, module not found
no module named DRF. Project serializer. The
one this is saying is that if we come back
to our code indirim find a particular. Okay,
good. So what is the saying is that he didn't
find modules, the serializer that was the
serializer ndrf proach. So we're importing
this dot model dot serializer. We're supposed
to import it from you. But as you can see,
we were importing it for me. So normally,
we're supposed to use like the views dot view,
in our project, actually, we can still use
it in. In this place, no one is was using
the app, but because he's in the project,
we just need to do is to make sure that we
are bringing it in from yours. Let me just
say, from those D, F serializers. And then
from the d r f dot models, so we can just
save this and that should work perfectly fine.
So now let's see if our data renewed and then
it should run without any errors and good
so As we can see, everything runs successfully.
Now, as I said, Let's come back to our browser.
As I said, Now we need to test this API today
is an application called postman. So let me
open a new tab and show you to get a smile
you'll need to do is type download postman.
And then once you type that you just hit enter
such it. So postman is an application, or
software, anything you like to call it, which
is used for testing your API. So since our
app is doing production yet, or prigionieri,
production is on live on the web or something.
For some testing locally on our locals, we
can use this application code customer. So
right here is going to take you to the website,
we are going to download the code. So it's
going to automatically detect your voice.
So as you can see, it changed to Windows because
I'm on a Windows, download it just installed
like a normal app, or the wind installer,
most of 2008, you should be good to go. So
now that we have postman installed, I have
it open right here. Well, I just want to do
is to create a new tab right here. And then
we're going to test the API in which we just
created. First of all, I'm gonna come in here
and then copy. So I'll copy the URL, because
that's the URL I'm gonna be testing anyway.
So right here, I'm just gonna base This is
the URL I'm gonna be testing. And I want it
to be a POST method. So right here, I'm gonna
call into body. So and then I'm going to click
on form data. Now I'm going to input key.
So this key is where I want to submit. So
let's see, we'll come back into our VS code,
we come into our serializer, we can see that
the fields required a name, and age. So we
know that in our models name is a character
field and age is an integer field. So to avoid
any error, we need to make sure that we abide
by everything. So name, does give you the
value of admin. And then key, that is the
age range, just give it a value of 25. Now,
if we sent sending the request is our postman
works, it's gonna tell the API for you. And
then gauge so as you can see right here, name,
it gives us a response of this particular
data name, admin, age 25. But how do we know
that this particular data has been submitted
into Moodle? So what wants to know is, as
this data is really saved in our database,
for us to be able to do this, we need to check,
we need to open up our admin interface, and
set up our admin panel and then check our
database. So let's quickly do that. First
of all, let's go back in here, we're gonna
cut out of this server. So now that we are
out of the server, what I want to do is to
create a super user, so I'll say python manage.py.
Create super user. This is going to prompt
me to input my user name. And my email my
password, just like I'm registering for a
platform or for website does exactly the same
thing. So let's give it a moment to your,
so I'm just gonna say admin. I'm gonna leave
this blank. I'm gonna give it a password.
Yeah, bypass and good. So now let's run the
server. Again. That is running, we're gonna
come into our VS code. And in the admin, the
Pew II, well, just gonna first of all, import
from dot models, import students, and they
want to register that student in our admin
interface. So admin, side or register, students.
So now this will show light as we register
in admin panel. We're gonna check that in
a minute. Please make sure this is running
Good. Let's come into our browser as open
a new tab. Let's go to slash admin. So But
as quickly do that right now. And then login
using the admin info. Okay, good. So now we
can see the under DRF app, we have students,
if I click on me, we should have one objects
in there. So as you can see, we have want
to dance, which is admin. And we submitted
that from our API. We didn't create these
from this admin panel, or from our projects
or from our website. It's true, our API. Now
let's go test that one more time. So we have
this API, we have the name, alleges give you
something like admin two, and then admin two
is 27 years old. So now when I send, because
it gives me admin to 27 years old. Now the
reason why it gives me this is because if
I come back here in our code, we'll see that
I said that, if it's valid, it should save
that data. And it wants to save that data,
it should give us a response of serialized
data. So that means if that is successful,
the response I want to get is the data in
which was submitted. So if I come back to
postman, anytime I get the data I simple idea
I submitted it means that was successful.
So let's come into our admin panel, it refresh.
Now we have another one right here. So that's
how to submit from our API. Now, that is cool.
Now let's talk about serializing, the data
that is going out, and I mean, the get method.
First of all, we already have model registered,
we already have created a super user. Now
to use our get method, we're gonna come back
into our fear school. Now, what I'm saying
is, as you can see, this get method right
here, when we did it earlier is just a blank
data, just a normal dictionary, by in this
post method, in this post function, we are
using serialization, let's serializing our
data. So let's say want to also serialize
the data in this gate. Now all we're gonna
do, since we already have self request, argument
and keyword argument, we're gonna specify
a query set. So let's get rid of these panella
silica query sets. query set can be students,
those objects does all know what we can just
do because this serializer
can be equals to students serializer on the
water specified our query sets, and we need
to specify one more thing insane. Many equals
true. Now, the reason we need to specify many
equals true is because this query set is a
list of objects. So from this student module,
we're getting all the objects I want, what
I mean by object is right here, all the data
we have in this student database, the student
database or the object. So as you can see,
it is more than one is going to bring a list
does where we have to specify many equals
true items is more than one. So after specifying
the query sets in a variable, I just have
another variable named serializer, which is
taken from the students serializer. And I
pass in the query said, Alan, I have to tell
you that many is equals to true. Now if it
was just one data, but yeah, just one particular
object or something we can just put square
he said, was since is more than one after
many equals to true. So now that we have that
we cannot return a response of serializer
data. So when a user tried to, say this API
using a get method, it is going to return
a response of dcls other data. And this is
a list of the objects in the student model,
which is basically all the data in that site.
So now, let's save it. And then let's go test
our API once again. But this time around,
we're just testing we get so get. Don't need
to remember to remove this first of all, so
it doesn't see no knowledge of it sent. And
as you can see, it doesn't give me a crease
it lists of the data we have in our project.
So it gives them in a JSON format. Now if
you don't see this, this particular script
And then that is just a dictionary. But since
we see these two ever again, and curly braces,
which is not taking each of the data, now
we know that it's returning it in a JSON format,
which is the normal standard way of returning
API response or request. So that is what we
can do when we're talking about get serializing.
Our gets request. But as I said, in Em, I
talked about many equals true. But let's say
it's just only one data. How do we do that?
So first of all, since we have this query
set, which is all the objects, we know that,
oh, God has more than one. So first of all,
let's get one, there's only one of the objects
so we can say, student students, one shouldn't
be equals to queryset dot first. Now, what
this query said or fails does is that is going
to get the first object in these students
who do so writing serializer, which students
serializer. And then we remove many dots true.
And voila, passing the query set. Now, we're
just passing only the first student, which
is student one. So now, we can just return
a response or serialize the data. So let's
go on to sit once again, writing we're gonna
get so once we send, as you can see, just
gives us only the first one, the data, we
can easily serialize our data in the Django
rest framework. Now let's talk about authentication
in the Django rest framework. So what do I
mean by these authentication? Now, these authentication
is going to allow us to protect our API endpoint.
So we might have some API that we can just
allow anybody to use without authenticating
or without authorizing that user. That's fine.
Boom, I also have some API's, which we want
a user to, first of all be authenticated,
I want the user to have an API key or a token
or something before you can assess that particular
API. Just for example, we use the YouTube
Data API, it needs to provide an API key which
you get from your Google Cloud account or
something like that. So that API key is going
to be used to authorize you or want educate
you to be able to use the API. So let's do
something similar in this tutorial. First
of all, what we want to do is to come into
our coach, right here. In views, we're gonna
use something called permissions, these permissions
is from the rest framework. So if I say from
rest, underscore framework. That's permissions.
Import. So when I say the restroom of the
permissions inputs, we are going to get a
bunch of permissions on bunch of wanted dication
lists. So like I can use allow any. Now this
is quite self explanatory, when clicking allow
any just allows any access, this isn't strictly
required. But you could use an empty permission
class list just to be. So what this is just
saying is that you can allow anybody to use
this particular API. So let's also see another
one like, is authenticated. So you can see
we have is admin user is authenticated, to
dedicated or read only. So we have a bunch
of so is admin user does also say for display
explanatory doesn't be an admin user before
the person can access the API, or is authenticated,
this is the one we are going to talk about.
So the user has to be authenticated into this
application. Before we can give the user the
chance before you can give the user the way
or something to be able to use our API. So
now let's import is authenticated. This one.
So now that we have that imported, we can
use it in our test view. Plus, to do this,
we can just add the code right here. So let's
say before any of the functions, let's just
add a variable named permission classes. Now
these permission classes is going to give
us like the permissions we want to collect
before a user can access any of these. So
most users on dedicated, can anybody just
access it, mostly be an admin user, whatever.
So there's gonna be a tuple. And then we'll
say is authenticated want the user to be authenticated?
Let's give it like that. So we only want authenticated.
Now if you want allow any damage anybody,
you can also just leave it blank like this.
This just means that anybody can access it.
Or you can just remove that. Anyhow, you want
to do so by using dedicated means the user
needs to be on dedicated before, you can use
it. Now let's save it and try something. If
we come into postman, and then we just sent
is gonna throw us an error. So as you can
see, okay, this is not the arrow we are looking
for. So this is just saying that our host
is not running. So let's come in here. So
it's running right now. Let's try that again.
So it's gonna give us a notification arrow.
Good. So it says detail. authentication credentials
were not provided. So now as you can see,
it requires us to be authenticated to provide
some authentication token or something before
it can give us access to URLs to our API's.
So now to be able to, to set up this authentication,
we need to come back into our code. And in
settings.pi, we're gonna scroll all the way
to the bottom. On the right here, we're gonna
say wrists. All the scuff free work should
be equals to column braces. And then who said
defaults. I'll just go on to education underscore
classes. Now, what we need is a square bracket.
And then you say rest. Now this should be
in small caps, rest, underscore framework.
authentication, token, authentication, this
is what we need. And then now we can save
this. So we can create this file. And then
now that we have now to use this rest framework,
we also need to actually add something, let's
go back to that settings to the installed
apps. So screw up. And then in the installed
apps, we want to add rest framework. So as
you can see, we already have rest framework
added on to this rest framework, dots fourth,
talking, so that is different. And then we'll
just save it to read for a month or two. Okay,
now we can quit it. Before we continue, we
need to run migrations. So let's opt out of
this server, Python manage. py make migrations
to after making migrations, no changes detected,
actually. So they're just wanting to spy migrate.
So this is going to migrate to the rest framework
dot auth token into our database, which Kathy
are talking or talking out. Okay. Ledger's
roll our server back. Actually, I don't want
to run the server back. So let's quit it out,
I want to do one thing. So first of all, I
want to flush all the data we have in this
our database. So we can, like show up can
show you how to create a token for each user.
So now we still have a user, let's flush every
single date. So say my UI flush. So this is
going to flush all the data we have in our
database, just click Yes. And then done. So
now we don't have any user, if I come in here,
I should actually be given an error that I'm
not dedicated or something. So okay, it can
repeat because there's no running. Both Normally,
the admin is deleted. Now want to create another
super user, a new super user, say python manage.py.
Create a super user. So right now, it should
prompt me to input user name. So user name,
leave that blank. Why good? So now we have
that created. Now, let's run our server back.
So let's give it So if we come back here now
into our server, so it asks us to log in again,
because we flushed out the data at first.
So, logging, good to come to the home, you're
gonna see now that I have odd talking up,
and they Nandita are talking Moodle. So this
is what we just did. So a good way to create
a token for user, one easy way is to just
come into our command line is up to the server
again, and same Python, manage dot P, y, d,
r f, underscore create underscore token, we
just pass in the user name. So this is going
to create a token for whatever user name we
passing. So let's wait for that is going to
give us a token right now. And it's also going
to save it in the host. Okay, so as you can
see, it gives us this token, just copy that.
And if we come in here, and it's refresh on
this model, we're gonna see that we're gonna
have one object. Okay, so let's first of all
run our server back, before we go test it
out, just to make sure everything is working.
So now let's hit refresh on this token. Now,
you can see now that we have that token right
here, the same thing starts with B and with
a C, A, B, and with a C, for the admin user
and created and this time, so this is what
we are, you can easily create a token for
a user. Now this user as a token, let me now
show you how you can use this talking in postman,
so you can authenticate. So normally, we're
just gonna come into our postman to authenticate
using de-stocking, what we just want to do
now is to go under authorization. And then
let me first of all, put this down a little
bit. So the type, we want to change this type
to API key. So it's giving me this because
I've tested some earlier before. So let me
just show this on step from scratch. So the
key, the default key for Django shouldn't
be authorization, authorization, and the value
you're going to write is going to be talking
and then followed by that particular token,
which was created for the user just talking,
which is tempting as the stalking. So let's
go back to postman. So right here, now, we
need to make sure that we're adding this to
the Edit notes to query parameters. Let's
bring this up a little bit. And it said, so
now, it doesn't tell us now again, that credentials,
tightknit some authorization credentials.
As you can see, it gives us a JSON response.
It says name is blank age is not all this
is because remember, we flushed our database
earlier. So that's given us know if we have
something in our database is obviously going
to show that to us. That's how you can easily
authorize or authenticate in your Django rest
framework. Well, now you know that let's say
you are using an external framework, like
you want to use react or something in this
your project, you don't want it to you can't
do this manually, like I just saw, we had
to come here to type by tomando spy DRF grade
token admin, before we were able to generate
a token for this user. We can't do that for
everybody on our platform, we want it to be
automated. I mean, that is the main purpose
of programming, right? So what we are just
going to do is to send details of the particular
user, so its username and password are going
to send it to our application and is automatically
going to generate the token or show us that
okay. So first, we're able to introduce are
gonna come into VS code, Amanda URLs A p y,
we're gonna say from rest framework.us talking.
Here, this one, those of us want to import
obtain of talking. So what this is going to
do is we don't need to create a new view in
views of UI. So this is a default, built in
view, which is from the rest framework that
are talking. So it allows us to just send
user's credentials, and then it obtains the
authentication token for us. So now let's
add a new path. Let's give a comma, path.
And then right here once the API slash talking,
slash, and then it'll give you that obtain,
or stoking. And then I'll give it a name of
something like obtain. So now that we have
that, we can test our API. So first of all,
let's copy this. Let's go back to postman,
to what wants to do is to open a new tab.
And then let's set this to post. And then
let's give it slash API token. And then right
here are gonna come into body form data. And
then we're gonna use the key of user name
is going to be the user name, which is admin,
and then a key of password. And then this
password, I'm gonna leave it blank, because
I don't want to show any password in this
video. But once you just put the password
of that particular user on it st is going
to show you the authentication token for that
user, basically. So that is how you can do
the magic also access this from your code,
you know, you can do something like send in
a request to this particular page, and then
getting the authentication token. So that
is how we can easily authenticate a user in
Django rest framework. So I really hope you
understood everything we did in this video.
I hope you go through the concepts of the
Django rest framework. I hope you understood
API's or Europe you now know about serializers.
I hope you now know about authentication in
your Django rest framework project. So guys,
that's going to be all for this rest framework
tutorial. I really hope you enjoyed it. And
if you did, please don't forget to smash the
like button and subscribe.